MEMBERS OF THE SUPPORT CAN COME
TO ROOM FORTY TWO A TO WE WILL
GET STARTED ON TODAY'S BUDGET
TO FOR COMMITTEE HEARING.
TEST
ONE TO ASSISTING ON. CHECK
CHECK OKAY LET'S GET STARTED
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME ASSEMBLY
SUB FOR ON STATE ADMINISTRATION
I BEEN ASKED READ SOME FOR PO
PROTESTS INTO HERE TO HELP
INSURE THIS OF A HERE. WHILE
ALSO ALLOW FULL ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION FOR THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM TODAY WE ARE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH TWO WE HAVE WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING. AND CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS OF
MINIMAL CONTENTION OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP SIX
FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER INTO LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK. THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I WILL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH. THE MICROPHONE. I
WILL ASK THE PUBLIC TO RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
pCOMMENT YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DOESN'T THINK UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING.
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO TWO
PEOPLE AT A TIME. THE PANELISTS
ON THE AGENDA. AND L. A. ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT. IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING. PLEASE SEND YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO BUDGETS OF
FOR. AT ASM DOT CA. DOT G. OVIH.
OKAY. WE ARE GOING TO GET
STARTED- WITHOUT QUORUM. BUT
FOR THE MOMENT MEMBERS TODAY
OUR GOAL IS TO HEAR A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSALS
AND TO LEAVE ADEQUATE TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE MAY
REVISION PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN A NUMBER OF
AREAS OF IMPORTANCE MANY OF
WHICH FALLS UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE SOME OF THESE
ITEMS MERE PROPOSALS WE HAVE
HEARD AND CHAMPIONED IN THE
PAST AND QUITE A FEW OF THE
PROPOSALS ARE NEW. THE ITEMS
VERY IN THE AMOUNT OF DETAIL
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION AND
OVERSIGHT TO THAT END WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
HEARING FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THESE PROPOSALS. BUT WE ARE
ALSO COGNISANT OF OUR
LIMITATIONS AND FULLY VETTING A
RECORD BUDGET THAT WAS JUST
RELEASED ON FRIDAY WITH MUCH OF
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
PENDING AND SLOWLY. ROLLING
OUT. THE FOCUS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY WILL BE A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR REACTION FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY NOTES FROM
THE PUBLIC. THAT IS ABLE TO
COMMENT ON THE BUDGET FOR THE
FIRST TIME. TODAY FOR MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE PLEASE KNOW
THAT WHILE TODAY'S FOCUS IS A
GENERAL OVERVIEW OF NEW ITEMS.
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF IS
CONTINUING TO FULLY VET THESE
PROPOSALS AND IS AVAILABLE TO
YOU AND YOUR STAFF RAINY
QUESTIONS FOLLOWING TODAY'S
HEARING. THANK YOU FOR
UNDERSTANDING AND WITH THAT
LET'S GET STARTED WITH THE
FIRST GROUP OF PROPOSALS THOSE
RELATED TO HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. OUR PANELISTS
TODAY INCLUDE. AB SECRETARY LEW
DISCUSSED ON METIS. AND LOTUS
MORALIS FROM THE L. A. L. LET'S
BEGIN. SECRETARY CASTRO. MAY BE
ON MUTE OH WAIT ONE SEC. SORRY
YOU HEAR ME YES ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON AS CHAIR. IN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST A TESTING
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU FINE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
SECRETARY OKAY RIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH AGAIN THANK YOU SHARE
AD HAVE A YOUNG MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT. GOVERNOR NEW SUMS
CALIFORNIA COME BACK PLAN ON
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS. THE
CALIFORNIA COME BACK PLAN BUILT
ON THE PRINCIPLE THAT AN
EQUITABLE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
MUST INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AND HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS. THE BUDGET PLAN
PREVENT EVICTIONS AND
DISPLACEMENT BY PROVIDING
DIRECT RELIEF TO RENTERS.
LANDLORDS HOMEOWNERS THROUGH
EXPANDED RENTAL ASSISTANCE FOR
CLOSURE PREVENTION. AND
HOMEBUYER DOWN PAYMENTS OF.
IMPORTANTLY A CENTERFOLD OF THE
COME BACK IS ON CALL. THE PLAN
PRESENTS A BOLD PROPOSAL TO
HOME KEY WHICH IS BEING A DOT
BY STATES AND ALSO BY OUR
FEDERAL PARTNER AS AN- MODEL.
IT ALSO ADVANCES A COMP. IN LAW
PRONG OF. THAT'S TO A FOUND
HOME OVER TO FIVE. WITH THE C.
S. H. AND THE HEALTH AND HUMAN.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY WORKING CLOSELY.
COLLECTIVELY THESE APPROACHES
ADVANCED THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
TO EXPAND HOUSING ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY. THROUGH
INCREASES IN HOUSING VOLUME. I
COUNT ABILITY AND FACILITATING
EXPEDIENCY ALL WITH A FOCUS ON
EQUITY. THE MAY REVISION LAYS
THE FOUNDATION FOR AN EQUITABLE
RECOVERY AND BUILT UPON THE
INVESTMENTS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PACKAGE OF
NINE POINT THREE BILLION IN THE
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE OF TWELVE
POINT FOUR BILLION. THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS ADMINISTERED THROUGH PCS
H. AND IT'S THE APARTMENTS.
FIRST BEGINNING WITH HOUSING.
TO HELP STABILIZE CALIFORNIA
TENANTS THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
TO EXPAND THE CURRENT RENT
WOULD BE PROGRAM TO COVER UP TO
A 100% OF BACK RENT AND FUTURE
RENT TO USING AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN FUNDING TO KEEP FAMILY'S
HOUSE. IN ADDITION TO THE
COMBINED FIVE POINT TWO BILLION
AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES TWO BILLION
IN UTILITY ASSISTANCE. AND
TWENTY MILLION FOR LEGAL AID
SERVICES FOR TENANTS IN
MORTGAGE LENDER HOLDERS. TO
PREVENT HOMEOWNERS FROM GOING
INTO FORECLOSURE THE U. S.
TREASURY HAS ALLOCATED ONE
BILLION IN OUR FANS WHO ARE
HOMEOWNER ASSISTANCE WHICH WILL
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY. THIS WILL PROVIDE
MORTGAGE RELIEF AND PRINCIPLE
REDUCTIONS TO HOMEOWNERS WITH
MORTGAGE DELINQUENCIES. A
COMBINATION OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND HOMEOWNER RELIEF
PRESENTS A HOLISTIC SET OF
SOLUTIONS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THIRTEEN
THOUSAND FAMILIES ACHIEVE
HOMEOWNERSHIP THROUGH
CALIFORNIA FACED DOWN PAYMENT
DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS 61% OF THE HOUSEHOLDS
THAT WERE SERVED WERE BLACK OR
LATINO CONTRIBUTING TO THE
NARROWING OF THE STATE'S WEALTH
GAP IN REDRESSING PAST RACIAL
INJUSTICES. THE MAJOR REVISION
PROPOSES TO ADD A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND THE
STATE'S FIRST TIME HOME BUYER
PROGRAM AND TO HELP BETWEEN
FIVE TO EIGHT THOUSAND MORE LOW
TO MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES.
THIS WILL BE PAIRED WITH AN
ONGOING STRATEGY TO INCREASE A
ROBUST PRESENCE IN
DISADVANTAGED AREAS INCLUDING
EXPANDING RENDON NETWORKS AND
LEVERAGING THE BUILDING BLACK
WEALTH IN HOUSING COUNSELING
INITIATIVES. I'D LIKE TO JUST
COSTA THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
HAVING SIGNIFICANT LEGISLATION
IN RECENT YEARS TO ADVANCE
HOUSING- AND ALSO TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
BUILD ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
OR EIGHTY YEARS. IN RECOGNITION
OF THE NEED TO EXPAND TO
LUCIA'S FOR ANYTHING YOU
FINANCING HOW MUCH OF A HAS
BEEN IN THE PROCESS OF STANDING
UP A PROGRAM USING NINETEEN
MILLION IN EXISTING FUNDS TO
CATALYZETHE PRODUCTION OF
INGREDIENTS. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO EXPAND THIS PROGRAM
BY ADDING EIGHTY ONE MILLION TO
HELP LOW AND MODERATE INCOME.
HOMEOWNERS FINANCE EIGHTY YOU.
INCREASING THE SUPPLY OF
HOUSING WHILE ALSO FURTHERING
OUR GOAL OF HOUSING EQUITY. IN
THINKING. IN THINKINGABOUT THE
HOUSING SPECTRUM THIS PROPOSAL
DOES NOT OVERLOOK A SEGMENT OF
OUR MOST ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING A TOTAL
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR ATVS
MY CURRENT FARMWORKER HOUSING
TO ADDRESS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND MAKE HEALTH AND SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS AND TO ENHANCE THE
LIVABILITY OF THESE COMMUNITIES.
WITH A FOCUS ON PRESERVATION
THREE HUNDRED MILLION AND OUR
PIPELINES ARE ALSO BEING
PROPOSED TO SUSTAIN THE
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS OF
HEVS LEGACY PROJECTS AS
AFFORDABILITY COVENANTS EXPIRE.
AND AS THESE PROJECTS BECOME AT
RISK FOR TRANSITIONING INTO THE
MARKET RATE HOUSING INVENTORY.
IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST
YEAR DEMAND FOR FINANCING TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS
OUTPACED FUNDS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN MANY PROJECTS HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO SECURE THE
FINAL FINANCING NECESSARY TO
START CONSTRUCTION. BY
INVESTING IN AT ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION AND ARE FOR FUNDS WE
WILL BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF MORE THAN SIXTY
THREE HUNDRED UNITS. OF SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS ARE THAT ARE ALL
AFFORDABLE. MY MOVING QUICKLY
PROJECT WILL ALSO AVOID
DEVELOPMENT DELAYS AND
ACCUMULATING COSTS. WE CONTINUE
TO WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
AND OTHER LOCAL PARTNERS TO
LEVERAGE STATE EXCESS LANDS AND
TO REPOSITION THE SITES FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. WITH AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY FIVE MILLION
AND ARE FOR FINANCE H. ET WILL
SCALE UP STATE EXCESS LAND
DEVELOPMENT WITH FUNDING FOR
VITAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND TO
MAKE HOUSING PROJECTS VIABLE.
ADDITIONALLY THE CALIFORNIA
COME BACK PLAN ALSO PRIORITIZE
PRIORITIZE THIS PART STATE GOAL
OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES.
WE KNOW THAT PLANNING WITH
COMMUNITIES AROUND SUSTAINABLE
LIVING IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MEETING THIS GOAL. TO ASSIST
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ADVANCED
COMPREHENSIVE PLANS THAT BRING
CLIMATE TRANSIT AND HOUSING
INVESTMENTS TOGETHER. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN FINES HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED FOR PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS TO
PROVIDE REGIONAL ENTITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE INFO
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND
PLANNING INITIATIVES. THESE
COMBINED HOUSING INVESTMENTS
COUPLED WITH THE STRATEGIES AND
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS WILL LEAD TO
UNLOCKING AT LEAST. FORTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW HOUSING UNITS AND
HOUSING PLACEMENTS. NOT LET ME
SPEAK WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- HOMELESSNESS. ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS COMPREHENSIVELY IS
THE CENTRAL FOCUS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S CALIFORNIA COME BACK
PLAN WITH A COMBINED TWELVE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS FOR
A UNIFIED MULTI AGENCY APPROACH
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. THE
PLAN PROPOSES HOUSING SOLUTIONS
FOR THE FULL DIVERSITY OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND WITH A FOCUS
ON RACIAL EQUITY. THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES ABOUT SEVEN
BILLION FOR ACQUISITION AND WE
HAVE OF HOUSING INCLUDING
CONVERSION OF HOTELS IN VACANT
BUILDINGS THE INTERIM AND
PERMANENT HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THE PLAN
LEVERAGES THE SUCCESS OF LAST
YEAR'S HOME HE- IN JUST SIX
MONTHS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WERE
ABLE TO ACQUIRE NINETY FOUR
PROJECTS INCLUDING EIGHT SIX
THOUSAND UNITS TO HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AT A COST OF EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. THIS YEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION HOLE T. TWO
POINT NOW WITH ONE BILLION
TARGETING FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR AT RISK OF
BECOMING HOMELESS. I AM
PARTICULARLY EXCITED THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING A FOCUS
ON FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN THIS
IS A BOLD INITIATIVE THAT SEEKS
TO END FAMILY HOMELESSNESS BY
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN AND I KNOW
WE CAN DO IT. ASSEMBLY
HOMELESSNESS IS THE FASTEST
GROWING SEGMENT OF
CALIFORNIANS. WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OVER
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WERE
SERVED BY THE STATE'S
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE SYSTEM
THE TWENTY TWENTY. A DATA POINT
THAT WE ARE NOW ABLE TO HAVE
THANKS TO THE HOMELESS DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM THAT WAS
RECENTLY LAUNCHED BY THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL. THIS FOCUS
ON ENDING FAMILY HOMELESSNESS
WILL REQUIRE UP ORDINATED
APPROACH ACROSS THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH FEDERAL AGENCIES LOCAL
LEADERS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. IN ADDITION TO
THE SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING SUPPORT IN BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES FORTY
MILLION FOR ENDING FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGE GRANTS
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT HCFC. FIFTY POINT THREE
MILLION FOR EACH YEAR SEEK TO
PARTNER WITH CALTRANS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO MITIGATE SAFETY
RISKS ADDING COMPLIMENTS ON.
OPERATING AND TO ADMINISTER
TARGETED GRANTS TO LOCAL. THIS
INVESTMENT HONORS A FACT THAT
WILL PERMIT HOUSING IS THE ONLY
TRUE SOLUTION TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS THERE ALSO ARE
THOUSANDS OF UNSHELTERED
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE FACING
URGENT AND DANGEROUS CRISIS
SEES EVERY SINGLE DAY WE NEED
OUR SUPPORT. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ALSO CALLS ATTENTION
TO ACCOUNTABILITY. HCFC LAUNCH
H. H. THE I. S. THE STATE'S
FIRST STATEWIDE HOMELESSNESS.
LET'S NOT STATE AN ANALYSIS BY
COMBINING INFORMATION FROM THE
FORTY FOUR CONTINUE ARMS OF
CARE ACROSS THE STATE INTO ONE
SINGLE POINT OF ACCESS. THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION FOR HDFC TO
BUILT ON THE LEARNINGS FROM H.
YEAH YES AND TO CONDUCT IN
FRANCE GIVE ASSESSMENT OF LOCAL
HOMELESS NET SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND STATE FUNDED HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. THE ASSESSMENT WILL
PROVIDE A DETAILED. VIEW OF THE
RANGE OF SERVICES AND THE
STRATEGIES THAT ARE UTILIZED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND HELP
DETERMINE THE STATE INVESTMENT
ARE LINED WITH LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS RESPONSIVE AND- IT
WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
COLLECTIVELY THERE'S GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AROUNDTHE
PLANNING AND THE EXPENDITURE OF
HOMELESSNESS RESOURCES. FINALLY
AT THE STATE CONTINUES TO
RECOVER AND BOLSTER LONG TERM
EQUITY AND RESILIENCY.
CALIFORNIA COME BACK PLAN
CONTINUES TO BUILD UPON ITS
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU ALL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCALS AND
WITH SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IN C. A. S. H. AND
THAT'S DEPARTMENTS HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR SYSTEM
PARTNERS TO ACHIEVE GREATER
COORDINATION AND ALIGNMENT IN
BOTH HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY AND THE
DRIVE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
INVESTMENTS. IN CLOSING I'M
HAPPY TO SHARE THESE COMPONENTS
OF THE CALIFORNIA COME BACK
PLAN WITH ALL OF YOU AB I TRULY
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL LEAD TO
AN EQUITABLE RECOVERY THAT
POSITION AT THE STATE. AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE WORK WITH
TO ROAR BACK WITH STRENGTH AND
RESILIENCY. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR TIME.
I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP. AND NOW I'M JOINED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND MEMBERS OF MY TEAM TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
BEFORE WE CONTINUE LET'S
ESTABLISH QUORUM MR SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CORREO HERE TO HEAR COOPER-
LACKEY HERE LET'S AREA. I DON'T
KNOW I. ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MISTER
CHIP. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
LET ME FIRST JUST SAY TO MADAM
SECRETARY JUST APPRECIATE. YOUR
COMMITMENT IN OUR GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THE
MORAL CRISIS OF THE DAY BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC AND DURING AND
AFTER WHICH IS HOMELESSNESS- I
THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT.
THIS HAS BEEN A SITUATION
THAT'S BEEN COMPLETELY
UNTENABLE AND AS THE GOVERNOR
SAID THIS BUDGET SURPLUS IS A
ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO INVEST AND MAKE MAJOR
PROGRESS TO END HOMELESSNESS
AND A VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
ALSO WANT TO COMMEND THE
ADMINISTRATIONFOR. YOUR
SUCCESSES AROUND HOME KEY WHICH
REALLY HAS BEEN- AN INCREDIBLE
MODEL- AND THE FOCUS IN THIS
BUDGET AROUND FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS I THINK WE HAVE A
REAL CHANCE OF BEING ABLE TO
NOT JUST REDUCE THOSE NUMBERS
BUT HOPEFULLY. AFFECTIVELY
ENDED HI IN THE COMING YEARS- I
WANNA REYES MISTER CHEWING UP
SO SORRY MY APOLOGIES TO
INTERRUPT YOU BEFORE WE GO TO
YOUR QUESTION CAN WE HEAR FROM
THE ALLEY- FIRST ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU AT THE OFFICE OF THE
ONLY A PLACE. MISS MORALIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M THAT'S WHAT
I THAT'S WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
WRITING A FEW OVER ARCHING
COMMENTS ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
NAME REVISION HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PROPOSALS BEFORE
MAKING SOME SPECIFIC COMMENTS
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
CONTINUES TO RECOGNIZE THE
STATE'S HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AND HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN A PRIORITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
AND ARE WORTHWHILE GOALS. IN
THE MAY REVISION THE GOVERNOR
SETS A GOAL TO FUNCTIONALLY AND
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS AND
FIGHTERS TO DO SO HE INTRODUCES
OVER THIRTY FIVE PROPOSALS THAT
FINDING YOU AN EXISTING PROGRAM
ACROSS THIRTEEN STATE ENTITIES
AT THIS TIME IT'S UNCLEAR TO US
HOW THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S ME REVISION
PACKAGE WORK TOGETHER TO MEET
THE SCHOOL. ADMINISTRATION DOES
NOT IDENTIFIED IN TROUBLES TO
MEASURE THE STATE'S PROGRESS
REPORTS FUNCTIONALLY ENDING
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS IN FIVE
YEARS IN ADDITION BALLOT
HOMELESSNESS IS ONE DIMENSION
OF THE STATE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS THE LEGISLATURE WILL
HAVE TO ASSESS IT THERE IT HAS
OTHER GOALS IN OTHER DIMENSIONS
OF HOMELESSNESS AND WHETHER OR
THE STATE. BUDGET CAN ADDRESS
THOSE GOALS AS WELL. THE
GOVERNOR'S AND MAJOR HOME AND-
FOR STARTING NEXT. EXISTING
STATE PROGRAM TO BUILD. HOUSING
AND- OF THE STATE THE AT. THAT
OFFER HAPPINESS. RECENT BUDGETS
HAVE PROVIDED FLEXIBLE FUNDING
DIRECTLY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SO THEY CAN ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND NOT FROM
COMMUNITIES. THE MAIN REVISION
DOES NOT INCLUDE THIS TYPE OF
PROPOSAL. THE LEGISLATURE WE
WANT TO AFFECTED IT'S
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS CHANGE
FOR WHAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
NINETEEN FLEXIBLE HUNTING FOR
LOCALS AS A FEATURE OF THE.
STATE ALMOST MISTER SPOCK'S. TO
WRAP UP MY GENERAL COME. IN THE
PAST TRUMP RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISH A PLAN
FOR ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS THE
GOVERNOR'S MEMBERS ARE LAID OUT
ONE POSSIBLE APPROACH. NOW THE
LEGISLATURE SIGNED IF IT WANTS
TO ADOPT THE GOVERNOR STRATEGY
OR MAKE SOME MODIFICATIONS.
TURNING TO SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
IN THE IN THE GOVERNOR'S NAME
REVISION. MANY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S UNIVISION PROPOSALS
REQUIRE LEGISLATION TO
IMPLEMENT. WHICH IS NOT YET
AVAILABLE SOME OF THE KEY
QUESTIONS THAT REMAIN THAT
COULD BE ADDRESSED THREE TBL
ARE WHICH PROJECTS IN EACH
CITY'S BACKGROUND WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. PORTABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION BACKGROUND
MUSCLE. AND HOWARD LESSONS
LEARNED OVER THE LAST YEAR
ABOUT HOME HE INFORMED HOW THE
PROPOSED TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING WOULD BE
USED. AS AN EXAMPLE HOW COULD
YOU FACILITATE THE USE OF A
DIFFERENT MIX OF PROPERTIES AS
HOTELS AND MOTELS MAY NOT BE AS
READILY AVAILABLE FOR USE TO
COMPETE. AT THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC SUBSIDE. IN OTHER
CASES. SUCH AS THE REGION EARLY
ACTS. PLANNING PRO PROPOSAL.
UNIONIST THAT MISSION INTO. IT
INTENT OF. ALIKI METHOD. THAT
MINISTRY. FOLLOWING THE
ADOPTION OF THE PROJECT RATHER
THAN TO KEEP OUT THIS APPROACH
WOULD LIMIT THE LEGISLATURE'S
AUTHORITY. IN ADDITION ALLEGE
HAS MADE MAJOR INVESTMENTS TO
EXPAND THE STATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STOCK IN RECENT YEARS
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED NEW
PROVISION ON PROPOSES
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATIONS IN THE
SPACE AS PART OF THE REVISION.
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE TO
DETERMINE HOW IT WILL PRESERVE
THESE GAMES IN THE LONG TERM.
IN PARTICULAR IN THE CASE OF
HOME HE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE PLANS FOR
OPERATING SITES FOR FIVE YEARS
HOW HOME HE CITES WILL BE
OPERATED AND MAINTAINED BEYOND
FIVE YEARS IS UNCLEAR. THIS
UNCERTAINTY COULD MAKE SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HEADED INTO
PARTICIPATING HOME KEY AND
COULD CREATE THIS WILL
PRESSURES FOR THE STATE AND THE
LONG TERM TO PROTECT HUNKY
INVESTMENTS. THE STATEMENT WANT
TO CONSIDER HOW IT BALANCES
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS AND
OPERATING. COSTS WITHIN THE
HOME KEEP PROGRAM. THE STATE TO
EXPAND DRIVE ADDICTS AND
PROPOSED. PROPOSED WITHIN THE
TWO. ON ESTABLISHED AMERICA. IS
ALSO CLEAR IN MANY CASES THE-
FUNDING IS MANY. OF BHAGWAT
QUESTIONED PROVIDED FOR THESE
PROGRAMS IN THE PAST IN
PARTICULAR THE THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN FUNDING ACROSS TWO
YEARS FOR HUNKIEST SIGNIFICANT.
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR THE
LEGISLATURE IMAGES TO ALLOCATE
A PORTION OF PROPOSED FUNDING.
THAT MORE CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH
THE EXPECTED CAPACITY IN
ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
LATER. THIS TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE ADDITIONAL TIMETO
MAKE HE POLICY DECISIONS ABOUT
ITS APPROACH TOWARDS
ADDRESSING. THE STATE'S HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES.
FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS RELATED
TO THE HOMELESSNESS. ACROSS
MANY DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS IT
WILL BE MORE CRUCIAL THAN EVER
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO SET
CLEAR EXPECTATIONS TO STATUTE
AND BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
ESTABLISHING REPORT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WILL ALSO HELP THE
LEGISLATURE EXERCISE OVERSIGHT
OVER THE STATE'S PROGRESS
TOWARD ADDRESSING. A HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGES IN
THE STATE THESE ARE JUST SOME
OF OUR INITIAL COMMENTS ON
THESE PROPOSALS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ANALYZE THEM. RIGHT
YOU WHEN YOU'RE STUCK ONE
PERMISSION IT'S TRAILER. BILL
BECOMES AVAILABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS ONE ISLAND TO
GET UP. MISS TWO THREE CONTINUE
YOUR QUESTION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AS I WAS MENTIONING VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE- THE GOVERNOR
FOR ON PROJECT HOME KEY IN THE
SIX RELAY TO THAT AS WELL AS
WHAT I DO UNDERSTAND IN THE MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS. THE FOCUS ON
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS GIVEN OUR
CHANCE TO LITERALLY AND THAT IN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS I WANTED TO
RAISE THREE SORT OF BIG
PICTURE- POINTS OF FEEDBACK
THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED FROM
AROUND THE STATE ABOUT WHAT
MORE WE NEED TO BE DOING. AND
JUST I ASK MADAM SECRETARY FOR
SOME COMMENTS OF THE FIRST IS-
THE CURRENT BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOCUSES ON FAMILY HOMELESSNESS
BUT WE ALL KNOW. THAT WHAT HAS
BEEN FRUSTRATING- OUR CITIES
AND HOMELESS ADVOCATES AND SO
MANY OF US IS THE LACK OF
PROGRESS RELATED TO STREET
HOMELESSNESS. WHO ARE TYPICALLY
NOT FAMILIES BUT SINGLE
INDIVIDUALS- SOMETIMES WITH
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
SUBSTANCE ABUSE CHALLENGES IN
OTHERS. AND FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A LOT OF- WHO
WHO REVIEWED THIS BUDGET IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT THIS BUDGET
IS FOCUSING ON WHAT WE SEE
EVERY DAY. IN OUR COMMUNITY SO
LOVE IT LOVE SOME THOUGHTS ON
STREET HOMELESSNESS. SECONDLY I
AS I'M SURE YOU'VE BEEN HEARING
FROM CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS. THE BUDGET
HAS INVESTED IN CITIES AND
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE AND
COUNTIES TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. TO SHELTERS
INTERM HOUSING AND RAPID RE
HOUSING THIS BUDGET DOESN'T
REALLY INCLUDE MONIES FOR THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND- WE'RE CERTAINLY
HEARING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ABOUT THE CHALLENGE. IN
MAINTAINING EXISTING SHELTER AN
EMR HOUSING SOLUTIONS UNDER HE
CAN HOP. I'M SURE YOU'RE WELL
AWARE OF THE THAT REQUEST FROM
THE BIG CITY MAYORS- IN THE
SPACE AND TO THE DESIRE FOR
MORE FLEXIBLE FUNDING IN THIS
AREA WANTED TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER THAT WAS A DELIBERATE
DECISION AND WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE ON ON THAT. AND THEN THE
THIRD BIG PICTURE QUESTION I
HAVE IS WE'VE HEARD FROM THE L.
A- ABOUT JUST THE FRAGMENTATION
IN OUR SYSTEM AND ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND I THINK. MANY
OF US WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A STEP
BACK BACK. IN MOVE FORWARD WITH
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
THAT FIRST STARTS WITH. A GAPS
IN NEEDS ANALYSIS UNDERSTANDING
IN EVERY JURISDICTION AT EVERY
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WHAT'S NOT HAPPENING.
MOVING FOR WITH REAL SHORT AND
LONG TERM PLANNING. ON HAVING A
LONG TERM STRATEGY TO ACTUALLY
AND HOMELESSNESS AND- THINKING
THROUGH ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
AS WE ARE ABOUT TO PUSH OUT
POTENTIALLY. AT LEAST TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS OR THANK YOU
FOR UP TO MANY OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE OR A HIGHER AMOUNT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
INVESTINGIN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THAT MONEY IS BEING PUT TO
GOOD USE AND SO LOVE SOME
THOUGHTS ABOUT. THIS DISCUSSION
AROUND A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH OF ANALYSIS PLANNING
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. SO I KNOW
THIS IS A LOT OF QUESTIONS IN
ONE BUT- SECRETARY FEW THOUGHTS
ON ANY OF THOSE TOPICS WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND AT ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES
CMPREHENSIVELY- I DON'T WILL
START OFF WITH A RESPONSE AND
THEN I WILL ASK OUR DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR HOMELESSNESS TO
AND ADD ADDITIONAL DETAIL. ON
THE FIRST OF ALL LET ME JUST
TRY TO CLARIFY THAT D. R.
TWELVE POINT FOUR BILLION THAT
IS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR- TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. IS
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON-
HOMELESSNESS INDIVIDUALS AND
SUPPORTING LOCAL EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS AND INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE ACCESSING THE HOMELESSNESS
RESPONSE SYSTEM- AND I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT ONE
COMPONENT- OF THE OVERALL- PLAN
IS. TO DEVELOP THAT WERE NEEDED
A COMPREHENSIVE AND MULTI
PRONGED STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS SO FOR
EXAMPLE OUT OF THAT THREE POINT
FIVE BILLION- THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED FOR HOME P. ONE
BILLION WOULD BE SET ASIDE FOR
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN- OF THE
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION THAT.
IS BEING PROPOSED TO ACCELERATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
OR OR SO IS BEING PROPOSED-
FOR- FOR FAMILY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS SO I SHARE THAT
AS AN EXAMPLE BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT- I WANTED TO CLARIFY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT. WE ARE
COMPLETELY I'M STILL VERY MUCH
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING-
HOMELESSNESS AMONG INDIVIDUALS
ADDRESSING- INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAT
ARE LIVING IN KATHMANDU- BUT
ALSO YOU KNOW RECOGNIZE THAT-
IT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE HAVE.
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN AND I
DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO CALL HOME
AND YOU KNOW I DO THINK THAT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COORDINATE WITH OUR- SISTER
AGENCY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES WITH LOCAL PARTNERS.
AND ALSO TO LEVERAGE A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE COMING IN FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OUT TO MAKE A REAL
DENT- IT HONEST- SECONDLY I
WILL ALSO MENTION THAT IN TERMS
OF. STRATEGY AND A PLAN TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AT THE
STATE- I AM PROUD TO SHARE
THAT. THE HOMELESS COORDINATING
A PLAN FINANCING COUNCIL JUST
TO TWO MONTHS AGO MAYBE THREE
MONTHS AGO ADOPTED A
COMPREHENSIVE. ACTION PLAN TO
PREVENT AND END HOMELESSNESS
THAT SPEAKS TO THE COMMITMENT
OF VARIOUS. STATE DEPARTMENTS
AND STATE AGENCY EAST AND LOCAL-
TO. SMOKE THE MEAT ON THIS- AND
SO WE KNOW VERY MUCH BUT THAT.
THIS IN OUR AGE- COUNCIL OR IN
OUR AGENCY ACCOUNT ON HOME.
WHICH IS THAT HM C- PAST THE
PLAY AND NOW HAS THE DATA
EIGHT. THE H. E. I. S. SYSTEM
TO BE ABLE TO DRIVE- THIS
ORDINATED APPROACH- INTO ALSO
THE LAND OF THE SUPPORT OUT TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES- AND THEN
WITH REGARD TO THE FUNDING- IN
THAT WAR- YEAH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AT TO SUPPORT HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS. IT IS THIS
YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE TO HAVE-
HAP IN FEET TALLER SUSTAINABLE.
AND THAT IT TO SOME YOU KNOW-
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS OR IN
SOME LOCALITIES AT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE BEING DEPLOYED AND
MADE. AVAILABLE TO ADVANCE A
LOCAL SOLUTIONS AND IN SOME
OTHER AREAS OUR TEAM IS
CONTINUING TO WORK CLOSELY TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE FOLDERS ARE
INVESTED INPUT TO SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL. I HAVE- SIGNIFICANT-
AND POSITIVE OUTCOMES- SO WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO MAYBE ASK
DEPUTY SECRETARY- ALLEY SEVEN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO WAIT. AND
THEN ADD ANY ADDITIONAL DETAILS.
THANK SECRETARY I THINK I WOULD
IF I AT A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL TO A OF THE PIECES.
AROUND HOMELESS- WITH THAT IS
QUITE A BIT ACT AND THEN THE-
AND BENNETT WELL IT A LOTOF
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. I'M VERY
ARE THE COMING HARMONIUM OF. OH
I'M SORRY I CAN ALSO TALK ABOUT
LOTTERY. GREAT RIGHT AND SO WE
JUST THINK I THINK THAT THAT
AND THERE'S QUITE A FEW PEOPLE
IN THE PROPOSAL THAT WILL
ACTUALLY DIRECTLY SUPPORT FOLKS
THAT ARE EXPERIENCING A
SHELTERED HOMELESSNESS. I THINK
THAT THE POTENTIAL THAT THE WAY
WE HAVE IT STRUCTURED IT IT'S
NOT AS OBVIOUS IN THAT AND THAT
MADE ME ARE YOU HAD AN OPEN
BOOK ON FIRST BLUSH BUT- DOUBLE
OF THOSE EITHER BUT I WOULD
JUST CALL OUT- BECAUSE WITH
THAT I AGREE MORE ON THAT THE
AGENT OUTSIDE AND THAT THE
BEHAVIORAL- HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE PIECES WE REALLY
DO YOU THINK WILL HELP FOLKS-
THAT THAT THREAT ARE COMING IN
FROM ST HOMELESSNESS THAT NEED
A LONGER TERM RESPITE BETTER
THINGS LIKE THAT. THAT WOULD
HAVE CALL OUT THAT IS THE IS
THE PIECE THAT WE DO THINK WILL
BE A SAFE LANDING SPOT FOR A
LOT OF FOLKS EXPERIENCING
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT THE HOUSING
DISABILITY ADVOCACY PROGRAM
THAT WERE IN THAT YES THAT'S
RIGHT BUT WE'RE ENCOURAGING AN
INCREASE IN THE PROPOSAL.
REALLY DIRECTLY UP- SUPPORTS A
LOT OF FOLKS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC FINANCIAL
PERFORMANCE YES- AND THEN THE
THIRD PIECE THAT I WOULD JUST
CALL OUT THAT IS NEW AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY QUITE EXCITED ABOUT
THAT AT THE END- REACHED YES
THE IS AROUND ARGUMENT EFFORTS.
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT MORE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE NOW
WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT MORE TO
LEARN THERE AND YOU REALLY WANT
TO ENCOURAGE AND SUPPORT-
LEARNING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND SO THOSE BOTH BUT
EXPERIENCE THAT WE INTEND THAT
THAT ARE PROPOSED IN THAT. IN
THAT- GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
REALLY ARE INTENDED TO GO OUT
TO COMMUNITIES WITH LARGER
ENCAMPMENTS HELP THEM FIGURE
OUT HOW TO RESOLVE THAT AND I
THINK AND STABLE WAY FOR FOLKS
MOVING EVERYONE INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING AND THEN TAKING THOSE
LEARNINGS AND REALLY I'M
SHARING THAT WITH THE ENTIRE
STATE I THINK YOU'RE GOING ON.
AND SO IS MY NEPHEW THAT IF HE
SAID THAT ARE A LITTLE EMBEDDED
WITHIN SOME OF THE PROPOSAL BUT
THAT WILL BE DIRECTLY
SUPPORTIVE UP. UP THERE
EXPERIENCING STREET. JUST TO
FOLLOW UP. I GUESS WHAT I DID
HEAR. TIED SAY I DO SUPPORT CAN.
MONEY CITIES AND- ARE FLEX. AND
THEN. DECIDE TO OF A MORE CA.
APPROACH OF TOLD FROM FOR
WITHIN THE MINISTER. THAT YEAR
YOU GOING TO REQUIRE. LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO REGIONAL
CAPS NEEDS ANALYSES AND MORE
LONGER TERM PLANNING. WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES- I AM
HOPING THAT WILL BE IN BUDGET
TRAILER THAT'S SOMETHING I WILL
BE LOOKING FOR VERY
SPECIFICALLY- WE DON'T HAVE TO.
IT LET'S HAVE A QUICK ANSWER
NOW. HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH YOU
AFTER THIS. HEARING ON THAT
BUT- VERY MUCH HOPE THAT THAT
WILL BE PART OF THE PICTURE AS
WELL- ONE FINAL QUESTION I KNOW
WE COULD TALK. FOR A LONG TIME
ON THIS BUT I JUST HAVE ONE
FINAL QUESTION WHICH IS- THERE
WAS A MENTION OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND WE SPENT AN
AWFUL LOT OF TIME BEFORE THE
END OF JANUARY. AROUND SB
NINETY ONE. AND AT THIS MOMENT-
WE HAVE POTENTIALLY FIVE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT CAN GO
OUT. AS FAR AS RUN RELIEF. OF
THE LAST REPORT WE GOT WAS THAT
AT THIS POINT ONLY FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION HAS BEEN APPLIED FOR
AND HOPING. OVER THE LAST WEEK
THAT NUMBER'S GONE UP BUT-
GIVEN THAT IT IS ONLY SIX WEEKS
UNTIL. THE JUNE THIRTIETH
DEADLINE WHEN ALL OF THE
CURRENT EVICTION PROTECTIONS
WILL GO AWAY- VERY MUCH ONE
UNDERSTAND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLANS ON NEXT STEPS AND- I'D
ENCOURAGE WOULD REALLY LIKE.
EVERYONE TO. START FOCUSING
SIGNIFICANTLY ON THIS OF JUST
HOW DO WE GET THE MONEY OUT AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. AND HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE THAT- WHEN THAT
DEADLINE COMES WE DON'T SEE-
VERY DIFFICULT CONSEQUENCES FOR
RENTERS- LOVE SOME THOUGHTS ON
ON WHERE THE CONVERSATION IS
WITH REGARDS TO- RENT RELIEF.
AND WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
STRUGGLING TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND I WILL AT. BEGAN
WITH THE A BRIEF RESPONSE AN
OVERVIEW AND THEN ASK A MEMBER
OF R. ICHIKI TEAM TO GIVE YOU
SOME ADDITIONAL SPECIFICS I BET
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENHANCE OUR BEAT
THE RIGHT RELIEF PROGRAM WITH
THE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS THAT ARE
COMING IN FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO WITH THE
ARE THE CHANGES THAT U. S.
TREASURY HAS PROVIDED- JUST
ABOUT A WEEK AND A HALF AGO WE
RECEIVED NOTIFICATION FROM U.
S. TREASURY. MAKING SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES THAT WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
INCORPORATING INTO THE
APPLICATION PORTAL THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL LEAD TO AN
APPLICATION THAT IS- MORE AND-
LESS EXPENSIVE OR LESS YOU KNOW
DANCE AS IT'S CURRENTLY AT. AS
A CURRENTLY YES I WE DO AT OUR
YEAH OF COURSE- OR NOT ONLY
SORT OF RELYING ON AN
APPLICATION PORTAL WE DO HAVE A
LOCAL PARTNER NETWORK. OF A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
ASK CLASSES STATE TO ENSURE
THAT THIS RESOURCE IS MADE
AVAILABLE TO TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS- A LOOK FORTINO TO
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ON. THE
THE BENEFIT UP TO ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT- FOR BOTH TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS I AND SO I'D LIKE TO
JUST SPEAK UP TURN IT OVER TO
AN ATV RIGHT YOU'RE A DOCTOR
VELASQUEZ OR- JEFF WILL BE
RESPONDING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM. SUPPLEMENT JEFFREY
ROSS. DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FEDERAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE IT
SHOULD BE. BOB SO FAR WE HAVE
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF.
ANALYSTS SAY SINCE REQUESTED OF
COMMON MORAL YES AND AS THE
SECRETARY AS MENTIONS- WE ARE
TRYING TO GO THROUGH VERY
COMPREHENSIVELY RIGHT OUT TO
SIMPLIFY THE APPLICATION BASED
ON THE LATEST TREASURY
GUIDANCE. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
ALL WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LANGUAGE. THAT WE
ARE PUTTING THE- INFORMATION
OUT IT IS NOT ALL THAT IT IS
REALLY. EASILY READ A VERY
SIMPLIFIED TERMS OF FOLKS
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR IT SO WE KNOW THAT. THAT
SHOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO HELP
MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS CAN GET
THROUGH THE APPLICATION PROCESS
TO COME IN AND SEEK ASSISTANCE
OFF BUT THEN AGAIN. WE ALSO DO
YOU KNOW THAT. THE STRUCTURE
THAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY IN PLACE
BOB WHILE IT. UP VERY OUT. FOR
TO BE ABLE TO GET LAUNCHED OF
THE- YEAR BOB GOOD PROGRESS
THAT WE'RE SPEAKING ALL YOUR
PERCENT PERSPECTIVE AND A 100%
GREERS- WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
THAT THAT WOULD LIKELY OPEN UP
THE DOOR MUCH MORE WIDELY. SO
THAT- WE WOULD START TO SEE THE.
EIGHT FLOW APPLICATIONS. AT THE
THAT WE GO YOU TO SEE OR EXPECT
THE DROPS. PRESHEAF FEEDBACK
AND JUST TO CLOSE- AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE I THINK THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS ANXIETY ON THE PART
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ABOUT. THE
CHALLENGES OF ACCESSING THIS
MONEY THEIR ARTICLES FOR
EXAMPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO ABOUT
HOW NOT A SINGLE PENNY AS YET
CALM FLOW TO MY CONSTITUENTS
WHICH IS A FUNCTION OF A NUMBER
OF THINGS BUT- I. HOPE THAT WE
CAN GET BRIEFED AND UNDERSTAND
IN VERY SHORT ORDER WHAT THE
PLAN IS GOING TO BE POST JUNE
THIRTIETH BECAUSE- TIME IS
TICKING AND WITH THAT OUR
MANAGER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND JUST A FOLLOW UP
IN TERMS OF THE TIME IS TICKING
AND ALL THESE VARIOUS DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS- HOW THE
DEPARTMENT WORKING ON A
COMBINED. GOAL OUT WHAT IS THE
COMMON GOAL AND HOW ARE ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND
DEPARTMENTS GOING TO BE WORKING
TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE THAT. THANK
ARE THANK YOU CHAIR- JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY WHEN YOU SAY
AND HOW ARE WE- AT WORKING
TOGETHER AT ARE YOU REFERRING
TO HEDT KELLY TO SAY INSTEAD OF
SAYING. WELL THERE'S A LOT OF
OUR IT'S A COMBINED EFFORT IN
TERMS OF ALL THE FUNDING THAT'S
BEING PROPOSAL VARIOUS
DIFFERENT- MEANS RIGHT. ALL IN
AN EFFORT TO END HOMELESSNESS
AND ACHIEVE A MEASURABLE GOAL
TO ENSURE THE PEOPLE HOUSE HAVE
HOUSING I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO
WHAT IS THE COORDINATED EFFORT
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING
AND HOW WILL WE ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY IN A MEASURABLE
GOAL OF SUCCESS. AS TO HOW WE
WILL GET THERE. YES THE GREAT
QUESTION ADD CHAIR AND- YOU
KNOW LET ME AND- JUST SAY THAT
THE AGENCY THE BUSINESS
CONSUMERS- SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY. HAS BEEN PLAYING A VERY
IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL ROLE AND
TERMS OF COORDINATING ALL OF
OUR HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
ANNOUNCEMENTS. I S. IF THE
SECRETARY OF THIS AGENCY AND
ALSO WITH A DEEP YOUR PASSION
AND- BACKGROUND IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH. A BEAT THE
LEADERS- BOTH BEING OUT THAT.
ART DIRECTOR OF H. T. V. THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALLAGY
SAYING- THE DEPUTY. AND
SECRETARY AND THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER WITHIN HDFC AND ALSO
BRINGING AND OF COURSE OF THE
PART IN THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING WHICH IS ALSO UNDER
AGENCY. ALONG WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF REAL ESTATE. I
AND I WORKING CLOSELY WITH-
THAT ARE YOU KNOW THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. SO MUCH OF
THE COORDINATION- CHAIR IS
HAPPENING THROUGH OUR AGENCY-
WE HAVE. AND ALSO INVESTING OUT
SIGNIFICANTLY AND ESTABLISHING-
DATA SYSTEMS THAT GIVE US A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE. AS
AN EXAMPLE THE HVAC. AS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE HEP RECENTLY RELEASED
AFTER HOUSING DATA VIEWER THAT
GIVES A LOCAL- COMMUNITIES THE
ABILITY TO SEE HOW THEY'RE
DOING IN TERMS OF MEETING OF
FAIR HOUSING GOALS. SO THAT
THAT EFFORT OF COORDINATION AND
INTEGRATION AND CONTESTING THIS
HAPPENING. I'M THROUGH V. M.
YEAH THE THROUGH OUR AGENCY
LEADING THAT WORK- AND I WOULD
SAY THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE VERY
MUCH- ONLINE AND SHARE IN TERMS
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
METRICS AND- BEING ABLE TO HAVE
BILLS AS PUBLIC METRICS OR-
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN SHARE
PUBLICLY SO THAT. WE ARE ALSO
NOT ONLY TRACKING OUR PROGRESS.
BUT ALSO I'M LOOKING AT AND
WHERE WE NEED AT LEAST. JOURNAL
TO OR NO WAY OF DOING I'M AT
WORK. THANK YOU HAVE A VARIETY
OF TO QUESTION AT THE FAR UP
BUT I ALSO WANT GIVE MY-
COLLEAGUES IN OPERA TO
QUESTIONS AND- JUST A REMINDER
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT WE ARE JUST
LEARNING ABOUT AS- AS WE TRY TO
GET THROUGH THIS. VERY
IMPACTFUL. HEARING OR WE HAVE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT ISSUE AREAS
MISTER LUCKY I TURN IT OVER TO
YOU. WELL THANK YOU AND- GOD I
HOPE I CAN BE HEARD ALIVE.
THERE WILL BE HEARD. YES I AM I
WANTED JUST TO SAY FIRST OF ALL
IT IS AN HONOR TO MEET YOU
MADAM SECRETARY AND I KNOW YOU
HAVE A HUGE RESPONSIBILITY. AND
I CERTAINLY RESPECT IT AND I
WANT TO JUST GIVE. A LITTLE
FOOD FOR THOUGHT IN A LITTLE
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE I. I'D
I'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE HOUSING FIRST
EMPHASIS- AND I THINK- HONKY
THE LANKY PROGRAM IS ONE OF
THOSE. AND I'VE I FEEL LIKE. OF
THE CERTAINLY. HOUSING IS A
CRITICAL FUNCTION. BUT THE I
BELIEVE THAT SOMETHING THAT IS
MUCH MORE POWERFUL AND- AND THE
AND THE MEASURE OF SUCCESS OF
ARE HOMELESS- EXPENSES. IS WHAT
PEOPLE SEE ON THE STREETS AND I
THINK ST HOMELESSNESS. HE HAS
THE BEST MEASURE OF HOW
SUCCESSFUL OUR PROGRAMS ARE.
AND I THINK ONE HAVING. THE
EXPERIENCE OF BEING A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONAL FOR
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS. ONE OF THE
WAYS WE DEAL WITH A LOT OF THEM
THE DYSFUNCTION IN OUR SOCIETY
MR LAW ENFORCEMENT I THINK IT'S
VERY UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE IT'S
VERY- IT'S VERY INEFFECTIVE.
AND IT'S VERY VERY TEMPORARY.
AND I THINK THE HOUSING FOCUS
IS ALSO TEMPORARY AND I THINK
WELL WHAT WE NEED TO TRY TO DO
IS TO SHIFTED. OUR OUR SERVICES
SUPPORT FIRST- BECAUSE WE AS AS
YOU KNOW THAT. A LARGE SHARE OF
OUR HOMELESS POPULATION. BATTLE
MENTAL ILLNESS ADDICTIONS AND
ADAPTIVE BEHAVIOR DISORDERS AND
I FEEL LIKE I DON'T SEE A WHOLE
LOT OF. BUNDY GOING IN THAT
DIRECTION AND I DON'T SEE A LOT
OF PLANNING GOING IN THAT
DIRECTION I THINK THAT THAT IS
REALLY. HOW WE GET AT THE HEART
OF THIS PROBLEM AND I THINK
PART OF THE REASON WHY WE DON'T
IS BECAUSE IT'S MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT. AND I THINK IT'S
TIME THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
SERVICES. ARE UNDER EMPATHIZED
AND I REALLY REALLY WOULD HOPE.
THAT WE WOULD- START FOCUSING
OUR ATTENTION ON THE DEMANDS OF
THESE PROBLEMS AND TO ACTUALLY
ADDRESS SERVICES FIRST SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE SUSTAINABLE. RECOVERY WE
CAN GET WE CAN GET SOMEBODY A
PLACE TO STAY BUT IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE UNLESS THEY HAVE.
THE SKILLS AND THE TOOLS TO
ADAPT. TO LIFE AND I'M HOPING
THAT- WE CAN SEE MORE FUNDING
AND MORE ORGANIZATION IN THAT
DIRECTION BECAUSE- IF IT
DOESN'T AND THIS PLAN IT'S HARD
TO SEE. AND I THINK THAT'S A
PROBLEM IT SHOULDN'T BE HARD TO
SEE IT SHOULD BE BALANCED WITH
THE WITH THE HOUSING. COMPONENT
AND SO THOSE ARE JUST MY
THOUGHTS YET YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER THAT IT'S JUST A
PERSPECTIVE I THINK IS VERY
VERY CRITICAL AND I HOPE THAT-
WE COULD SEE SOME ADAPT SOME OF
THAT TATIAN. TO THAT
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU. ANY
COMMENTS FROM SECRETARY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
FOR AND THE- RIGHT YOU NEVER
RAISING THE IMPORTANCE OF-
SOCIAL SERVICES WE YOU KNOW
COMPLETELY RECOGNIZE THAT ACT
IT IS A COMBINED EFFORT AND I
MAY ASK YOUR CHAIR- ALLEY A
SUDDEN OUR DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
HOMELESSNESS SHE JUST MAYBE
ELABORATE AND SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT MORE AND- TOWARDS THE
INVESTMENTS. THAT ARE COMING IN
THROUGH THE AGENCY TO HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- MOST OF THE SOCIAL
SERVICES AND HEALTH YOU KNOW
SERVICE INVESTMENTS ARE COMING
IN THROUGH- H. H. H. S. S. OUT
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AND SO- ALLEY DO YOU
WANNA GO HEAD IN CHINA AND-
AFTER THE OTHER. I'LL BE REAL
QUICK AND I WOULD SAY I THINK
THAT THERE'S A LOT. THAT WE CAN
ATTACK AROUND THE KILLING
PROPOSAL AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'LL GET I DON'T WANT TO MISS
IT AND WE CAN'T REALLY HEAR YOU
CAN YOU SPEAK A LITTLE LOUDER
PLEASE. YES SORRY I WILL DO MY
VERY. I WOULD JUST SORT OF
THING I THINK THAT THERE IS
QUITE A BIT WITHIN THE CALLING
PROPOSALS. THAT WOULD ADDRESS A
LOT OF THAT IS. A LOT OF THE
CONCERN YOU'RE SEEING. THAT
THAT I WOULD I WOULD. I WOULD
HAVE TO TAKE TO GET INTO MUCH
DETAIL HERE AND SPEAK FOR THAT
FOR THEM BUT- YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY AROUND SOME OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE PIECES THAT
WOULD INCLUDE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES. A LOT OF THAT THEIR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE EFFORTS THAT
ARE HAPPENING WITHIN BOTH THE
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS PART BUT
ALSO. YOU KNOW WITHIN CURRENT
FUNDING IS NOT JUST FOR HER
HOUSING AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE
THEY ALSO INCLUDES A LOT OF
IT'S A PART OF SERVICES. LIKE
THIS. I'M AND THEN WHICH WOULD
ALSO JUST CALL OUT BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S A SMALL PIECE OF IT
BUT I THINK ARE REALLY CRITICAL
ONE IS THERE'S ALSO A PROPOSAL
AND THEY'RE- OUT OF FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
ABOUT SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR
VETERANS THAT HIGHLIGHTED BY
HOMELESS ARE CURRENTLY
HOMELESS. THAT WOULD REALLY GET
A LOT OF THIS WORK TO DO SO
JUST. APPRECIATING VERY MUCH
THAT THAT WE COULD DO MORE AT
TEN FRAME AND FLAG THOSE
PIECES- BUT BUT. DO VERY MUCH
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE IN THEIR-
THANK YOU FOR. I WE WILL COME.
TO RIVER I KNOW THAT YOU AND I
HAD A- AS- A- MEETING OF. WEEK
OR SO AGO. WHERE SOME OF THE
SAME- RUSSIANS WERE RAISED IN
TERMS OF HOW DO WE ALIGNED.
WHAT WE SEE IN BUDGETS OF FOR
AND WHAT IS COMING OUT OF
BUDGETS UP TO THAT'S RELATED TO
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND MENTAL
HEALTH ASSISTANCE AND HELP
ASSISTANCE IN GENERAL FOR OUR
OWN HOUSE POPULATION. AS WE TRY
TO ALSO DO THE WORK NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
HOUSING SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO. MERGE THE TWO SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE AN OVERALL
PICTURE. AS TO WHAT THE
OVERALL- OUT RESULTS OF
MEASUREMENTS WILL BE. MISTER
COOPER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
ABILITY COMMITTEE FOR SEVEN
YEARS NOW WE TALK ABOUT THIS.
YEAH WE'VE GOT SIX POINT EIGHT
BILLION THIS BUDGET PREVIOUSLY
WE'VE SPENT OTHER TWO BILLION
OF HOMELESSNESS FOR- PROJECT
ROOM KEY AND HOME KEY.
INFALLIBLE MAKE YOU MISTER
LACKEY'S COMMENTS. IT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION IT. YOU NEVER
HEAR THE ISSUES DEALING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE WELL THE PRIMARY ISSUES.
YOU CAN GO TO HOUSING YOU WANT
THESE FOLKS DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY THE ABILITY. TO MAKE
THAT DECISION TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE IN ALL WANT TO MAKE IT
FOR THEM. I'VE NEVER HEARD
ANYONE FROM THE MISTRESS TALK
ABOUT CONSERVATORSHIP SOME
THESE FOLKS CANNOT MAKE A
DECISION. AND WHAT WHAT'S THAT
IS- THE JAILS HELD A LOT OF
FOLKS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS THEY
SHOULD NOT BE THERE. BUT I HAVE
SEEN IN THERE THEY'VE GOT OKAY
OR GOTTEN SOMEWHAT NORMAL ON
MEDICATION. AND NO ONE'S EVER
TALKED ABOUT THAT. MOST USEFUL
CANNOT MAKE THOSE DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES SOMEONE HAS TO MAKE
THAT. AND TOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION OR SOMEBODY
ELSE. RECOGNIZE THAT TAKE FULL
STEPS. THINGS ARE GONNA CHANGE.
OF THIS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN
THE PUBLIC IS HOMELESSNESS IN
DEALING WITH IT. WE'RE THROWING
A LOT OF MONEY AT IT. ARE WE
GONNA SOLVE IT I THINK.
SOMEWHAT BUT TO REALLY DO A
DEEP DIVE. INTO HAVE A HAVE A-
LASTING AFFECT. IN WE ADDRESS
THOSE. ISSUES WE'RE NOT GONNA
MAKE A SNIFF IMPACT WE SAID IT
TIME AND TIME AGAIN WE SAID IT
LAST BUDGET CYCLE WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND IT HASN'T CHANGES HIS
HOUSING HOUSING HOUSING HOUSING
THE PART BUT IF YOU'RE UNABLE
TO MAKE THAT DECISION ERRED
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY BECAUSE
OF WHATEVER IMPAIRMENT- IT JUST
DOESN'T WORK AND YEAH THIS
WRAPAROUND SERVICES IN THIS
INCLUDE IN THERE SOME MIDDLE
HEALTH AND SUBSIDIES BUT
NOTHING OF SUBSTANCE THAT
REALLY HELP THESE INDIVIDUALS
DO THAT IN. THE PUBLIC TIRED OF
THIS PUBLIC EXPECTS GOVERNMENT
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND THE
REALLY- AGREE JUST CASES YOU
SEE OUT THERE WE'RE DOING
NOTHING FOR THEM. AT ALL SO AT
SOME POINT OPCIONAL WAKES UP IN
THE ADMINISTRATION A. N. N. HAS
THE COURAGE TO DEAL WITH THAT
AND TALK ABOUT CONSERVATORSHIP
FOR SOME OF THE WORST CASE. THE
WIDER MEET ME ON THE STREETS
YOU KNOW SUMMERTIME IT'S HOT
NOW AND- IT'S JUST A IN JUST AS
WE'RE DOING THESE PEOPLE. SO
HOPEFULLY THEY MISSED AND SOME
TO SO TO DO SOME. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER ANNIE COMMENT
FROM. THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
THE WHITE HOUSE. OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND.
THIS IS CHRIS. CRYSTAL THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WOULD
LIKE TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS THE
ATTACKS REYES REGARD WE ARE ON
THE UP PERSON STRUGGLING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND OF THE
TWELVE POINT. REALLY DON'T
PACKAGE FORTUNATELY FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS WAS TARGETED
TOWARDS PERSONS WHO ARE ON
MULTIPLE POPULATIONS. IT'S
INCLUDES A TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONSORTIUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR THE HOUSING DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM- TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR HOME SAFE.
AND ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION. AND
THEN TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
FOR VETERANS SO WE DO HERE WHAT
MEMBERS ARE SAYING ME. WE
APPRECIATE THE IMPORTANCE OF-
REACHING OUT ALL ELEMENTS OF
THE HOMES. POPULATION IN UNDER
EARNING A SIGNIFICANT MONEY
DISBURSED. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT- MISTER NAZARIAN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. GOT IT GOT
THREE. QUICK QUESTIONS THAT I'D
LIKE TO FOCUS ON AT FIRST-
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY FOR
BEING HERE WITH US- AND- AND I
WANT TO FIRST LOOK AT THE.
LITTER ABATEMENT PROGRAM THAT
IS WELL OVERALL THE CALTRANS
SUPPORT DOLLARS I SEE THAT IN
THE EXPANDED CALTRANS
COORDINATION AND DRESSING CAN'T
MINCE ENCAMPMENTS THERE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT POTS FIFTY MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
ENCAMPMENT RESOLUTION GRANTS
AND THEN THE TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION FOR THE CALTRANS
ENCAMPMENT COORDINATORS POINT
PLAN. AND THAT IS A BIT OF A
SEEMS LIKE A SMALL RELATIVELY
SMALL AMOUNT GIVEN THE CONSTANT
AND CONTINUED NEED IN HAVING TO
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES
WITH- WITH ENCAMPMENTS THAT.
ARE VERY SIMILAR TO FAVELAS SO
THAT'S ONE BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE'S A FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
MILLION LITTER ABATEMENT
PROGRAM SIDE WANT TO.
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT HOW THESE DIFFERENT
FUNDS. ARE GONNA BE
COORDINATING OR WORKING
TOGETHER- SECOND. MANAGER I'M
HAPPY TO ASK ALL THE QUESTIONS
NOW OR KEEP IT ONE BY ONE. ALL
AT ONCE. SECOND IS THAT- YOU
KNOW THROUGH HAPPENED THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED A FEW YEARS AGO WE
HAD THE BENEFIT OF FLEXIBLE
FUNDING- FOR SERVICES AND AS
YOU CAN TELL FROM THE MYRIAD OF
COMMENTS NOW THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE EITHER BY. MR LACKEY THE
CHAIR OR OR MISTER COOPER AND
MR CHIU- WE CAN SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY ON THE HOUSING AND- BUT
THE NEED FOR INVESTING CRITICAL
AND SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
SERVICES IS WHAT'S GONNA ALLOW
US. TO GET OVER THE HUMP OF
DEALING WITH SYSTEMIC
HOMELESSNESS AND SO I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THE HAP COMMITMENT OR
FLEXIBLE FUNDING COMMITMENT. IS
GONNA BE THIRD- SOMETHING THAT
I'VE FOCUSED ON FOR MANY YEARS
NOW BEING IN THE LEGISLATURE
BUT I'VE ALWAYS LOOKED AT IT
FROM THE PRISM OF CAL- YES. AND
NOT MUCH FROM THE HOUSING
BUDGET BUT NOW I'M BRINGING IT
INTO THE HOUSING CONVERSATION.
GIVEN THIS ONE TIME OPPORTUNITY
OF MAKING THIS. GIVEN THIS ONE
TIME. SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
THAT WE CAN MAKE IS LOOKING AT
A SEISMIC AN EARTHQUAKE
RESILIENCY INVESTMENT-
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT. WE'RE TALKING
BECAUSE THE ABOUT PUTTING IN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO
HOMELESSNESS BUT ONE THING WE
CONTINUE TO LACK. IN OUR VISION
IS THAT WE ARE SITTING ON
EIGHTY THOUSAND VULNERABLE
HOUSING STRUCTURES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA EIGHTY THOUSAND.
THESE ARE THESE INCLUDE SOFT
STORY BUILDINGS AS WELL AS
OLDER BRICK BUILDINGS DUCTLESS
BUILDINGS THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
JUST ONE MAJOR SEISMIC ACTIVITY
AWAY FROM CRUMBLING DOWN AND A
SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY OF THESE
BUILDINGS ARE IN THE HOPES OF
THE BAY AREA AND GREATER LA
AREA WHERE. GEOLOGICALLY THAT'S
WHERE MOST OF THE SEISMIC
ACTIVITY IS AND SO GIVEN WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT AT THE
POTENTIAL- UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCE OF ONE MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE BRINGING DOWN A LOT
OF THESE BUILDINGS. AND THESE
ARE. THE POOR CONDITION
BUILDINGS THAT HOUSE THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. SO YOU
CAN JUST IMAGINE TO WHAT EXTENT
ARE HOMELESSNESS IS GOING TO
EXPAND OVERNIGHT SO MUCH SO
THAT FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO
ARIZONA STATE CONDUCTED A
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS EXERCISE
IN ANTICIPATION OF POTENTIALLY
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS. LEAVING
CALIFORNIA IN IN THE EVENT OF
AN EARTHQUAKE AND
REESTABLISHING THEMSELVES IN
ARIZONA- THAT THAT NEWS HAS
JUST STAYED WITH ME EVER SINCE
AND IT JUST STRIKES ME THAT WE-
WILL NOW HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT BUT I'M NOT SEEN.
RESILIENCY DOLLARS IN MAKING
SURE THAT THESE- THESE
VULNERABLE BUILDINGS ARE
ADDRESSED IN ADVANCE SO THAT
WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH A
GREATER NUMBER OF HOMELESSNESS
SO IF YOU CAN. PLEASE PROVIDE
RESPONSES TO ALL THREE
QUESTIONS I'D APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR SECRETARY HAD
ANOTHER COMMITMENT AND INTENT
TO HOP OFF AND BUT I WILL I
WILL TAKE IT. I DON'T THINK THE
FIRST ONE AND THEN MAYBE AND
OVERNIGHT APARTMENT OF FINANCE
NEEDS TV FOLKS FOR THE OTHER
TWO- RELATED TO THE ENCAMPMENT
PIECE- AND THE WORK THAT WILL
BEGIN TO CALTRANS- HCFC HAS
BEEN WORKING VERY VERY CLOSELY
WITH CALTRANS. PARTICULARLY
SINCE THAT THE PANDEMIC AND
HELPING THINK THROUGH HOW TO
KEEP- FOLKS THAT ARE THAT ARE
ENCAMPMENTS PARTICULARLY ON
STATE LANDS HOW TO KEEPTHEM
SAFE I'M NOT ENSURE THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SAFE AND WHEN
NEEDED HOW THAT HOW TO SAFELY
MOVE FOLKS AND- DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND RESOLVING CAN'T
RENT AND SO A LOT OF THE WORK.
I'M THE STAFF THAT ARE THAT ARE
RECOMMENDED FOR- CALTRANS IS
FOR A LOT OF THT WORK THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING LOCALLY WE
HAD HDFC WOULD ALSO HAVE A
PIECE AND THAT OUR NATION WITH
LOCAL ENTITIES I'M NOT
HOMELESSNESS EXPERT SIDE AND
GETTING FOLKS INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING. AND THAT'S WHERE A LOT
OF THAT GRANT FUNDING WOULD GO
IS REALLY TARGETING I'M
SPECIFIC ENCAMPMENTS PRIMARILY
IN CAMPUS THAT ARE OVER FIFTY
INDIVIDUALS REALLY HELPING.
THOSE FOLKS INTO SAFER AND MORE
PERMANENT HOUSING THAT SORT OF
THOSE PIECES THE LETTER
ABATEMENT PEACE IN THE PART OF
THAT- AS WE KNOW WE CAN'T
REMOVE ALL THESE CAMPAIGNS
IMMEDIATELY THERE IS QUITE A
BIT. OF LETTER EFFORTS THAT
THAT THE CALTRANS IS CURRENTLY
UNDERTAKING TO KEEP THOSE
PHONES- ENCAMPMENTS AS CLEAN AS
SAFE AS POSSIBLE AND WORK TO
ACTUALLY MOVE OPENED A
PERMANENT HOUSING SO THAT THAT
IS WHERE THAT FUNDING COMES
THEN. I WOULD MORE DETAIL AND
WE PROBABLY NEED UPON OUR
CALTRANS FOLKS BUT BUT WE HAVE
BEEN COORDINATING WITH THEM
QUITE CLOSELY AND I MATH PIECE-
AND ARE ARE EXCITED TO CONTINUE
THAT WORK AND LEARN. HOW BEST
TO SUPPORT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND ENDING CAN'T RESOLUTION-
AND THEN RIGHT HANDED OVER TO
OUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BROKE
DOWN. ON THAT THE MORE FLEXIBLE
FUNDING AND THAT RESILIENCY
PIECES SO SKEWS ME JUST A
FOLLOW UP THEN VERY QUICKLY
WHICH IS FOR EXAMPLE THAT.
FIFTY MILLION. INDIAN CAPITAL
RESOLUTION GRANT. AND THE
CALTRANS AND CORPS. OF TWO
SEVEN. WE DO YOU EXPECT TO SEE
HAPPEN WHAT WILL WHAT WITH IN
THE- BASED ON. BUT I CALTRAIN
GET MY- AND AGAIN IN MY ACTUAL
GET OVER FINANCE TO TALKS ITS
ITS FIRST BUT- I'M REALLY DO
THEY'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
WORK WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT AND HOW TO
KEEP HOW TO KEEP THESE THE
USING CANON SAFE AND WHEN
NECESSARY TO RESOLVE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF JUST. TIENEN
TENTATIVE OUT WORK BEING DONE
AND SO THAT WOULD BE THE BIG
LEAGUE HARPER SACK TO KEEP THAT
WE'RE DOING AND EXPAND THE WORK
THEY'VE BEEN THEY'VE BEEN
DOING. ON THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON OUR END SOME OF THAT
WOULD ALSO INCLUDE HDFC STAFF
TO CONTINUALLY A SIGNING WITH
WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES BUT AND
LARGE MAJORITY OF THAT THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WILL GO
FOR HIS HANDFUL OF COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE ALREADY STARTED
THINKING THROUGH AND HAVE
BROUGHT RESOURCES TO THE TABLE
I'M KIND OF RESOLVE ANY TIRING
CAN'T MANY MOVE FOLKS IN THE
STATE FOR UNSTABLE HOUSING.
WHERE THEY NEED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO DO THAT AND LEARNING
FROM IT SORT OF WHERE THEY HAVE
GREATER INNOVATIVE WAYS TO DO
THAT- THE EXPECTATION S THAT
WE WOULD BE USING THOSE FUNDS
FOR VERY TARGET AND THANK YOU
EVENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT WE THINK WE CAN FULLY
RESOLVED. AND THE FOLKS AND A
PERMANENT HOW THE ENTIRE COME.
IN CANADA CANADIAN DEPARTMENT.
MR FRIEDMAN. THE LOCAL.
BUSINESS THERE AND I WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP AND QUESTION THAT BE.
IN MY IN MY CA. AND LIKE YOU
MENTIONED AND- PARTS OF L.
COUNTY AND ACROSS THE STATE.
STATE PROPERTY IN CALTRANS. IT
TAKES A LONG TIME TO GET
CALTRANS TO GO OUT TO A
PROPERTY JUST FOR BASIC CLEAN
UP TO BEGIN WITH. THEN THERE'S
ALL OF THE- TRASH AND DEBRIS
AND HUMAN WASTE THAT IS. LEFT
OVER AND TURNED KAMIN SAID MISS
AND I HEAR YOU SAY I HEARD YOU
SAY. THESE SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS
WOULD BE TO KEEP ENCAMPMENTS
SAFE. CAN YOU ELABORATE ON WHAT
THAT ACTUALLY MEANS BECAUSE WE
HAD A RECENT AND CAPMAN CLEANED
WHERE WE FOUND A LOT OF.
UNFORTUNATELY NEEDLES DRUGS A
LOT OF. A LOT OF THINGS THAT
REALLY ACTUALLY SHOULDN'T BE ON
THE STREET AND SO EASILY
ACCESSIBLE AND COMMUNITIES AND
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO. WHAT
THE TRANSITION ACTUALLY LOOKS
LIKE AND WHAT IS THE
MEASUREMENT OF SUCCESS TO KEEP.
CALTRANS AND STATE PROPERTY
CLEAN. AND NOT TO WITH
ADDITIONAL ENCAMPMENTS ONCE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
SAFELY MOVED. INTO MORE
PERMANENT HOUSING. YEAH I
THOUGHT MAYBE AND JUST TALKING
THROUGH THAT A RANGE OF
INTERVENTIONS RIGHT SO THAT
THAT LED OUR BASEMENT I THINK
THERE'S ALSO AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT ARE FINANCE SPOKESMAN
MRS WELL THAT IS SORT OF AT A
HAZARDOUS WASTE CLEANUP PIECE
OF BAD PROPOSAL AS WELL. BOTH
OF THOSE ARE REALLY INTENDED TO
TRY TO KEEP THE ISLANDERS THAT
THAT'S SORT ONGOING CAMPAIGN
SETTINGS THAT'S HELPING. ME OUT
THAT LETTER HELP KEEP THEM AS
SAFE AS POSSIBLE WHILE WE TRY
TO TRANSITION INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING REQUIRED BUT THAT WOULD
BE STATEWIDE. THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD BE VERY TARGETED
TOWARDS SPECIFIC. HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT WE THINK WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE COULD
RESULT BEING TIRING CANNOT MOVE
ALL OF THOSE FOLKS AND A
PERMANENT HOUSING AND THEN
CALTRANS OR THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
COULD COULD FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT THAT PROPERTY IS.
THE CERTIFICATE CARE AND
THERE'S NOT AN ADDITIONAL.
ARGUMENT THAT THAT POPS UP. AND
JEFF YOU KNOW MY NAME I AND TO
BUILD UPON WHAT THE MADAM
CHAIR. ASTON OR MAYBE JUST
COMPLEMENT WHAT SHE'S SAYING.
WHAT WHAT EXACT. WHO WHO'S
GONNA BE IN CHARGE OR THEY'RE
GONNA BE MATRIX EXPECTED TO BE
RECEIVED. AND AS WE CONSTANTLY
RUN INTO THIS PROBLEM SO I YOU
KNOW THIS IS A THIS IS A CRISIS
WITH THAT NO ONE WANTS TO SEE
GO TO WASTE. IF WE CAN BE
MAKING INVESTMENTS THAT WE KNOW
WE CAN GET RESULTS FOR WHO'S
GOING TO BE IN CHARGE. TO BE
RECEIVING THE DOCUMENTATION OF
WHAT WAS EXACTLY DONE WITH THE
DOLLARS THAT ARE BEING INVESTED.
YES OVER THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S FULLY HDFC- THE
BEAUTY OF AGI AFTER THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO TRACK- HOUSING
OUTCOMES THAT LONG TERM HOUSING
SUSTAINABILITY. FOR ANYBODY
THAT IS RECEIVING SERVICE THAT
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
ENCAMPMENTS ON W. AND SO WE
GARY MATCH EXPECT THAT THERE
WILL BE AN ONGOING. DATA
ANALYSIS. FROM THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO DETERMINE-
HOW THOSE FOLKS HAVE MOVED IN
HOUSING HAVE BETWEEN AND WITHIN
THE HOUSING AND HOW LONG THEY
WERE ABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT
HOUSING THAT HAPPENED EXACTLY.
AND WHO WILL BE AND WHO WILL BE
THE- INSTITUTION OR THE PERSON
IN CHARGE. OR. L. OR
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS. FINALLY
IT COMING TO THE HOMELESS COURT
MEETING IN COMES THAT WE BE
OKAY. ARE AND OKAY THANK AND
THEN- AS FOR THE OTHER TO THE
HAP WERE TO FLEXIBLE FUNDING
AND THE RESILIENCE FUNDING.
BRITAIN IS ALSO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO THE BUDGET CURRENTLY
DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY FLEXIBLE
FUNDING BUT WE ARE OPEN TO HAVE-CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT WHAT FLEXIBLE
FUNDING WOULD LOOK LIKE. AND
WHAT ACCOUNTABILITY OF THOSE
FUNDS WILL LOOK LIKE I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE FUNDING
FOR HELP TWO POINT OH HAS NOT
GOING ON GOING OUT YET
INTERVIEWS MULTI YEAR
AVAILABILITY FOR THAT FUNDING.
AND I'LL MOVE ON TO YOUR YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES THERE IS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN THE BUDGET FOR
THIS PURPOSE. I DON'T KNOW ALL
THOSE DETAILS AS IT FALLS ON A
DIFFERENT POLICY AREA BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY GO BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES A FINANCE AND GET
THOSE DETAILS TO YOU. I THINK
WE WOULD LIKE THAT VERY MUCH.
GETTING THE DETAILS TO THIS
PROPOSAL IN PLAN WOULD HELP US
REALLY WORK WITH YOU IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET TO A GOOD SPACE
WHICH I THINK IS THE DIRECTION
THE MISTER NAZARIAN IS HEADING
UP. SURE IT'S CALLED THE
PREPARE CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE
IF YOU. WANT TO LOOK FORWARD IN
THE BUDGET SOMEWHERE BUT I WILL
GET THOSE SPECIFIC DETAILS TO
YOUR STAFF THANK YOU. AND
MENTORED DECREES APARTMENT A
FINANCES MIGHT ALSO ADD ON A
SPECIFICALLY TO SOME OF THE
HOUSING PROPOSALS THAT COULD BE
COVERED. OKAY COVER SEISMIC
RETROFITTING- JUST WANT TO KNOW
THAT POTENTIALLY REAP OR THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND- PLANNING
GRANTS. TO GO TOWARDS US I
THINK RETROFITTING AS WELL AS
OUR PRESERVATION PROPOSAL- AND
A- OUR INFLUENCES SUCH A GRANT
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAD- FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ENABLE ONE.
UNDER COULD ALSO GO TOWARDS
ISAAC RETROFITTING. THANK YOU
AND MISTER CHRIS THANK YOU FOR
THAT I ACTUALLY HAD A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ON THE REAP FUNDING
AND HOW IT WILL ACTUALLY BE
DISTRIBUTED CAN YOU ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT ON THAT. CERTAINLY
SO FOR THE REFUNDING IT'S
LARGELY TO MIRROR KIND OF HOW
OF ROOF WAS DONE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. WE ARE
LOOKING TOWARDS- HAVING THE
FUNDING GO OUT TOWARDS WE TO
ENTITIES IN THIS CASE THE- THE
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS. OR A
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION-
COMMITTEE OR SOME OF THE- AS
WITH THE CURRENT REPROGRAMMED.
IF THERE ARE NO OF. SUCH
ENTITIES ENTERED AS CERTAIN
AREAS THAN A WORKING GROUP
MULTI AGENCY GROUP. OF THE
FUNDING TO GO TOWARDS THEM.
ALLOCATED- ALLOCATED TOWARDS
THEM. IS THERE IS A DETAILED
PROPOSAL TO YOU CAN ALSO SEND
OVER WITH REGARDS TO THE
DISTRIBUTION OF REFUNDS. YES SO
MENTAL WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS.
FINALISING THE ULTRA LIBERAL
THAT CAN PROVIDE SOME MORE
INFORMATION AS TO THE
ALLOCATION AND- I CAN PROVIDE
THAT ONCE THAT IS- FINALIZED.
THANK YOU. MISTER NAZARIAN ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. OKAY
OKAY. BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD- I
ACTUALLY DO HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT I
WANTED TO. ADDRESS AND REALLY
RELATING TO. YOUTH HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CAN YOU PLEASE
ELABORATE AS TO WHAT THE PLAN
IS TO ENSURE THAT- YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS IS ALSO ADDRESSED.
GET AFTERNOON VENTURE MEMBERS
DANA CRUZ DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I COULD TAKE A STAB AT US IN
THE HOUSING PROPOSES AND THEN
REFER TO- MY COLLEAGUES YOU CAN
ADD FURTHER- WE ARE PROPOSING-
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING FOR FOSTER'S FORMER
FOSTER CARE YOUTH AGES EIGHTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY ONE I NAVIGATORS
HOPE THAN A SIXTY FIVE HOUSING
STABILITY AS WELL AS MICHAEL
I'M GOING A TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING- HOUSING STABILITY
SERVICES FOR. ACTIONS IS A
GROUP OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE- OF FORMER FOSTER YOUTH OR
EVEN- FOR PROBATION- A YOUTH-
AND HAVING TO PASS IT OVER TO
YOU- IF YOU'RE AFTER SIGNED- IF.
SHE HAS ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD
FOR THE HOME SIDE. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY AND SO I THAT ALSO A
GOOD AMOUNT I WAS TRYING TO
PULL IT UP HERE THERE'S SO MUCH-
BUT THAT THERE'S NOT A LARGE
CHUNK THAT IS ALSO GOING FOR
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS
SPECIFICALLY IT DO YOU THINK
HE'S- A LITTLE BIT LOUDER PLACE
YOU'RE YOU'RE FADING IN. YOUR
AUDIO. VERY SORRY ABOUT THAT I
THINK I'M HAVING BAD TIMES
INTERNET TODAY APOLOGIES FOR
THAT. IT WAS JUST I'M ALSO
MENTIONING THAT THERE IS. A
CHUNK OF FUNDING TAT I WILL
HAVE A NUMBER FOR HERE JUST A
SECOND- AROUND SEAT FOR FIRST
YOU HOMELESSNESS WITH CSU'S.
ADAMS COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THE UC SYSTEM AND SO I'M I'M
KIND OF LOOKING TO SEE IF HE IS
THE EXACT A DOLLAR ON THAT- ARE
AMAZING FOR IT. I HAVE BIRTH
BRITNEY THOMPSON TO PARTLY
FINANCE. YES ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AT THE STATE
COLLEGES FOR STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS. IN ADDITION TO
THE PROPOSAL TO BAN OUTLINED
THERE'S ALSO. EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM WHICH IS FOR A
PRIORITY GIVEN TO FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. AND THEN THERE'S GOING
TO BE A 8% YOU SET ASIDE IN
HOME KEY. THANK YOU FOR THE
TECH THE TO THAT I'M TO TAKE
TERMS OF HOW WILL A PROJECT
HOME KEY B. SIGNIFICANT. FACTOR
IN ENSURING SO. THE HOUSING FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE BUT THERE'S THREE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT I HEARD
YOU TALK ABOUT. ONE IS A FOSTER
YOUTH SECOND IS STUDENT-
HOMELESSNESS AND THEN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. SO HOW
DOES ALL OF THAT COMPARED TO-
EFFORTS THAT WERE MADE IN THE
PAST. AND I WOULD I WOULD JUST
MENTION REAL QUICKLY ON THE
PHONE KEY PIECE THAT IS
CRITICAL IN TERMS OF THAT WILL
BE A PERMANENT HOUSING I PLACE
IT FOR YOU SO WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING THROUGH THE FULL THE
FULL RANGE AND WE WILL HAVE A
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AND FOSTER
YOUTH AND STUDENT WE ALSO HAVE
PERMANEN HOUSING EFFORTS TO
COMPETE. I'M ABOUT 8% I THINK
ALL OF THAT- WILL THEN. THE
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS PROPOSAL.
THERE HAVE BEEN THINK YOU KNOW
TO. THE DAYCARE BEEN OF THAT
WORK OR BEING DONE I BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A- SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THOSE FINDINGS BUT
BRITNEY IN DATA YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THAT MARK. ON
ALL OF THIS IS VERY MUCH
BUILDING ON WHAT YOU'VE DONE
AND YOU CAN COUNT. AYE WE HAVE
SEEN COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE REALLY DOUBLING DOWN. ON
EFFORTS WITH USE HOMELESSNESS
AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
POPULATION BETTER AND WHAT IS
MORE WHAT IS MOST NEEDED FOR
THAT POPULATION. SO WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT THESE RESOURCES ARE
VERY WELCOME PARTICULARLY THE
HOME KEY EFFORTS I THINK WILL
BE PARTICULARLY WELCOMING
COMMUNITIES. THAT I STARTED
UNDERSTANDING. THE POPULATION
BETTER AND HOW BEST TO SERVE
THEM. THANK YOU FOR THEM IS
MISTER. THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION BEING INVESTED AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL THE CSU
IN THE UC. HOW WILL THAT BE
THIS DISTRIBUTED WHAT IS THE
PROGRAM MANAGEMENT LOOK LIKE.
THREE THOUSAND IF I. SO FUNDING
SPREAD ACROSS CAL COMMUNITY
CALL. CAL STATE YOU. AND TO USE.
IN THE SPORTS PURPOSE- ONE PART
OF IT IS BASIC NEEDS. FOR
STUDENT IN HOMELESSNESS. AND
THEN OTHER COMPONENT FOR RAPID
RE HOUSING. THANK YOU AND IN
FACT CAN YOU WALK ME THROUGH
THE PROCESS SO I'M A STUDENT AT
AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I
NEED ASSISTANCE WHERE DO I GO.
WHO'S IN CHARGE. I DON'T HAVE
THE SPECIFICS ON THAT BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY GET THAT FOR YOU AND
YOUR STAFF. HOW AND THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY
IMPACTFUL- PIECE TO DIVE INTO
IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS AND YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO RESOURCES
BUT I'M ALSO VERY CONCERNED IN
TERMS OF LIKE THE MANAGEMENT OF
THESE FUNDS AND HOW EXACTLY ON
THE GROUND LEVEL SOMEBODY THE
NEEDS ASSISTANCE CAN ACTUALLY-
OBTAINED RESOURCES AND FIND OUT
HOW TO GET INFORMATION. AND IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO WORK ON THEN YOU KNOW
WE SHOULD FIGURE THAT PIECE OUT.
SURE I'M GONNA WALK THROUGH ON
HOW TO ACCESS THE FUNDING TO
MAKE SURE TO STUDENTS ARE ABLE
TO EFFICIENTLY AND QUICKLY
ACCESS EIGHT DIGITAL DETAILS.
THANK YOU- ONE FINAL QUESTION
AND FOR THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
IS CAN THE DEPARTMENT EXPLAIN
WHY THE AYE AYE G. PROGRAM
CONCENTRATES ON BROWNFIELD. HOW
LONG DOES IT TAKE FOR THE
TYPICAL IG PROJECT TO BE
COMPLETED HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE
TO- BROWN FOR PROJECT I'M SORRY
TO BE COMPLETED AND SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE FOCUS ON MORE
SHOVEL READY READY PROJECTS.
SANTA CRUZ DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I GOING THE SENATE THE
BROWN TO REMEDIATE ISSUE IN
THEN PLAN TO THE- IF HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD. OTHER
BOOKS BROWN'S REMEDIATION AS WE
PART OF A LONG TERM VIEW THAT
DIDN'T. IS TAKING TO. BUILDING
HOUSING UNLUCKY. MORE HOUSE
MORE THAN FOR. AS WELL SO YOU
CAN SEE. UP JUST PRODUCE MORE
HOW. IT'S ABOUT PRETTY HOUSING
THE APPROACH AREAS. FOR
INSTANCE NEAR- NEAR TRANSIT AND
URBAN LIKE. HELP ME ARE CLIMATE
GOALS. A BIT HAPPY TO ALSO WERE
OVER TO EACH STUDIO THEY HAVE
ANY ELSE TO ADD. THANK YOU-
THEY MAY. CHASES WILL DOUBLE
THE GOOD. OF THE DEPARTMENT
HOUSING. DEVELOPMENT AS YOU
KNOW IT'S SIX. IMPORTANT TO
ESTABLISH OUR- GOOD
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR DEVELOPMENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSES. BROWN HERE
REMEDIATION AS- YOU PART OF
THAT- IT IS NOT THE ONLY-
UPCOMING FOR ON THEIR THE AYE
AYE PROGRAM WE HAVE MORE MY- ON
THEIR- ONE THINK THOSE ANOTHER
TO. DOLLAR I THAT WOULD COOPER
ALL THEIR TIME OF
INFRASTRUCTURE OF. I JUST READY
NEXT TO MAKE OUR LAND READY.
FOR HOUSING AS THEY THAT I. YES
IN THE RIGHT LOOK. NOW THEIR
JOBS AND NEAR- IT'S VERY- THE-
PROGRAM FOR- FOR THESE. SO- IF
IT'S BROWN. BY IT'S ALSO
THERE'S ALSO ADDITIONAL MONEY.
TO THE CONVERSATION ON ON THE
HOME KEY AND- YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS AND JUST REALLY
STATE FOR THE RECORD THAT. NOT
EVERY NOT EVERY YOUNG PERSON IS
A FOSTER YOUTH OR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH NOT EVERY YOUNG PERSON.
IS GOING TO COLLEGE AND SO WE
NEED TO REALLY FIGURE OUT. WHAT
THAT REALLY LOOKS LIKE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE. THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAT
FALL OUT OF THAT CATEGORY THAT
MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES- IN A DIFFERENT
CAPACITY AND SO I JUST WANNA.
PUT THAT ON THE TABLE THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
PERSONALLY WANT TO- REALLY DIVE
INTO A LITTLE BIT DEEPER AND
REALLY ENSURE THAT. THIS
BUDGET. ALLOWS FOR A REFLECTION
OF OUR VALUES IN WHICH YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS IS ALSO REFLECTED
IN A WAY THAT ACTUALLY OFFER
SOME ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
OUTSIDE OF THE- THE GROUPS THAT
WERE MENTIONED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON. TOWARDS ISSUE NUMBER
TWO- PRESENTATION ON THE
GOVERNOR'S. LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT I JOINING US WILL
BE SECRETARY- JULIE'S- JULIE SU
AS WELL AS CHAO'S ALAMO WITH
ALEJO. SECRETARY SUE YOU'RE ON.
FIVE CHILDREN CARILLO CANYOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU-
THANK YOU SO MUCH- I JUST
WANTED TO PICK UP PERSONAL UP
PLAN APPROVAL JUST TO SAY I'M
SO PROUD TO BE IN A STATE WHERE
OUR LEADERSHIP REFLECTS OUR
BEAUTIFUL DIVERSITY- AND I'M SO
EXCITED ABOUT YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND
THAT OF ALL OF YOUR COLLEAGUES
DURING THIS REALLY DIFFICULT
YEAR- IT'S BEEN A YEAR WERE
CALIFORNIANS WHO CAME TOGETHER
BUT THE STEPS THAT WE HAD TO
TAKE. WHICH CERTAINLY SAVE
LIVES IN WHICH THAT HAS NOW
MADE CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE
PLACES OF LOWEST KOBE
TRANSMISSION IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY ALSO REQUIRED
TREMENDOUS SACRIFICE AND THE
SACRIFICES LIKE THE EFFECTS OF
THE PANDEMIC ITSELF WERE NOT
BORN EQUALLY WORKERS OF COLOR
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS WOMEN
HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY HARD HIT.
THIS IS AND SOME CASES WHOLE
INDUSTRIES WERE ESSENTIALLY
SHUT DOWN OVERNIGHT AND WORKERS
HAVE PAID THE PRICE BOTH ON THE
FRONT LINES AND ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT LINES. WE HAVE HAD
MANY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT UNEMPLOYED
WORKERS HAVE FACED ALL OF US
NOT JUST MY TEAM AT THE LABOR
AGENCY BUT ALSO YOUR STAFF HAVE
WORKED COLLECTIVELY WITH EDTA
TRYING TO ADDRESS THEM. AND
THIS WORK OF COURSE IS ONGOING
AND THE PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES AND SHORTCOMINGS
THAT PREDATED THE PANDEMIC.
WHAT WERE MADE IMPOSSIBLE TO
IGNORE BY IT. THIS INCLUDES
BENEFITS SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION
SOMETHING THAT EDT STARTED
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BUT WE ARE
NOW FORCED TO AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO THINK REALLY
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT WHAT A MODERN
SYSTEM BASED ON GOOD
TECHNOLOGY. ALSO WITH A HUMAN
CENTERED CLAIMANTS CENTERED A
VISION COULD LOOK LIKE- AND SO
THIS BUDGET- PROPOSES TO- PICK
UP THAT WORK AGAIN- AND THAT
WORK WAS PUT ON HOLD WHILE EDT
FOCUSED ON MEETING THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND WE ARE FORCED TO
RELY ON THE EXISTING SYSTEM TO
DO SO- IT ALSO INCLUDES IN THE
EDT BUCKET- MONEY TO IMPLEMENT
DIRECT DEPOSIT SOMETHING YOU
HAVE ALL RAISED AS WELL AS WE
HAVE INTERNALLY TALKED ABOUT-
THIS WILL. BOTH ADDRESS THE
NEED FOR PROMPT PAYMENTS AND
ALSO- HAVE A SAFEGUARDS AGAINST
FRAUD. WELL THERE'S ALSO A
PROPOSAL TO HAVE YOU Y.
NAVIGATORS AT THE- AMERICAN JOB
CENTERS SO- EXPANDING IMPROVING
SUSTAINABILITY OF UP PEOPLE TO
ASSIST CLAIMANTS WHEN THEY NEED
IT- THAT EIGHT. IT. ALSO IT IS
MILLION DOLLAR- ITEM FOR
DEFERRED WORKLOADS THIS IS
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PANDEMIC SEARCH AND THEN THERE
IS- TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT- EDT LANGUAGE ACCESS
INITIATIVE AGAIN SOMETHING THAT
YOU ALL AND I STARTED WANTING
KNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
LEADERSHIP ON THIS- TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO IMPROVE MULTI LINGUAL
SERVICES- IT ALSO INCLUDES
GRANTS TO CBO'S TO PROVIDE
OUTREACH EDUCATION TO THOSE
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
COMMUNITIES- THIS BILL IS ON
THE VISION THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS HAD OF
WORKING IN CONJUNCTION WITH
CBO'S WHAT THE TRUST OF
COMMUNITIES THAT WE NEED TO
SERVICE. AND DIRECTOR REDESIGNS
IS ALSO HERE TODAY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
ABOUT THESE ITEMS WHAT WE ALSO
KNOW IS THAT BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC EVEN PEOPLE WHO WERE
EMPLOYED WERE NOT ENJOYING THE
QUALITY OF JOBS LIVABLE WAGES
HEALTH BENEFITS JOB SECURITY
UNION PROTECTIONS UPWARD
MOBILITY AND OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE JOB THAT WE WANT FOR
OURSELVES FOR OUR LOVED ONES
AND FOR ALL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY LIKE THAT
THE NATION'S FASTING GROWTH IN
BOTH HIGH WAGE JOBS AND LOW
WAGE JOBS BUT A HOLLOWING OUT
OF THE MIDDLE CLASS AND A
DECLINING SHARE OF WORKERS WHO
RECEIVE HEALTH BENEFITS
RETIREMENT BENEFITS IMPORTANT
SOURCES OF ECONOMIC SECURITY
AND KEY MEASURES OF JOB
QUALITY. AND WE KNOW THAT NOT
ALL REGIONS OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
FULLY PARTICIPATED IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC SUCCESS
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ALL
PARTICIPATE IN A VIBRANT
ECONOMY THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BUILD AND SO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WHAT WE CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA COME BACK PLAN
PROPOSES TO NEARLY ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN AN ECONOMIC RESILIENCE AND
JOBS PACKAGE TO TACKLE THE
CHALLENGES HAT WERE BROUGHT
ABOUT BY THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO
THAT EXISTED BEFORE. IT
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT BAD JOBS. ARE
CHOICE JUST AS GOOD JOB BOB
CHOICE AND THROUGH THE- INVEST.
YOU ARE TO THE THAT WE- TO PAUL
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE WE CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENT CHOICE SO WE
ARE THE PROPOSAL LOOKS AT
REBUILDING OUR ECONOMY. AND
ALSO REVERSING THE DECADES LONG
TRENDS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC OF
GROWTH IN LOW WAGE JOBS AND
GOOD THE GROWING GAP BETWEEN
THE RICH AND POOR. AND THIS
BUDGET REALLY- LACES STRATEGIC
INVESTMENTS IN HOW WE DELIVER
ON ON ON THAT WORK. IT INCLUDES
A SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE FUND FOCUSED ON
BOTTOM UP PLANNING FOR EACH
REGION RECOGNIZING THAT ONE
SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL AND THAT
WE HAVE TO BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT
WHAT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
GROWTH ARE GONNA LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE TO BE INTENTIONAL ABOUT
JOB CREATION. IN THE LANGUAGE
OF ECONOMIST WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT THE DEMAND SIDE FOR
LABOR. AND THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
ALSO INCLUDES ROUGHLY THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO GET WORKERS INTO THOSE GOOD
JOBS IT INCLUDES BUILDING
BRIDGES BETWEEN COMUNICADO
EDGES AND I WORKFORCE AGENCIES
IT'S ABOUT TRANSFORMING OUR
WORKFORCE SYSTEM SO THAT WE ARE
TRULY PREPARING WORKERS FOR THE
JOBS OF THE FUTURE WE'RE
MEETING EMPLOYER NEEDS AND
WE'RE COMBATING THE SYSTEMIC
EXCLUSION OF THOSE WHO. WALKING
BEHIND EVEN IN GOOD TIMES SO
THIS IS ABOUT THE SUPPLY SIDE
OF LABOR AND WE CANNOT DO JUST
ONE WE HAVE TO DO BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS AND THIS BUDGET REFLECTS
THAT SO EACH OF THESE TWO
PIECES HAS TWO CATEGORIES UNDER
IT- SO REALLY FOUR PIECES THAT
COMPLEMENT ONE ANOTHER THAT ARE
THAT ARE REALLY INTERLOCKING.
SO FIRST ON THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR FUND THIS
IS AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT
FUNDING THAT WOULD TREAT THIS
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
FUND THE TWO COMPONENTS ONE IS
PLANNING IT WILL PROVIDE
PLANNING GRANTS TO EACH OF THE
STATE'S REGION'S RECOGNIZING
THAT I SAID THAT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND GROWTH
STRATEGIES HAVE TO COME BOTTOM
UP BY THOSE WHO KNOW THE
REGION'S BEST WHO KNOW THEIR
ASSET ASSETS WHO CAN ALIGN THE
REGION'S. STRENGTHS ALONG WITH
THEIR CHALLENGES WHO CAN LOOK
AT HOW TO ECONOMICALLY
DIVERSIFY EACH REGION FOR
LONGER TERM RESILIENCE AND THAT
WILL ALSO REFLECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
CLIMATE AND EQUITY AND ACCESS
SO- THE THAT THAT FUNDING WILL
GO TOWARD HIGH ROAD TRANSITION
COLLABORATIVE'S WORKER VOICES
ARE HEARD WHAT INDUSTRY MEETING
LABOR AND MANAGEMENT COME
TOGETHER AND WE'LL BE HEARD.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
REGIONS THE BILL AND QUEST LIKE
WILL WE THE JOB OF ARGUE. WHERE
WILL THE JOBS COME FROM SO THE
FIRST PART OF THAT IS PLANNING
GRANTS THE SECOND PART OF THAT
AGAIN THE TO UNDER THE FUND THE
SECOND PIECE OF IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PLANS THAT COME. INTO
ACTION- IMPLEMENTING REGIONAL
ECONOMIC PLANS. AND
IMPLEMENTING WHAT THIS
INCLUSIVE PROCESS- COMES UP
WITH SO THAT WERE ACTUAL THE-
CREATING STRONG INDUSTRIES WITH
GOOD JOBS IN THEM ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THEN HE
SAID GO UNDER THE WORK FORCE
THE JOB READY INSIDE. THAT'S
THE DEMANDS. ONE IS HOW DO WE
CREATE STRONG TRAINING PROGRAMS
THAT TALK WAYS- IN AN EQUITABLE
WAY AND THESE ARE INVESTMENTS
IN A HIGH ROE TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS AND HYBRID
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS- THE
BUDGET PROPOSED AN ADDITIONAL
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS ON TOP
OF THE TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE ORIGINAL. TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THIS WILL ADDRESS
INDUSTRIES IN DEMAND GROWTH
INDUSTRIES LIKE HOSPITALITY
TRANSPORTATION HEALTH CARE- AND
OTHERS THESE ALSO ALIGNED WITH
OTHER PARTS OF THE BUDGET AND
OTHER PARTS OF OUR ECONOMY
RIGHT JOBS. THAT INCLUDE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES- HOUSING-
WOULD YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT
RIGHT TRANSPORTATION- AND ALSO
HAS THE FUNDING FOR THE
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL. TO
FIND I. T. ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING HEALTHCARE AND
PUBLIC SECTOR JOBS TO TRADE
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
WORKERS THESE ARE SECTORS THAT
ARE NOT CURRENTLY COVERED UNDER
ETP- SO THERE'S THAT THOSE
TRAINING PIECES- THAT ALLOW.
THAT THAT FIT INTO OTHER-
PRIORITIES IN THE BUDGET AND
PARTIES TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
YOU'RE JUST HELP CALIFORNIA
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE AND THE
LAST PIECE IS INVESTMENTS IN
THE STATE'S WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS. THAT
STRENGTHEN THE LINKS BETWEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS SO- REALLY YOU KNOW
IT'S A HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO IMPROVE
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS- OF THIS
KIND OF FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS COMPLIMENTS THE FUNDS I
JUST TALKED ABOUT TO H. I. T.
P.'S HRC SEES. REALLY
ADDRESSING A LONGSTANDING
CRITIQUE THAT OUR EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS AND PATHWAYS DO NOT
CORRELATE TO CURRENT AND FUTURE
QUALITY JOBS SO FOR
INTERLOCKING COMPONENTS UNDER
TWO BIG BUCKETS ONE IS THE THAT
THE PLANNING FOR THE KINDS OF
JOBS WE WANT TO KIND OF IT KIND
OF WOULD HAVE REGION BY REGION.
AND THE OTHERS HOW WE GET
PEOPLE CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE USUALLY GET LEFT OUT IT
INTO THOSE JOBS THE LAST THING
I JUST WANT TO SAY IS THAT WELL.
SO MUCH ABOUT THE LAST YEAR WAS
NOT WORSE. SOME OF THE THAT
REFLECT IN THE IN THIS
CALIFORNIA COME BACK PLAN IN
THIS NEW REVISED ARE THE RESULT
OF SEEDS THAT WERE PLANTED
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. AND AS
WE'VE SEEN THE LAST YEAR AS
MANY OF OUR CONVERSATIONS HAVE
BEEN ABOUT WE CANNOT. FIX THE
LEAKY ROOF ON THE HOUSE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE STORM SO WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT THE INVESTMENT IN
STRONG. AND THE STRONG WITH
THAT HAS BEEN DONE BEFORE AND
THE LEADERSHIP OF TIM RAINEY OF
THE CALIFORNIA WILL PUT YOU ON
THE BOARD AND READ HAVE YOU
HEARD OF THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL AND BOTH OF THEM
ARE ALSO HERE TO ANSWER YOUR
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. ABOUT THOSE
INVESTMENTS THAT WORK WAS.
INVESTING IN HIGH ROAD JOBS AND
WORKFORCE INNOVATION- AND
APPRENTICESHIPS- AND
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO- WE GET
THAT THE BUDGET BUILT ON THE WE
COULDN'T DO THESE THINGS
WITHOUT THE ONE THAT HAD BEEN
DONE IN A PRIOR AND THE BEST IS
THAT YOU ALL HAVE. A B. TWO
PRIOR ALSO AND I JUST WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
TAKE PART IN A STERILE WHITE
STAIRS ALSO ON TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THIS. AND WE HAD A FUTURE
FOR COMMISSION EFFORT THAT
THAT'S ALSO REFLECTED ALL OF
THIS TO WRITE YOUR COLLEAGUE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASH KALRA WAS
ON THAT COMMISSION THAT
COMMISSION RECOMMENDED JOB FOR
EVERY CALIFORNIA WHO WANTS ONE
PARTICULARLY JOBS THAT MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS LOOK YET TIME IT
DOES NOT JUST OPPORTUNITY FOR
CLEAN. WATER AND CLEAN AIR BUT
ALSO GOOD JOBS. ARE HELD IS
BEING- INVESTMENTS NOT JUST
OPPORTUNITIES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS AND AFFORDABILITY
ISSUES BUT ALSO CREATING GOOD
JOBS SO- SO ARE. THESE
INVESTMENTS REFLECT THAT- IT
REFLECTS KIND OF FUTURE PROOF
CALIFORNIA PIPELINE NETWORK OR
SYSTEM OR EDUCATION STUDENTS
AND OUR JOBS. OF THE FUTURE AND
IT REALLY- SHOWS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S ASPIRATION TO BE A
HIGH ROAD STATE WHERE OUR
STRONG COMMITMENT TO WORKING
PEOPLE IS AS CRITICAL TO OUR
IDENTITY AS OUR TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATIONS AND OTHER THINGS
THAT MAKE CALIFORNIA GREAT. AND
THESE PRINCIPLES ARE REALLY
INFUSED THROUGHOUT THE PROPOSAL
AND I'LL STOP THERE TO SEE- IF
THE IF OUR COLLEAGUES. THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCING ANYTHING
THAT THEY WANT AT. FIVE HUNDRED
PUBLICLY APARTMENT- FINANCING
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD AFTER THAT
SUMMARY ON THE CURRENT HEARING
NEED CHAIR IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU WE WILL CONTINUE ON
ON THE SALAMA WITH THE L. L.
CHAZELLE LOW WITH THE L. A. L.
MIND COMING THROUGH FIRE. WE
CAN HEAR YOU FINE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ON EARLIER TODAY OUR OFFICE
RELEASED A- BRIEF HANDOUT
SUMMARIZING THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION WORKFORCE RELATED
PROPOSALS NOT ONLY WITHIN THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY BUT ACROSS ALL OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. ON OUT WE WERE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY MORE THAN THIRTY
FIVE NEW WORK WORK RELATED
PROPOSALS IN THE BUDGET ACROSS
THIRTEEN DIFFERENT ENTITIES.
AND TOTAL WE SOME. NEW FUNDING
FOR THESE PROPOSALS TO GET JUST
ABOUT FIVE BILLION. DOLLARS FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR- AND SORT OF
HIGH CAR HI LEVEL COME ABOUT.
THE WORK FORCE PROPOSALS
REGARDING- AND BEFORE TURNING
TO THE SO CALLED JOBS PACKAGE
THAT SECRETARY SUIT JUST WALK
YOUR- ARM SO SPEAKING BROADLY
ABOUT PROPOSALS ON WE'VE GOT A
FEW CERTAINLY HAVE MERIT- AND
WORK LEGISLATORS CONSIDERATION.
GENERALLY WE VIEW. ALSO IS THAT
EXPAND UPON IT IS. STATE
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
SHOWN SUCCESS OUGHT TO BE THOSE.
I WOULD MOST AMERICANS ARE MANY
I HAVE SHORTCOMINGS AT THIS
POINT AT LEAST- FOR INSTANCE
ARE MADE APPROVALS ARE NEW AND
THE RELATIVELY LARGE- ACTUALLY
DAY RELATIVE. TO WHAT THE-
MENTENG AGENCY HAS OFTEN AND
PAST AND SO WE'RE NOT SURE IF
EACH OF THESE ENTITIES WILL
HAVE TO ADMINISTRATIVE CAPACITY
TO MANAGE SUCH A NEW LARGE
WORKLOAD- SIMILARLY MANY THE
PROPOSAL'S LACK OF CLEARLY
DEFINED ROLES. ARE UP FOR
INDUSTRY OR OTHER PARTNERS AND
THIS RELATES TO AT THIS POINT
IN THE MAY REVISION CYCLE. IN
ESSENCE A LACK OF SIGNIFICANT
DETAIL FOR EACH OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT'LL GET INTO MORE
IN A SECOND ON IT FINALLY WORK
THEIR OVERARCHING COMMENT IT'S
NOT CLEAR WHAT THE- SORT OF. UP
CLEAR OVERARCHING PLAN IS FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S NAME REGION
WORKFORCE PROPOSALS AS I
MENTIONED THERE SPREAD ACROSS
ACROSS DIFFERENT ENTITIES AND
IN SOME CASES INTERACT WITH
EXISTING PROGRAMS BOB MAYBE
DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS ON IT SO MORE
INFORMATION IS NEEDED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AT THIS. POINT
BEFORE MAKING AN ASSESSMENT. I
WANT TO THE SPECIFIC PACKAGE
IT'S A- STUDENTS WALKING AGAIN
TOPICAL IS NEARLY ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS PRIMARILY
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN FUNDS THE
LARGEST COMPONENT IS THE
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
BONTA SECRETARY SUIT MENTIONED-
THIS WOULD BE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
GRANTS. TO REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS- OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS TO IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS. ON THAT ARE ALIGNED
WITH THE STATE'S OP FORTHCOMING
REPORT OF THE INVESTIGATION
PLANS TO PUBLISH IN JULY-
CALLED THAT JUST TRANSITION
ROADMAP. FONG I DON'T THINK WE
WOULD POINT OUT IS THAT BECAUSE
THE ROADMAP ISN'T YET PUBLIC
AND LEGISLATURE HASN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW IT IN
DETAIL OR PROVIDE COMMENTS OR
FEEDBACK IT'S A BIT CHALLENGING
AT THIS TIME. SENATE TO SORT OF
REFLECT UPON THE RESILIENCY
FUNDED AND IT'S PACKAGED-
THROUGH THE LENS OF THE JUST
TRANSITION ROAD MAP. BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T YET HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK THROUGH THAT-
ADDITIONALLY IN THERE ARE EIGHT
OTHER COMPONENTS OF THE JOBS
PACKAGE- THEY'RE ALL INCLUDED
IN ONE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
THERE'S RELATIVELY LIMITED
INFORMATION AT THIS TIME- BUT-
IN LARGE PART A OUR- NEW
PROPOSALS RATHER THAN EXPANSION
OF EXISTING PROPOSALS- I WOULD
MENTION THAT. THE WARRANTY
EXPANSION OF AN EXISTING
PROGRAM IS THE NINETY MILLION
DOLLAR EXPANSION TO THE I ROADS
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM IN
THE COMMUNITY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD THIS IS A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF A PROPOSAL
THAT IN OUR VIEW WARRANTS.
CONSIDERATION HAS MERIT BECAUSE
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SORT. OF THE TOOK BREAD AND
BUTTER WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
PROGRAM AT THE STATE'S OPERATED-
IT HEARING ARE ALL IS REYES
CONCERN AND- THE DEPARTMENT OF.
AS WELL ABOUT STATE'S JUST FRAG
WORK SYSTEM- AND WE WERE IT'S
POINT GIVEN THE MULTI OF NEW
PROPOSED. ARE THAT RELIGION
COULD COME TO A FIVE. EVEN
THOUGH MANY OF THE PEOPLE ARE
JUST TO TOGETHER DIFFERENT
ENTITY- AND ASK A LOT OF MOVING.
ALL AT ONE TIME AND IT SHOULD
BE TAKEN UNDER CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION. ON MY FINAL
REMARKS WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH-
JANUARY PROPOSAL LOOKING BACK
AT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED NEW
DEPARTMENT OF BETTER JOBS AND
HIGHER WAGES WHICH WOULD BE A
DEPARTMENTAL REORGANIZATION.
ARE CONSOLIDATING I PORTION OF
THE E. D. WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING. PANEL OF THE COUPLE
WORKFORCE AT ALL BOARD AS WELL
ADDS- DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STAY WITHIN TI
ALL. YEAH THE TIME R. O. NOTE
THAT WE REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
PURSUING A DEPARTMENTAL
REORGANIZATION THIS TIME GIVEN
THAT CHALLENGES AT THE E. D.
WHAT'S THE STATE'S UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PROGRAM. I WAS
WORRISOME AND- NOW WHAT ARE WE
MUST AMPLE THOSE CONCERNS ARE
BECAUSE OF THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN MAY
REVISION AND THEY AT THE
FORTHCOMING AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN ACTS FUNDS- WILL QUESTION
WHETHER. SPECIFICALLY
COMPLEMENT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD WILL HAVE TO
SPEND MINISTRY CAPACITY
ALONGSIDE LABOR AGENCY TO
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW YORK
REORGANIZATION IT'S TIME- THANK
YOU HAVE TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT WELL THIS IS
DEFINITELY A LOT OF INFORMATION
THEY WERE ALL KIND OF TRYING TO
DIVE. DEEP INTO AYE I HAVE A
LOT OF- I HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP
BUT I ALSO WANT TO OPEN IT UP
TO. TO MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL
BUT LET ME BEGIN WITH SECRETARY
SUE CAN YOU PLEASE ELABORATE AS
MUCH AS YOU CAN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS PROPOSAL HAS NOT.
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE YET- THE
JUST TRANSITION ROAD MAP WHAT
EXACTLY DOES THAT LOOK LIKE. IT
IS A CONVERSATION THAT WE ALL
HAVE JUST TRANSITION ARE. ARE
HOT WORDS THAT WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT. BUT I AM ACTUALLY QUITE
INTERESTED IN TERMS OF THE WHAT
WE'VE DONE AND THE LEGISLATURE
TO. ENSURE THAT WORKERS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
RETAIN A GOOD JOB A GOOD UNION
JOB A GOOD SALARY JOB- IN
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
BEING- IMPACTED BY LEGISLATION
AND CURIOUS AS TO WHAT THAT
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR I AM ACTUALLY
GOING TO TURN THIS OVER TO US
SEVERAL WHITE- FROM OPR WHO IS
HERE- WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY ON IT BUT SHE HAS
REALLY- BEEN DRIVING A LOT OF
THAT I WOULD LOVE TO GIVE HER A
CHANCE TO SHARE. THAT VISION
SERRA. EXACTLY NEED- THANK YOU
SO MUCH SECRETARY SUE FONG
THANK YOU TO ALL THAT THE
MEMBERS FOR- ENGAGING IN
CONVERSATION WITH US ABOUT THIS
INCREDIBLE INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES. I THINK THE THING
TO SAY ABOUT THE JUST
TRANSITION ROAD MAP IS THAT. WE
TRIED REALLY STEER AWAY FROM
THE LANGUAGE OF JUST TRANSITION
FOR ALL KINDS OF REASONS WE
RECORDED WITH AS A I WROTE
TRANSITION YOU'LL FIND THE
NAMES. IN THIS OP PROPOSAL
ALIGNED WITH THAT HARBOR
COLLABORATIVES CENTER WERE HIGH
ROAD IS A VISION OF
SUSTAINABILITY EQUITY JOB
QUALITY SHARED PROSPERITY ALL
OF THE THINGS THE VALUES THAT
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS HELD
UP IN IN TOTAL WANT TO SEE IT
DIFFERENT WAYS SO IT IS A
TRANSITION. IS NOT. ONLY A
TRANSITION- IT TWO FAR A CARBON
ECONOMY WHICH AFFECTS
EVERYTHING SECTOR NOT JUST
ENERGY TRANSPORTATION BUT ALSO
SMALL JOBS AS WELL AS THE
RECOVERED. FROM THE ECONOMY OF
THE STATE IN MANY REGIONS AND
MANY SECTORS BY THE PANDEMIC SO
WE THINK ABOUT RECOVERY AND WE
THINK ABOUT TRANSITION AND HOW
DO WE DO THAT IN A WAY THAT
LIFTS UP ALL CALIFORNIANS I
THINK A SECRETARY SU SAID SO
ELOQUENTLY. IT'S NOT AS IF THE
ECONOMY BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WAS
ANSWERING ALL OF OUR ECONOMIC
INEQUALITY OUT QUESTIONS SO
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE HERE SO FOR US. WE'VE
BEEN DISCOVERING IN OUR MANY
CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR IS THIS
HIRING TRANSITION REALLY IS
THIS THE LONG RANGE PLANNING
GAME THERE ARE CERTAIN SHORT
TERM THINGS THAT WE CAN ALL DO
INCLUDING THE THINGS IN THIS
PROPOSAL. BUT REALLY THERE ARE
FIVE ELEMENTS SO I THINK WHAT
WE THINK ABOUT IT LET ME JUST.
DIRECTOR TENSIONS WORKFORCE IS
ONE OF THOSE THINGS BUT WE
SIMPLY CANNOT TRAIN OUR WAY OUT
OF A JOB FIRST AS WE CANNOT
TRAIN BEFORE JOBS THAT DON'T
EXIST OR QUALITY JOBS YET
THAT'S NOT AN EQUITY AGENDA SO
MILLION THINKING ABOUT. FIVE
ECONOMIC DIVERSIFICATION
INDUSTRIAL PLANNING. WARNING
THE SAFETY NET. BUILDING. THE
WORK. OVER THE PAST YEAR- AND
THEN DOING SUMMER WE LOVE SO
THAT WE ACTUALLY DECIDE WITH
THEIR OWN CANNOT. WILL LIKE
THAT'S WHAT MY UP THE JEFF
TRANSITION. SO WE ARE UP-
SERIES OF- AREAS OF WAR. TO BE
LOOKING AND MY THINK OF THAT IN
THIS. THE BUT YOU CAN
RESILIENCE FUNDS AT THE
ECONOMIC DIVERSIFICATION. AND
HE TURKEY. REALLY LIVE UP SORT
OF THE COUNTRY'S CUTTING EDGE
VISION OF HOW TO. ADEQUATELY
PREPARE WAS FIRST- FOR A NEW
ECONOMY AND THE LAST THING I'LL
SAY IS THAT WE'RE REALLY
THINKING ABOUT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT CALIFORNIANS HERE NOT
JUST FOLKS WHOSE JOBS HAVE BEEN
OR MAY BE DISRUPTED. BUT FOLKS
WHO HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL KINDS OF
BUSINESS BUILDING AN ECONOMY
THAT WORKS FOR THAT SO JUST
TRANSITION IS NORTHWEST
CATEGORY. IN WHICH WE'RE
LOOKING AT ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT SECTORS AND THIS. OP
REPUBLICANS. SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSES TWO OF THEM. AND WHAT
IS AND IF I MAY WHAT IS THE-
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT. HI ROAD
OR JUST TRANSITION IS NOT JUST
SOLELY FOR WORKERS THAT ARE-
WHOSE INDUSTRIES MAY BE
IMPACTED. BUT THAT WE ARE ALSO
CREATING A PIPELINE OF NEW WORK
FORCE. SOME CURIOUS AS TO WHAT
THE DIRECTION IS GOING TO BE
FOR OUR CAPE THROUGH FOURTEEN.
EDUCATION SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT
AS YOU WORK ON A PLAN. WE ARE
INCLUDING THE FUTURE WORKFORCE
AND ENSURING THAT THEY ALSO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A GOOD
JOB A GOOD SALARY AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION I WILL I WILL ANSWER
ONE PIECE OF IT AND TURN IT
BACK TO. SECRETARY OF STATE. I
THINK THAT. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
PROPOSAL BUILDING JUST
TRANSITION COLLABORATIVE
ALLOWING REGIONS TO DECIDE WHAT
THEIR ECONOMIES LOOK BY. THE
WAY THAT WE GET. FROM THE
EQUITY QUESTIONS AND BROAD
QUESTIONS OF- OF. ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE PIPELINES IS THAT IT
IS SETTING THE STATE'S ROLE IS
TO SET AN INCREASE OF TABLE THE
STATE'S ROLE IS TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE- PUTTING SOME GUARD
RAILS ON THE WORK WHENEVER WE
INVEST MONEY DOESN'T. CHEAT BOT
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS THE CHIEF
EQUITY METRICS DOESN'T ACHIEVE
JOB QUALITY METRICS. THAT
REMAINS TO BE DETERMINED BUT I
THINK THEY STILL HAVEN'T
GONZALEZ SO THE TABLE AT WHICH
LABOR COSTS TO BE PRESENT AT
WHICH COMMUNITY GROUPS- ARE
REALLY GROUND LEVEL ECONOMIC
EQUITY GROUPS ARE INVOLVED IN
THE VOICES OF WORKERS INVOICES
A COMMUNITIES. AND RESIDENTS
ARE ALL PARTICIPATING AS WELL
AS- EDUCATION SYSTEMS AS WELL
AS THE BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
LABOR UNIONS AS WELL AS OTHER
FORMS OF WORKER VOICE AS WELL
AS THE WORKFORCE BOARDS- AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL SO
IT'S A BIG TABLE THERE'S ROOM
FOR EVERYONE TO HAVE THEIR
VOICE IN THIS. AND THAT IS THE
WAY THAT WE- DECIDED THAT- OR
THAT WE ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
NONE BOB BROUGHT ACCESS TO
THESE JOBS AND I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT THE HIGHER TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS. REALLY ENSURE
THAT NOT ONLY INCOME BUT
WORKERS BUT THAT THERE ARE
COMPLAINTS IAN FOR PEOPLE
THAT'S- COULD NOT HAVE ACCESS
SCHOOLS GOOD JOBS YET SO IT IS
IT IS. PART AND PARCEL OF THE
HARDWOOD VISION. THAT- THAT
THESE PIPELINES SPENDING ACCESS
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. IS OPEN.
TO ALL PROBLEMS. I'M SURE I'LL
JUST ADD TO THE A LITTLE BIT
RIGHT. YOU'RE THE QUESTIONS
WE'VE BEEN LIKE YOU THESE ARE
THAT THE THINGS THAT WERE
TRYING TO ADDRESS AND- THERE'S
THAT. YOU KNOW THE CALL THAT
THERE STATE IT'S ALL LIKE
THERE'S TOO MANY. OF IT TO WORK
YEAH THAT REALLY THERE ARE
STILL PIECES TO IT BECAUSE IT
REALLY DOES. WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE OF THE
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE TO SEE HOW IT
ALL FITS TOGETHER INTO AGAIN
THE KIND OF ECONOMY THAT WE
WANT CALIFORNIA- HAVE- AND YOU
KNOW. AGAIN HOW DO WE GET PAST
THE WORDS THIS IS THIS IS THIS
IS THE EFFORT RIGHT IT HAS TO
BE. REGION'S WE YOU KNOW WE SAY
BOTTOM UP PLANNING BECAUSE
EVERY REGION HAS HAS DIFFERENT
ASSET THERE ARE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES THEIR DIFFERENT
STATES OF TRANSITION THERE ALSO
IN DIFFERENT STATES IN TERMS
OF. HOW FAR ALONG. THEY ARE IN
A YOU HAVE YET TO HAVE ALREADY
SET WHAT WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE CLEAR THAT
WE WANT TO BE INCLUSIVE RIGHT
WE WANT THERE TO BE. YOU DON'T
THAT DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE IT
THERE HAS TO BE MANAGED BUT
THERE HAS TO BE UP COMMUNITY.
AND AND BEYOND THAT BUT WE
EXPECT THAT THE REGION'S ASKED
YOU KNOW SO OFTEN THE CASE WHEN
WE GIVE THAT SORT OF SET THE
TABLE GIVE THEM OPPORTUNITY.
THAT THAT THERE ARE- THAT THERE
THAT THERE WILL BE IDEAS THAT
DEVELOP THAT THEN WE WANT TO
INVEST IN. AND WE NEED TO DO IT
ALL UP QUICKLY WHICH IS WHY
THESE ARE THESE ARE REALLY BIG
INVESTMENTS- I ALSO JUST WANT
TO ADDRESS YOU KNOW I THINK ON
THE ON THE KEY TO FOURTEEN
PIECE. SO YOU KNOW THERE WILL
BE A PLANNING PROCESS BUT THE
REASON I SAY THIS- FOR
INTERLOCKING COMPONENTS BUT THE
ONLY TO EXIST IS THAT THERE YOU
KNOW THAT THIS THIS LAST PIECE
ABOUT WHAT WHAT'S THE ROLE OF.
ALL OF THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
RIGHT THERE THERE'S A HUNDRED
FIFTY. FIVE HUNDRED ONE DOLLARS
INVESTMENTS HERE IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PARTNERING SO THAT
THEIR ROLE IS CLEAR TO WRITE SO
THAT SO THAT YOU KNOW WHEN WE
HAVE. EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS THAT
THESE ARE ALL ALSO- PART OF ONE
VISION SO THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
GETTING YOU KNOW TRAINED ON
THINGS FOR WHICH THERE ARE NO
JOBS- AND YOU'LL BE BECAUSE-
SYSTEMS TEND TO. REACT SLOWLY.
WE NEED TO DO THE PLAY. HEADED
TO. SO THAT STILL SO THAT WE
DRIVING THE SAME TO. SO THAT'S
WHY THERE'S SO MANY PIECES TO
IT. AND WHAT WE SEE IN THE
MICROCOSM OF THE H. R. T. P. H.
I. C. C. WORLD IS THAT IS THAT
IT DOESN'T WORK. YOU KNOW I
JUST I SORT OF- CHALLENGE THAT
THE NOTION THAT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH AND CARE ABOUT. YOU KNOW
WHAT'S OF ALL INDUSTRY AND WHAT
YOU KNOW WE DEFINED INDUSTRY AS
BOTH. THE WORKERS AND THE
EMPLOYERS WE'VE SEEN THEM COME
TOGETHER AND H. R. T. P. H. I.
C. C. CONTEXT. AND AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS WHAT IS
NEEDED. FOR THE FOR THE DEMAND
SIDE FOR THE FOR THE PLAN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SIDE NOT
JUST THE TRAINING CENTER.
THINGS TO THAT'S WHAT THIS FUND
WOULD. WHAT WOULD WOULD DO TO
HELP MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS.
THANK YOU I SECRETARY SUE. I
WANT TO GO BACK A LITTLE BIT TO
THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR FIGURE- THAT'S
PART OF THE AMERICAN RESCUE
PAN. PLAN AND I FEEL LIKE YOU
MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT IN THE
BEGINNING. BUT HOW WAS THAT
FIGURED DECIDED. GO AHEAD SIR
I'M SORRY I WAS. SORRY- STILL
THERE I THINK THE DISCUSSION
WAS NOT THERE IS A TREMENDOUS
SENIOR ONCE IN A GENERATION
MOMENT HERE- AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRIES THAT OFTEN
BECAUSE THERE'S MONEY FOR
PLANNING VERY RARELY IS THERE
FOLLOW UP INFORMATION TO REALLY
BUILD ONE BILLS YEAH IDEA IS IF
TO INVEST AND THIS WILL GIVE
US. YOU KNOW WE CAN DO THE MATH
OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS AND
WE COULD SAY IT DEPENDING ON
HOW THE RELATIVES SEVEN TEN
MILLION DOLLAR PROJECTS BURKE
SENSES READING AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO ACTUALLY CARVING IT UP
THAT WAY BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT
IT IT'S ENOUGH MONEY TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
CRITICAL EQUITABLE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
THAT ARE CRITICAL TO KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY- GOING ON
IN A WAY THAT IS ACCESSIBLE TO
ALL FOLKS WHO IS REALLY ABOUT
PARTLY HAVING A FARM FONG THAT
HAD ENOUGH MONEY THAT WE DIDN'T
REGION'S FIGHTING OVER ONE
ANOTHER. FOR MONEY BUT THAT
THERE WAS ENOUGH MONEY FOR
EVERY REGION TO HAVE A HANDFUL
OF PROJECTS WHICH THEY FELT
WOULD BEST LIFT UP THEIR
ECONOMY IN A WAY THAT WORKED-
REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD THAT
WORK IN THEIR WORKERS AND THAT
WAY TO WORK WITH THEIR PROPERTY
TAX BASE RIGHT THAT THAT THIS
IS THE THIS IS THE IDEA BEHIND
IT THAT THAT WERE COMMONPLACE
WITH THAT WE'RE OPPORTUNITY
COME AT THIS FROM A PLACE OF
AMPLITUDE RIGHT. THAT WAS THE
THINKING IN SUCH A BIG. PART
THANK YOU FOR THAT I WANT TO
PICK NOW AND SAY- I REALLY HOPE
AS WE- OUT THIS HIGH.
TRANSITION ROAD MAP THAT WE ARE
ALL CONSIDERING THE
COMPLICATIONS OF DIVERSE. AND
EQUITY AND ENSURING THAT.
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
ACCESS TO. THE RESOURCES TO JOB
TRAINING TO THE JOBS OF THE
FUTURE TO ENSURING THAT. IT IT
GOES IN A WAY THAT'S
DIVERSIFIED ACROSS THE STATE
AND THAT EQUITY IS AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE CONVERSATION
WHICH I BELIEVE- WE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE ALL ALL
DISCUSSED- BE IT. I WANT TO
PIVOT ON TO THE ISSUE OF. EDT
I'M CURIOUS AS TO HOW THE-
LANGUAGE ACCESSIBILITY
COMPONENT IS GOING TO BE.
ROLLED OUT CAN YOU PLEASE
DETAIL WHAT IS PLANNED IN TERMS
OF LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
EXPANSION. SURE SURE LET ME
ACTUALLY ASK FOR SIGNS TO DO.
WE SUBJECT RESPONSE POSSIBLE
SHE DIDN'T MAKE IT NASTY
VARIOUS WITH EDT- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- YEAH NO PROBLEM OH
OKAY SORRY THAT SHE'S GOING AND
NANCY SORRY. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION SO- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE- I'VE MENTIONED THIS IN
SEVERAL FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO THE COMMITTEE- FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP- ON THIS ISSUE
IT IS SOMETHING THAT- YOU KNOW
EDT HAT AND YOU KNOW. IT HAS
BEEN WORKING ON FOR A WHILE-
AND YOU KNOW WITH THE HELP OF
THAT COMMITTEE EMBERS- AS WELL
AS THE STAKEHOLDERS- I THINK
WE'RE IN A GOOD PLACE TO START-
WHAT WE WANT TO DO AND YOU KNOW
BASICALLY WHAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE
IS YOU KNOW EVERYBODY WE HAVE
THE GOAL OF EVERYONE OF
SERVICING EVERYONE IN THEIR
NATIVE LANGUAGE THAT IT THAT IS
OUR GOAL- AND SO JUST JUST A
FEW THINGS JUST TO TOUCH ON-
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE. A
LANGUAGE ACCESS PORTAL- SO IT'S
EASIER FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
NAVIGATE THE WEBSITE- IN ACCESS
TRANSLATED FORMS IN THEIR
NATIVE LANGUAGE- WE'RE GOING TO
EXPAND THE TEAM TRANSIT ODD THE
TELEPHONE INTERPRETIVE SERVICE
SERVICES THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW- WE'RE LOOKING AT OVER. A.
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES. I AND OF- AS- THE
SECRETARY MENTIONED WE ARE
GOING TO- PROVIDE DIRECT GRANTS
TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- TO DO TARGETED
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION WE DO
SOME OF THAT INTERNALLY AT EDT
BUT WE REALIZED. THAT YOU KNOW
WE REALLY COULD USE THE- THE
HELP OF THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH THIS DAY
TODAY- WE ARE GOING TO BE
HIRING A MULTI LINGUAL. ACCESS
COORDINATOR- WITH DECISIONS
UNDERNEATH THAT PERSON TO
BASICALLY OVERSEE- ALL ALL OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
LANGUAGES- WE ARE WORKING ON-
HIRING ADDITIONAL STAFF. TO
PROCESS I'D NEW MULTI LINGUAL-
PAPER FAX AND PHONE
APPLICATIONS FOR THOSE THAT MAY
NOT HAVE ACCESS. TO ONLINE
SYSTEMS THAT WOULD- INCLUDE-
THE HIRING OF ABOUT THIRTY OR
SO- HE PR'S WHICH OF THE
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM
REPRESENTATIVES THAT WE SO
OFTEN TALK ABOUT. THAT HELP
CLAIMANTS NOW- AND- WE YOU KNOW
RECENTLY WE DID HIRE A CLAIMANT
STAKEHOLDER AS WELL IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY PART OF THE B. C.
P. BUT- HE DID- HIGHER CLAIM
AND STAKEHOLDER THAT'S HELPING
WITH A LOT OF THE- MARKETING
SOME OF THE PROMOTION TO DO
OUTREACH TO STAKEHOLDERS AND
WOULD LIKE TO JUST BRING THAT
ALL TOGETHER. THANK YOU I WANT
TO OPEN IT UP TO MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE DIETS MR CHU. THANK YOU
I'M GONNA BE BRIEF BECAUSE I
KNOW WE HAVE A LONG AGENDA
TODAY BUT FIRST I JUST WANT TO
THANK- THE AGENCY AND EDT FOR.
THE INVESTMENT THAT THEY
PROPOSED TO THE MAY REVISE- IN
THE LAST COMMITTEE HEARINGS ON
THIS. I THINK A NUMBER OF US
FROM THIS COMMITTEE WE
EXPRESSED. OUR HOPE THAT EDT
WAS GOING TO HAVE MORE BUDGET
PROPOSALS AND THE SPACE AND-
REALLY WANT TO COMMEND- TDD
DIRECTOR IN THE LABOR AGENCY
FOR COMING BACK TO US. WITH
WHAT I THINK ARE VERY
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENTS TO
ADDRESS OGOING ISSUES. BOB
SPECIFICALLY AROUND LANGUAGE
ACCESS AROUND IT MODERNIZATION
AROUND DIRECT DEPOSIT. BOB YOU
KNOW I KNOW THERE ARE STILL
MANY DETAILS TO BE HAMMERED OUT
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
CONVERSATION I WANT TO JUST ASK
ONE QUESTION WHICH WAS RELATED
TO THE ALLOCATION OF THE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
MONEY TO ADDRESS DEFERRED
WORKLOAD AND ONGOING WORK NO WE
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE'RE AT THE END
OF THE WE'RE SEEING THE LIGHT
AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PANDEMIC- BUT I
THINK WE ALL KNOW. WITH REGARD
ET DE THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
WORK BUT STILL HAS TO HAPPEN.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS EDT
ESTIMATES ARE THERE OVER ELEVEN
MILLION WORK ITEMS THAT STILL
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED THAT COULD
TAKE UP TO THREE AND A HALF
YEARS TO COMPLETE. BUT WITH THE
RECENT BUDGET PROPOSAL- WE CAN
HOPEFULLY BRING THAT WORKLOAD
DOWN TO TWELVE MONTHS WANT TO
JUST UNDERSTAND. HOW CERTAIN
ARE YOU AROUND THAT TWELVE
MONTH TIME PERIOD IS THERE ANY
WAY FOR US TO ACCELERATE THAT-
THAT DOES AS YOU CAN IMAGINE ON
BEHALF FOR CONSTITUENTS FEELS
LIKE AN AWFUL LONG TIME. TO
WAIT. FOR THE END OF THIS TIME
PERIOD. I THINK WE ALL REMEMBER
AT ONE OF THESE PRIOR HEARINGS
IN SEPTEMBER WE WERE TOLD THE
BACKLOG WAS COULD BE CLOSED BY
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S JUST
CONTINUED. ON WANT TO JUST GET
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON ON ON THAT
TIME FRAME AND WHETHER THERE'S
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO PULL THAT
UP IT INCLUDING. MORE
EXPENDITURE IN THIS AREA. I'M
HAPPY TO DIRECT THAT TO THE
DIRECTOR OR TWO MYSTERIOUS.
WHOEVER WANTS ANSWERS.
REDESIGNS YOU GATE. SO MANY
CLARIFIED THAT THE ONE POINT
SIX MILLION- BACK HAS BEEN
COMPLETED. THAT'S NOT THE
WORKLOAD THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS IF YOU RECALL
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE HEIGHT O
THE PANDEMIC WHILE WE WERE
WORRIED ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE
PAID. WE CHANGED OUR POLICIES
AND HELD BACK SOME
DETERMINATION PROCESSES. THAT
IS THE WORKLOAD THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOW. SO I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAD A LOT OF
CONCERN ABOUT THAT ONE POINT
SIX MILLION AND SO I WANT TO
REASSURE YOU THAT JOB. IT THAT
WAS HANDLED IN JANUARY SO COULD
I JUST UNDERSTAND BECAUSE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE STILL A
MILLION FOLKS WERE OUT THERE
FOR HIM THERE IS NOT RESOLUTION
OF WHERE THEIR THEIR THEIR
THEIR CASES ARE- IF YOU COULD
YES. AND THAT'S IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
WE WERE JUST GETTING A HAMMER
WITH CALLS WE SEE ALL THESE
NUMBERS AND WE UNDERSTAND NOT
ONE POINT SIX MAYBE IT'S ONE
POINT OH. WHAT WE TALKING ABOUT
OR NOT YES THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION ASSEMBLY WHEN ARE WE-
D. NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT YOU SEE WHO ARE READING.
OF THAT WE HAD YOUR FOR YOUR
TAKE A LOOK AT OUR DASHBOARD WE
HAVE A DIVIDED INTO TWO PARTS.
WE HAVE A NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WE ARE WAITING FOR THEM
TO CONTACT US. TO CERTIFY. FOR
THEIR BENEFITS YEAH IT'S BEEN A
MYSTERY TO OUR AND WE HAVE.
COMMUNICATED WITH THIS GROUP AT
LEAST THREE TIMES BY. EMAIL BY
TEXT ARE ENCOURAGING THEM TO
CERTIFY. THAT'S THAT'S THE
FIRST. THEN THERE'S A BUCKET OF
BACKLOG OF OURS THERE HAS BEEN
NO EXPERIENCED A SURGE IN PART
DUE TO THE- IN END OF BENEFIT
YEAR IT'S REALLY IT'S REALLY
MAGNIFIED THE WORKLOAD AND I
AND I KNOW THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT BECAUSE THIS IS HAPPENING
FOR LEGISLATIVE STAFF AS WELL-
WE HAVE. A HUNDRED NINETY NINE
THOUSAND- CASES THAT ARE TWENTY
ONE DAYS LATE AT. WE'RE WORKING
ON NOW THIS WORKABLE. IS
NEITHER ONE OF THOSE ITEMS.
THIS WORKLOAD THIS ARE DEFERRED
WORKLOAD IS WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DETERMINED THE DETERMINATIONS
NEED TO BE COMPLETED. AND THE
REASON THAT'S SO IMPORTANT IS
THAT. THEY ONE OF OUR CONCERNS
OVER PAYMENTS AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE GET TO PEOPLE IN
TIME SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
HUGE OVERPAYMENT PROBLEM SO
THAT'S PART OF THE REASON THAT
WE'RE GOING BACK TO THESE
DETERMINATIONS SO THAT'S A
SEPARATE ARE DEFERRED WORKLOAD.
I HOPE I ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION. I THINK SO BUT YOU
KNOW AGAIN WHAT I'M ASSUMING IS
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TWELVE
MORE MONTHS BEFORE THESE ELEVEN
MILLION WORK ITEMS THAT INVOLVE
A LOT OF FOLKS GET RESOLVED AND
THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN DO TO
REALLY BRING THAT TIME FRAME UP.
ARE AT THE VARIOUS WITH WINDY
DAYS SO I MEAN I CAN SAY THAT
THAT IS THAT IS THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL- YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW-
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW GIVING THE-
GIVEN THE PROJECTIONS THAT WE
DID THAT'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE I
MEAN WE ALWAYS. YOU KNOW
DEPENDING ON IF THEY CAN GET
THROUGH SOMETHING FASTER THAN
SOMETHING ELSE I MEAN THERE IS
A POSSIBILITY THAT IT TAKES
LESS TIME. WE'RE WE'RE
CERTAINLY NOT OPPOSED TO THAT-
BUT GIVEN THE UP THE NUMBER OF
HOURS THAT THAT WERE POINTED
OUT. YEAH THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW. OKAY I JUST
WANTED TO ASK- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY TWELVE MONTHS IS AN
AWFUL LOT OF TIME RIGHT NOW FOR
FOLKS ARE STRUGGLING SO. WANNA
MAKE THAT POINT IF IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE TO USE SOME PORTION
OF THE- TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF BUDGET SURPLUS TO
ADDRESS THAT AND BRING THAT
DOWN WE ARE. TALKING ABOUT
POTENTIALLY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WE COULD OTHERWISE GET OUT
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS ON THAT SO-
LOOK FOR TO MORE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT AND- WITH THAT'LL
TURN IT BACK OVER TO MANAGER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER TO
EITHER ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. NOW I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LONG AGENDA I DO HAVE
ONE- ONE PENDING QUESTION
REGARDS FOR EDT REGARDING THE
BANK OF AMERICA CONTRACT WHICH
IS SCHEDULED TO END THIS SUMMER
HAVE YOU ALREADY STARTED THE
ARTS P. FOR DIRECT DEPOSIT IF
NOT. CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
WHAT EFFORTS WILL BE UNDERTAKEN
TO ENSURE THE JUST TRANSITION
TO A POTENTIALLY A NEW
CONTRACTOR. THANK YOU VERY
SWEET EDT- WE HAVE NOT STARTED
THE ACTUAL RFP PROCESS ITSELF
FOR THE DIRECT DEPOSIT BUT WE
ARE I MAY HAVE MENTIONED- IN
THE- IN A PREVIOUS HEARING
THAT. WE ARE LOOKING AT ALL THE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS THAT WE HOPE
THAT WE HAVE INCLUDING USING
THE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE- AND
THE DIFFERENT- WHAT IS
AVAILABLE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
AND SO I DO ANTICIPATE- AT
SOMETHING YOU KNOW IN THE NEXT
PROBABLY COUPLE OF WEEKS ON
THAT. OKAY PLEASE PLEASE KEEP
US. POSTED AS AS SOON AS YOU
CAN. I HAD A- COMMENT AND
UNFORTUNATELY MR NECESSARY AND
HOW TO. TO LEAD TO CATCH A
FLIGHT BUT- HE BROUGHT UP IN A
PREVIOUS- HEARING AND I'M
CURIOUS IF THERE'S BEEN ANY
MOVEMENT ON THAT ON THAT- IT
WHEN WE ANTICIPATE THERE'S
GOING TO BE A MAJOR INFLUX. OF
CLIENTS COMING YOUR WAY TO EDT
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED MAYBE DOING
SOME SOME VIDEOS IN ADVANCE
POTENTIALLY ON YOUTUBE SO OR ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THAT DESCRIBE.
WHAT TO DO WHERE TO GO HOW TO
ACCESS RESOURCES. SO THAT OUR
OUR OFFICES ARE ALSO NOT
INUNDATED WITH THE SAME
QUESTIONS AND THE WEBSITE IS
VERY HARD TO NAVIGATE. WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE FOR YOU AND
ALSO LIKE AND THE IMPACT THAT
WOULD HAVE ON YOUR CALL CENTER
I IMAGINE. ANY UPDATES. ALL
REDESIGNS FROM EDG. SO ARE.
THERE ARE WHAT YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS I SAY OFTEN IS THAT.
LEGISLATORS HAVE BEEN VERY
FORTHCOMING. WITH THEIR
SUGGESTIONS AND OPINIONS. AND
ARE WE REALLY TOOK THAT COMMENT
TO HEART WE KNOW THAT EVERYONE
WAS SURPRISED BY THE- INCREASE
AT THAT BENEFIT YEAR END. AND
WE ARE. MOVING OUR
COMMUNICATIONS. ACTIVITIES TO
THE BEGINNING OF. THE
DISCUSSIONS OF ANY CHANGES THAT
WERE MAKING. SO THAT WE CAN
BEGIN TO. CATCH THIS IN
ADVANCE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. GOOD I'M I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT THERE'S SOME
DIRECTION MOVING ON THAT THAT
AND THAT'S ANTICIPATING VERSES
REACTING- WHICH REACTING CAN
OFTEN BE VERY VERY DELAYED-
WHICH CAUSES US A LOT OF
HEARTACHE IN TERMS OF- SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS IN NEED
ASSISTANCE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE TIME WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
OF THE MAYOR'S I'M SORRY THE
GOVERNOR'S MAYBE VISION
PROPOSALS ON EQUITABLE- AND
BROAD BASED RECOVERY. LET'S
BEGIN. WE HAVE- MISTER WHITE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AS WELL AS MR JOHNSON CHAS
ALAMO WITHOUT LEO AND- BRIAN
WHETHER FOR WITH THE L. L. AS
WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE YELLING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TOMORROW JOHNSON WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS RELATED
TO EQUITABLE AND BROAD BASED
RECOVERY. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NOT. THAT HAVE
BEEN HARDEST HIT BY THE
PANDEMIC. IN MARCH THE STATE
ENACTED THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS WHICH IS THIS IS
CRAFTED TO PROVIDE TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION TO FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS TO HELP THEM DEAL
WITH THE ECONOMIC DISTRESS
CAUSED BY AND DAMAGE. THAT
MAYBE YOU SHOULD PROPOSES A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION TO THE
FIRST GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS AND
TARGETS A LOW TO MIDDLE INCOME
INDIVIDUALS. WITH AN ADDITIONAL
FOCUS ON FAMILY. IT IS EXPECTED
TO GROW BY EIGHT POINT ONE
BILLION IN TAX REBATES TO
ELEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS AND TO OVER TWENTY
ONE MILLION INDIVIDUALS.
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
CORBETT NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE ELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESSES AFFECTED BY
THE PANDEMIC WITH MICROGRAMS OF
UP TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. SO FAR TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO
THIS PROGRAM AND HAS SUPPORTED
SIX ROUNDS OF GRANTS INCLUDING
AROUND FOR NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS. THAT MAY REVISION
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION TO FIND
THREE ADDITIONAL ROUNDS OF
GRANTS. UP TO FIFTY MILLION
ALLOCATED FOR NONPROFIT
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS ONLY
THIRTY FOUR MILLION WAS AWARDED
TO ELIGIBLE RECIPIENTS. THAT
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO OPEN
ADDITIONAL ROUNDS OF. RIGHT
ELIGIBLE NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS UNTIL THE
REMAINING SIXTEEN MILLION HAS
BEEN AWARDED. THE MAY REVISION
BUILDS ON THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
INITIATIVE PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS OWNERS AS
THEY RE OPEN THEIR DOORS WE
HIRE STAFF AND EXPEDITE THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY. THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE INCLUDED TEN
BILLION FOR THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE STATE
SMALL BUSINESS CREDIT
INITIATIVE TO STRENGTHEN STATE
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT FINANCING
A SMALL BUSINESSES. CALIFORNIA
IS ESTIMATED TO RECEIVE AT
LEAST EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY
FIVE MILLION IN THREE TRANCHES.
THE U. S. TREASURY IS STILL
DEVELOPING THEIR GUIDANCE FOR
PROGRAMS AND ANTICIPATES
ROLLING THEM OUT OVER THE NEXT
TWO TO SIX MONTHS. GIVEN THE
AVAILABILITY OF ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL STATE SMALL BUSINESS
CREDIT INITIATIVE FUNDING THE
MAY REVISION REDUCES THE AMOUNT
BUSINESS
FROM THE FIFTY MILLION
PROVIDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
TO TWENTY MILLION. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO CONTINUES THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION ONE
TIME TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA
COMPETES GRANT PROGRAM FOR
BUSINESSES THAT PROMISE TO MEET
SPECIFIC CRITERIA. ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MILLION ONE TIME TO
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA COMPETES
TAX CREDIT TO ENCOURAGE
BUSINESSES TO COMMIT TO
CREATING JOBS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY AND ADVANCED
TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
AUTHORITY SALES TAX EXCLUSION
THAT MAY REVISION INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME TO
EXPAND ITS SALES TAX EXCLUSION
WITH ENCOURAGING. WHICH
ENCOURAGES AND BASS
MANUFACTURING AND GREEN
TECHNOLOGY. THE MAY REVISION
EXPANDS THE MAIN STREET SMALL
BUSINESS TAX CREDIT USING FORTY
SEVEN MILLION FROM THE FIRST
ROUND AND ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO PROVIDE
CREDITS TO BUSINESSES WITH UP
TO FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND A
20% DECLINE IN SALES. IT
DIGITALLY THE MAY REVISION
CREATES AN ELECTIVE TAX FOR
PASS THROUGH ENTITIES TO HELP
MITIGATE WHAT IMPACT. BUSINESS
OWNERS OF THE LIMITATION ON
STATE AND LOCAL TAX DEDUCTIONS
DUE TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FEDERAL TAX CUTS AND
JOBS ACT AND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FUNDS THIRTY FIVE MILLION
IS FOR MY PROGRAM TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SEE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP THE MAY
REVISION SHIFTS THIS FUNDING
FROM. TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
LASTLY THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING ONE TIME
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
TOURISM INDUSTRY TO ADDRESS THE
NEGATIVE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
CAUSED BY THE PANDEMIC. NINETY
FIVE MILLION AMERICANS RESCUE
PLAN PACKED FUNDING TO CONTRACT
WITH VISIT CALIFORNIA TO
IMPLEMENT STRATEGIC MEDIA
RECOVERY CAMPAIGNS THAT WOULD
JUMP START A QUICK RECOVERY OF
CALIFORNIANS TRAVEL AND TOURISM
INDUSTRY ONCE IT'S SAFE TO
TRAVEL. TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ARKLA FUNDING TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
CALIFORNIA'S ELEVEN PUBLIC
PORTS ON THE BASIS OF REVENUE
LOST AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND THIRTY MILLION TO
EXPAND THE FILM TAX CREDIT FOR
PRODUCTIONS THAT WEEK LOCATE
FROM OTHER JURISDICTIONS ADD
THIS CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION
WE HAVE FINANCE STAFFING
DEPARTMENT EXPERTS ON HAND TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LET'S HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS. NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ABOUT THE L. A. U.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAD ALOE AGAIN
FROM THE L. A. L. ALL SPEAK TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS PROPOSAL AND
ENTERED MY COLLEAGUE BRIAN
WHETHER FOR- TO DISCUSS THE
BUSINESS SIDE- COMPONENTS OF
THE PROPOSALS ON. THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED A SECOND BROADER
ROUNDED GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
PAYMENTS TOTALING EIGHT POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
FAMILIES WITHOUT A DOUBT THE
GROSS INCOME UP TO SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON THE COST OF
THAT SECOND ROUND IS. SLIGHTLY
MORE THAN DOUBLE THE COST OF
THE FIRST ROUND OF THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS PAYMENTS AND
THIS IS BECAUSE THE BROADER
SECOND ROUND WOULD PROVIDE
PAYMENTS TO CALIFORNIANS WITH
HIGHER EARNINGS SO THERE WILL
BE MORE. BENEFITS- DISTRIBUTOR.
I WE KNOW IT IN OUR- OF THE
GOVERNOR'S FIRST PROPOSED ROUND.
BONTA STATE'S. ESPECIALLY
RELATIVE TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE PANDEMIC
RELIEF IS LIMITED- AT THAT TIME
AND WE CONTINUED TODAY TO
RECOMMEND THAT THE OLD EPIDEMIC
RELIEF OF THIS SORT BE TARGETED
TO THOSE MOST IN NEED. AND IT
FOCUSES ON THOSE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL AND A RELEASE- AND
MOST NOTABLY THIS GROUP OF
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO FILE
TAXES USING AN ITEM. ON IN
REVIEWING THE GOVERNOR SECOND
ROUND GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS.
BECAUSE ALL- WE FIND AT THE
BACK MAJORITY OF THE PROPOSED
PAYMENTS WILL GO TO HOUSEHOLDS
WITH ALREADY RECEIVED. FEDERAL
STIMULUS CHECKS- AS ONE
EXAMPLE- COMPARING TWO
OTHERWISE SIMILAR HOUSEHOLDS OF
FORCE OF TWO WORKERS IN TWO
CHILDREN- I GREW UP IN THE
HOUSEHOLD THAT IT'S ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL STIMULUS CHECKS
WHAT ABOUT THIS TIME RECEIVED
ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN COMBINED FEDERAL BENEFITS
UNDER THOSE THREE. SETS OF
PETROL STIMULUS PAYMENTS
WHEREAS A SIMILAR HOUSEHOLD BUT
WITH UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO
ARE INELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL AID
BUT ONLY HAVE RECEIVED ABOUT.
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AT THIS
POINT. I'M SO MY OF THIS
INEQUITY- WE PERCENT ALTER. AND
RECALL THAT WE JUST PUBLISHED
THIS- BUT THE ONE. CONSIDER IF
YOU WANT MORE. TARGET STATE
STIMULUS ASSISTANCE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS THAT THE
FIRST EXAMPLE OR ALTERNATIVE
THIS IS WHAT WE CALL THE EXPAND
ALTERNATIVES- FOR INSTANCE THE
LEGISLATURE ADDED. ON TOP OF
THE EIGHT POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSING OF A
REVISION. TO PROVIDE. INCREASED
BENEFITS TO UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS AS AN EXAMPLE HAVING
TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
STIMULUS PROPOSAL WE ESTIMATE.
THAT SALES PAYMENTS FOR FUND
DOCUMENTED WORKERS COULD BE
INCREASED FROM FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS EACH WHICH IS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH. OUR
SECOND ALTERNATIVE OF IF WE
PROPOSAL LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION WHAT WE CALL THE
REDIRECT ALTERNATIVE- AND IN
ESSENCE THIS WOULD WORK WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
AMOUNT OF EIGHT POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. BUT INSTEAD
LIMIT- STIMULUS CHECKS FOR THE
SECOND ROUND TO HOUSEHOLDS
WITH. ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME UP
TO FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
RATHER THAN SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EXAMPLE- RESPONSE
COULD BE YEARS BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
PAYMENTS. MADE TO DOCUMENT IT
HOUSEHOLDS BOB WE BELIEVE IN
THIS EXAMPLE THAT PAYMENTS
COULD BE INCREASED FROM FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT
HOUSEHOLDS- THAT THAT SCHOOLS
THAT I PRESENTED ARE SIMPLY
EXAMPLES OF THESE TWO OPTIONS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS WHEN
WORKING WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO. TARGET STATE AIDED
TO FILL IN THE GAPS IN FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE. TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTRIAL MUCH
APPOINT OF KERR FOR. WHAT DO
YOU MEAN BY. UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS AND THE SPACE. I'M NOT
REAL IS IT REALLY TO THIS
REALLY TO I'D OR SEPARATE.
THAT'S RIGHT I SHOULD HAVE BEEN
MORE CLEAR YOU'LL HAVE TO
FORGIVE ME- ON THE FIRST ROUND
OF GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
PAYMENTS INCLUDE PAYMENTS TO
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO FILE
TAXES USING HIGH TEN OF THE
SECOND ROUND OF PROPOSED
PAYMENTS WHICH WOULD FOLLOW THE
SAME STRUCTURE AND THE FISCAL
ESTIMATES THAT WE PRESENTED
JUST NOW- ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THAT SO. THE SMALLER SORT OF
SUBSET OF THE STATE'S
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS WHO FILE
THEIR TAXES USING. THANK YOU
AND THE WANT TO MAKE A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION THAT NOT ALL I
TEN TAXPAYERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED
WE HAVE TPS RECIPIENTS THAT ARE
ALSO- I TEND TO TAXPAYERS SO
JUST. JUST FOR CLARITY IN TERMS
OF THE POPULATION THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE THERE ARE
SEVERAL DOCUMENTED WORKERS AT.
A FALL WITHIN DIFFERENCE BASIS
OF WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. YOU'RE
RIGHT GENERAL TAKE THAT POINT
OF CLARITY INTO. CONVERSATION
THANK YOU SO WE ARE SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT. IN YOUR IN
YOUR ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL ABOUT
INCREASING THE FUNDING OR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND RESOURCES FOR
ITIN TAXPAYERS. PREVIOUS DURING
THE BEGINNING OF CODED WHERE WE
HAD THE ADDITIONAL PLAN GOING
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY NONPROFIT
GROUPS THAT WERE SERVING
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WITHOUT
WITHOUT ITEMS CORRECT. THAT'S
RIGHT YEAH OKAY JUST I WHAT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE CLEAR ON THAT. THANK YOU.
FOR ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. I JUST HAVE
A I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
I'M GONNA START WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESS PROGRAM CAN WE GET
SOME CLARIFICATION IN TERMS OF
HOW MANY APPLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
PLANTED YES SO SOARED INTO A
MEDICARE I'D LIKE TO- PRESENT
OUR COMMENTS ON THE SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS OLYMPIC ENERGY
JOBS AND IF YOU DON'T MIND I'M
SO SORRY MISTER WEATHERFORD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S QUITE
ALRIGHT THERE'S A LOT ON THE
AGENDA TODAY- SO I'LL BE VERY
BRIEF- THE GOVERNOR'S ON. X.
THE PROPOSAL TO- PROPOSES. TO
EXPAND THE- COVERED RELIEF
GRANT FROM BY ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION. DOLLARS WOULD PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR MORE
THAN- A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS I MEAN I'M
SORRY- A HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND MORE GRANTS. AT THE
SAME TIME THE PROGRAM TODAY HAS
RECEIVED A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND MORE APPLICATIONS AND
I WAS ABLE TO FIND. AND SO WE-
WE ESTIMATE THAT ANOTHER EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
BE NECESSARY TO FIND ALL OF THE
GRANTS THAT HAVE BEEN REQUESTED
SO FAR AND WE- UNDERSTAND THAT-
THERE ARE VARIOUS OBJECTIVES
FOR THESE GRANTS AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH IN YOUR
STUFF TO THINK ABOUT VERY SALT.
OF FUNDING ALTERNATIVES.
REGARDING THE- THE JOBS
INITIATIVES- THE GOVERNOR.
PROPOSED SEVERAL NEW
INITIATIVES TO EXPAND THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PROPOSALS AND
WE PROVIDED SOME COMMENTS IN
JANUARY. THAT WE THINK STILL
APPLY. AND I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT- ARE KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT. THE
FIRST IS WE RECOMMEND REJECTING
THE PROPOSED INCREASE IN THE
CAP ON THE KATE. EXCLUSIONS
BECAUSE ROUGHLY TWO THIRDS OF
THE COST. WILL BE BORNE BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND MOREOVER
WE DO NOT TINK THIS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES EFFECTIVE. OR TIMELY
PANDEMIC RELEASE. WE SIMILARLY
WRECKED REJECTING THE PROPOSED
EXPANSIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES. GRANT PROGRAM BECAUSE
THE LEGISLATURE COULD PROVIDE
MORE EFFECTIVE ECONOMIC RELIEF
TO BUSINESSES IN OTHER WAYS. IN
PARTICULAR WE PREVIOUSLY NOTED
THAT EXPANDING THE MAINSTREAM
HIRING CREDIT. WOULD BE WELL
SUITED TO ASSISTING THOSE
BUSINESSES THAT WERE HIT
HARDEST BY THE PANDEMIC. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ONE TIME
FUNDING TO THE CALIFORNIA HAS
MERIT. SINCE THE TOURISM
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO BE
DEPRESSED WE FURTHER RECOMMEND
CONSIDERING A TEMPORARY
REDUCTION IN THE TOURISM
ASSESSMENT FEE TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO TOURISM BUSINESSES.
AND LASTLY WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANTS TO THE PORT AUTHORITIES.
IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES WANT TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE PORTS WE RECOMMEND LINKING
GRANTS TO COMMITMENTS TO
ACHIEVE OTHER STATEWIDE POLICY
OBJECTIVES SUCH AS IMPROVING
AIR QUALITY. OR ADAPTING TO SEA
LEVEL RISE NECKLACE OR COMMENTS
ON THOSE ON PARTS OF THE PER
THE PACKAGE. THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATED LET SOME LET'S
START WITH SOME SOME QUESTIONS
AND- HOW MANY APPLICATIONS HAVE
BEEN FUNDED WITH THERE ARE
CURRENT ROUND OF FUNDING AND
HOW MANY APPLICATIONS REMAIN ON
THE WAIT LIST. IS THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING INTENDED TO
FOCUS ON THOSE WHO ARE ON WAIT
LISTS ON THE WAIT LIST OR NEW
APPLICANTS. THIS IS RELATED TO
THE SMALL BUSINESS PROGRAM.
CAROLYN GRAY HERE HELLO SB A
DIRECTOR. WE HAVE RECEIVED TO
DATE FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND I FINISHED
APPLICATIONS WHICH REPRESENTS
JUST OVER SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN REQUEST. AND OF THOSE HOW
MANY HAVE BEEN FUNDED. WE HAD
THE EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE SUNDAY OR AWARDS MADE.
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND FUNDED
OKAY AND- ALL OF THE COMPLETED
SO YOU HAVE. FOR TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE THOUSAND COMPLETED
APPLICATIONS EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED
WHAT IS A PERCENTAGE OF THE OF
THE DIFFERENCE THAT WILL BE
MOVING FORWARD. ARE THEY ALL ON
THE WAIT LIST OR IS THE
PERCENTAGE OR IS A PORTION OF
THAT LIKE SIMPLY NOT MOVING
FORWARD. WELL THERE WILL BE A
PERCENTAGE OF THE APPLICATIONS
THAT FOR WHATEVER REASON DO NOT
MOVE FORWARD TO SAY.
VERIFICATION OR VALIDATION
PROCESS SEES- WE HAVE CONTROLS
IN PLACE FOR FRAUD WASTE AND
ABUSE. ON THE INSTILL-
POTENTIALLY THERE IS A
PERCENTAGE OF APPLICATIONS THAT
WILL NOT MOVE FORWARD FOR THAT
REASON. OKAY SO IT'S THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE WAIT
LIST OF THE DIFFERENCE OR FOR
NEW APPLICANTS. OR A COMMON
COLD WE INTEND TO ACHIEVE BOTH
ON WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO DO IS
TO RUN- BROWN'S FOR. CLOSED
BROWN'S FOR A WAIT LISTED ON
APPLICATIONS AND- ROUND A FINAL
ROUND THAT WOULD BE OPEN TO
EVERYONE. SO WE HOPE TO ACHIEVE
BOTH. AND WHAT ARE THE- THANK
YOU AND WHAT ARE THE
MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS TO DO
THAT LIKE WHAT IS THE
ANTICIPATION PLAN OR THE
ANTICIPATED PLAN. TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT. WE FOR NEW
APPLICATIONS- THAT HAVE NOT YET
ACCESS THE PROGRAM. WE WOULD BE
GOING BACK TO THE PARTNERS IN
THE NETWORK AND RESUME THE
WEBINARS. AND OUT REACH THAT
WE- HAVE BEEN DOING. IT WITH A
D. INCLUDE YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
INVITATIONS TO MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE LOCAL CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS. CBS CHAMBERS ON SMALL
BUSINESS AND ETHNIC
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE
OUTREACH. I ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE HAVE PROPOSED ON THE
FINAL ROUND TO BE AN OPENING
ROUND. AS WE WOULD LIKE TO GET
THE MAXIMUM AND THAT AMOUNT OF
TIME POSSIBLE. TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH. THANK YOU THAT WE
EVEN HIT THOSE THAT DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE PROGRAM TO DATE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY WANTED TO
DISCUSS THE ADDITIONAL OUT
REACH. OUT REACH PROVISIONS CAN
YOU EXPLAIN OR GIVE ME THE PLAN
IN WHICH YOU'RE OUT REACHING TO
A DIVERSE POOL OF RESOURCES AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
SMALL CHAMBERS TO ENSURE THAT-
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT MAY NOT
BE TAPPED INTO EXISTING.
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES ALSO
KNOW THAT THIS FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE. YES- GO AHEAD DID
YOU NOTICE OKAY I APOLOGIZE
THAT IT BROKE UP JUST A LITTLE
BIT YES TO DATE WE HAVE SEVENTY
FOUR ON ETHNIC MEDIA PARTNERS
ON THAT ARE ALREADY ENGAGED WE
ARE PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ACROSS OUR NETWORK
PARTNERS AND THIRTY DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES ARE REPRESENTED ON
AND IT DOES NETWORK PARTNERS
AND STILL WE EXPECT TO CONTINUE
TO AMPLIFY AND TO RELY ON OUR
NETWORK PARTNERS TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THAT HELP REACH AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SUPPORT.
AND WHAT ARE THE METRICS OF
SUCCESS TO DO THAT THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OKAY I'M
GONNA REACH OUT I'M GONNA DO
OUR REACH WITH THE SEVENTY
FOUR. COMMUNITY PARTNERS BUT
THE RESULTS OF THE APPLICATIONS
MAY NOT MAYOR THE SUCCESS RATE
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S DIVERSITY
AND EQUITY IN THE SMALL
BUSINESS PROPOSAL GRANT SO.
WHAT DOES THAT ACTUALLY LOOK
LIKE. I THINK THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO- PARTNER WITH
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE REACHING
INTO DISTRICTS AND AREAS. WHERE
THE TARGET POPULATION THE IS. I
THINK THAT- WE HAVE SEEN A
CORRELATED IMPACT. FROM ROUNDS
ONE INTO- VERSES THE LATER
ROUNDS WERE WEEK INCREASED- THE
ETHNIC MEDIA PARTICIPATION.
INCREASED IN LANGUAGE SUPPORT
WE SAW. A POOR LADY INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF SUCCESSFUL
APPLICATIONS AND AWARDS. SO I
CAN GET IT WOULD BE REASONABLE.
I'M TO BELIEVE THAT MOVING
FORWARD IF WE WERE TO-
CONTINUE. I'LL OR TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON THE IN LANGUAGE AND
RURAL AREAS SUPPORT THAT WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE. I'M THE
SAMETYPE. OF IMPROVEMENT IN
WARDS. THANK YOU I WOULD SAY TO
YOUR COMMENT OF WORKING THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S PARTNERSHIP AND THE
PREVIOUS- ISSUE AREA THAT WE
COVERED IT WITH EDT. BECAUSE OF
THE ISSUES WITH EDT AND ARE
STAFFED ESPECIALLY OUR
DISTRICTS STOPS BEING SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY WORKING ON CASES
WITH EDT. IT HAS NOT ALLOWED
OUR LEGISLATIVE AND DISTRICT
OFFICES TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
WORK. THAT TRADITIONALLY WE
WOULD HAVE DONE TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY
TO- PROGRAM EQUALLY WITH YOU TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE DOING THE
OUR REACH NECESSARY SO I WOULD
JUST. YOU KNOW IN FOR LACK OF
BETTER WORD JUST PUSH BACK A
LITTLE BECAUSE WE ARE ALSO AT
CAPACITY AND SO WE ARE LOOKING
WE ARE LOOKING TO YOU FOR SOME
GUIDANCE IN TERMS OF HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT. YOU KNOW
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LOW INCOME
MICRO BUSINESSES MICRO
ENTERPRISES AT CETERA HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS WEEK THESE
RESOURCES AND- AND THAT THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO AND THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO DO THAT
OUTRAGE IS AT THE FRONT AND
CENTER OF THE CONVERSATION. AND
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING THE
MEASUREMENTS AND METRICS OF
SUCCESS OF WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
KNOWING. THAT BECAUSE OF.
ISSUES RELATED TO EDT IN THE
OFFICE AND OUR OFFICE IS
WORKING ON THOSE CASES. WE ARE
ALSO NOT A CAPACITY TO BE ABLE
TO ASSIST IN THE MANNER THAT WE
WOULD TRADITIONALLY DO. YES I
UNDERSTAND. AND THOSE ARE
PRIORITY AREAS AS WELL. AND WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE THAT WE
CAN TO REACH INTO THOSE AREAS-
THE ONLY THING THAT I WOULD
SAY. I'M REGARDING THAT IS THAT
YOU ALL KNOW YOUR CONSTITUENCY
BETTER THAN WE DO. AND SO WE-
HAVE LOOKED TO ENGAGE AS MUCH
AS WE CAN WITH MEMBERS SO THAT
WE- TARGET THE AREAS THAT YOU
ALL KNOW. ME TO BE TARGETED
WITHIN YOUR DISTRICTS SO AND
UNDERSTOOD WE ARE ALL TRACKS.
THANKS THANK YOU YES WE ARE. I
pGOOD AS WE POSSIBLY CAN TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE RESOURCES. TO
BE ABLE TO STAY OPEN TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY AND TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP THE AUTHENTICITY OF THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WE ALL
REPRESENT AND TO BE ABLE TO
STAY OPEN AND EMPLOYED LOCALLY
AND- TO ALL THE WONDERFUL
THINGS THAT ARE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY DOESN'T THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT. I WANT TO
PIVOT JUST A LITTLE BIT- IN THE
SAME TOPIC RELATED TO ART
MUSEUMS AND CULTURAL ARTS
CENTERS THAT CATER TO ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AS WELL SPECIFICALLY THAT
HAPPEN. HARDEST HIT- AND DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC WHAT ARE THE LONG
TERM EFFECTS OF HAVING THE
CENTERS POTENTIALLY SHUT DOWN.
AND WHAT'S YOUR FINANCIAL
IMPACT TO FULLY RECOVER AT AND
HOW CAN WE SUPPORT OUR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS- BY FUNDING THEM-
FUNDING THE CENTERS AT THIS
TIME. I THINK THAT- AS- FIRST
OF ALL OUR CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT- COMMUNITY ASSETS-
BUT- YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I.
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS TO AT THE
MOMENT BUT- MY OFFICE COULD
CERTAINLY. WORK WITH YOU TO
FOLLOW UP ON ON THE SPECIFICS
THAT THAT. HAPPENED TO YOU I'M
HAVE A CALL. TO ENJOY DOWN ON
THAT OKAY. THANK YOU THAT WOULD
BE GREAT AS WE KNOW THAT ARTS
AND CULTURE PLAY A HUGE ROLE IN
THE MORALE OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS THE- YOU KNOW
UNDERSTANDING. THAT YOU KNOW
WHERE WE COME FROM WHERE WE'RE
GOING IN OUR HISTORY ETCETERA
AND- SCIENCE IS CLEARLY. AT THE
AT THE HEAD OF THE CONVERSATION
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS. MEXICAN
MOMENT THAT WE'RE LIVING
THROUGH IT SO THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE. I WOULD APPRECIATE
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
THAT. I WANT TO PIVOT A LITTLE
BIT TOO- THE FILM TAX CREDIT. A
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
AND THIRTY MILLION. IN ADDITION
FOR A FUNDING TO. TO KEEP
PROJECTS HERE- I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT BETTER
AS TO WHAT THE DIVERSITY
EFFORTS ARE FOR THE FILM. TAX
CREDIT AND WHAT ARE THE TRADE
OFFS. CALLING BELL THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- OUR DIVERSITY TO
CREATE. DIVERSITY REQUIREMENT
CAREER READINESS INITIATIVE IN
PILOT SKILLS TRAINING PROGRAM.
ENCOURAGE AND CLINTON'S
INCLUSIVENESS FOR PROVIDING.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
FROM DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS- WE
JUST LAUNCHED THREE POINT OUT
IN. JULY IN WITH THE PASSAGE OF
THREE POINT OUT FUNDING WAS
ESTABLISHED TO CONTRIBUTIONS.
MADE BY THE APPROVED- PROJECTS
THAT ARE IN OUR PROGRAM TO
CREATE A PILOT SKILLS TRAINING
PROGRAM. THAT TARGETS PEOPLE IN
UNDER SERVED- AREAS AND UNDER
REPRESENTED AREAS- SO THAT THEY
CAN RECEIVE TRAINING AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
PRODUCTION WORK. AND WE ALSO
HAVE A DIVERSITY INITIATIVE
WITH IN THREE POINT OH THAT
REQUIRES MANDATORY- SUMMARY AT
THE RAP OF THE PRODUCTION ABOUT
THE HIRING PRACTICES ALL OF FOR
WOMEN AND MINORITIES WE ALSO
HAVE A CAREER READINESS
PROGRAM- AND THE CAREER
READINESS PROGRAM- TARGETS HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND- AND PEOPLE
FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO
PROVIDE PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE
FOR THEM SO WE HAVE A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IN PLACE.
CAN YOU PROVIDE SOME STATISTICS
IN TERMS OF WHAT THAT DIVERSITY
AND EQUITY ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT IS
THE PERCENTAGE OF. THE
FILMMAKERS THAT ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO API WHAT IS
THE BELOW THE LINE TRAINING
LOOK LIKE AND WHAT IS THE
WRITER'S ROOM LOOK LIKE I
IMAGINED THAT. THESE ARE ALL
PART OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
YOU HAVE WHEN YOU APPROVE. OF
THE PROJECT MOVING FORWARD OR
AS THE INDUSTRY SAID WHEN YOU
GREEN LIGHT A PROJECT. MOVING
FORWARD. WHY WOULDN'T THE
EXPANSION OF OPPORTUNITY IS
FUNDAMENTAL I CAN GIVE YOU SOME
STTISTICS ON- SINCE. TWO TWO
THOUSAND NINE APPROVED PROJECTS
IN PROGRAM TO POINT UP SUBMIT
DIVERSITY INFORMATION FOR CAST
AND CREW MEMBERS THAT ARE
HIRED- THIS INFORMATION WAS
VOLUNTARILY SUPPLIED- IT DOES
NOT REPRESENT FULLY THE CASTING
CREW HIRED BUT- OUT OF A
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE PROJECTS.
EXCLUDING BACKGROUND
PERFORMERS- THERE WERE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND.
ROUGHLY PRODUCTION HIRES. AND
OUT OF THOSE THERE WERE TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE- LATINOS ON THE CREW
AND THREE HUNDRED AND- THREE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY- LATINOS. AND NOW MOVING
FORWARD AS I MENTIONED WITH
THIS NEW ITERATION THE FAMILY
TV TAX CREDIT PROGRAM WE WILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TRACK DATA
BECAUSE WE DO REQUIRE- IT IS A
PROVISION OF THREE POINT OUT OF
FOR THE PROJECTS TO SPEECH
SUBMIT THIS IMPORTANT
INFORMATION. WHAT ABOUT TALENT
WHAT IS THE POOL OF TALENT LOOK
LIKE. ONSCREEN THE POOL OF
TALENT ON SCREEN I CAN GIVE YOU
UP ENIK ANECDOTALLY I THINK.
I'VE GROWN UP PERSONALLY- IN
TERMS OF IN TERMS OF OUR OUR
OUR PROJECTS- IT WAS HARD TO
IT'S HARD TO- TO SAY EXACTLY
REGARDING THOSE BUT THERE. AYE
I DO BELIEVE THERE ISN'T AS
MUCH REPRESENTATION- THAT THERE
THAT THERE SHOULD BE. FRANKLY
OKAY WELL THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT SO A LOT OF THE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN GREEN LIGHTED.
YOU HAVE STATUS FOR SOME OF THE-
BELOW THE LINE WORKERS BUT IN
TERMS OF REPRESENTATION AND
TALENT. WE CAN QUICKLY LOOK IT
UP AND SEE WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE.
YES MADAM CHAIR I DID SAY CAST
AND CREW I JUST CAN'T PULL OUT
THE AMOUNT IN TERMS THE EXACT
AMOUNT OF THE CAST AS RELATED
TO THE CREW IN THOSE NUMBERS.
WHY AND IF I MAY ASK WHY IS THE
WHITE WHY IS IT A VOLUNTEER
BASED IN TERMS OF THOSE
STATISTICS. AND THAT WOULD BE
AND ENGAGE IN TWO POINT OH
THREE POINT OH IS DIFFERENT
THIS IS THIS IS MANDATORY
REPORTING SO THIS IS THE- FOR
THREE POINT OUT AND I THINK I
BELIEVE THAT WE WERE THE FIRST
STATE ACTUALLY TO INTRODUCED
THIS PROVISION AND AN AT BAT
FROM A TV TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
ALTHOUGH NEW YORK ALSO HAS ONE
NOW. WE HAD A VERY SUCCESSFUL
HEARING WITH AN INITIATIVE THAT
WE HAVE IN THE ASSEMBLY CALL
THE- THING LETTING US
INITIATIVE CHAIRED BY.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN LORENA GONZALEZ
IN WHICH ONE OF THE LAST
HEARINGS THAT WE DID WAS
SPECIFICALLY ON. ON HOLLYWOOD.
AND THEN A SUBSIDY TO ENSURE
THAT REPRESENTATION AND IN
FILM. AND TV- IN MOVIES. IT
LOOKS LIKE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO I'M- I'M
ACTUALLY QUITE CURIOUS AS TO
WHAT THREE POINT A LOOKS LIKE
TO ENSURE THAT. WE MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION THAT HAS EQUITY. WHEN
IT COMES TO THESE FUNDS. WELL
ALSO WITH IN TERMS OF. THEY
ALSO HAVE TO REPORT PROJECTS
REPORT THEIR VOLUNTARY.
PROGRAMMING THAT THEY DO AND
SOME EXAMPLES THAT WE HAVE OUR
FRIENDS DID SO MANY SO MANY
TELEVISION HAS A DIVERSE
DIRECTORS PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES ACCESS AND EXPOSURE TO
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUND EPISODIC.
DIRECTING SO WE DO HAVE THEY
THEY ARE DOING PROGRAMS OF
THEIR OWN THROUGH THEIR OWN- D.
III PROGRAMS AS WELL. AND IF I
MAY I JUST WANT TO BRING IT
BACK OUT HUESO THIRTY MILLION-
AN ADDITIONAL DOLLARS ONLY FOR
RELOCATION. BOB FOR RELOCATING
SHOWS WEALTH THAT THE GOVERNOR
SAID THAT IN TERMS OF LOWERING
BACK A PRODUCTIONS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO OR NOT. LAUREN BACK
WITH LAUREN PRODUCTIONS IT
WOULD LIKE TO COME FROM A
JURISDICTIONS- HE HE STATED
THAT PERHAPS FROM JURISDICTIONS
WHOSE VALUES DON'T NECESSARILY
ALIGN. WITH THEIRS AND SO THIS
IS ME WE LIVE IN THAT THE
STATE. OF CALIFORNIA I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT ASSETS
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN TERMS OF
PRODUCING HERE AND FOR KEEPING
PRODUCTIONS HERE IN THE STATE
BRINGING PRODUCTIONS HERE ARE
YOU KNOW BE A VALUES THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED SO MUCH YOU KNOW
EVEN HERE AT THIS HEARING. AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT I'M I'M JUST
HOPING THAT THERE IS A
CORRELATION BETWEEN. RELOCATION
OF CERTAIN PRODUCTIONS AS WELL
AS DIVERSITY AND EQUITY WITHIN
THE WITHIN THAT RELOCATION.
YEAH WELL YOU KNOW AND WE BATES
SAID THE FILM TV TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM IS A- PROVEN JOB
CREATOR AND YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC SPENDING-
TAKES PLACE WHEN PRODUCTIONS
PRODUCED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THERE IS A GENERAL
I CAN GIVE YOU OF I I'D SAY-
EMPHASISED AND COMMITMENT TO
DIVERSITY- IN THE PRODUCTION
ENTERTAINMENT PRODUCTION-
ENVIRONMENT AND SO IT THAT
CONTINUES CONTINUES TO GROW AND
AGAIN WE'LL HAVE AN IDEA AT THE
END OF THE ROUTE OF THOSE
RELOCATING SHOWS. OF YOU KNOW
WHAT WERE THEIR HIRING
PRACTICES- WENT WHEN THEY
DECIDED TO COME AND SHOOT HERE
AND SO THERE IS THAT KIND OF
ADDED GOING TO BRING
ENCOURAGEMENT I THINK THAT IS.
THAT IT IS INCLUDED IN. THE AND
THE THREE POINT OH PROVISION.
THEY YOU AYE AYE MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT DIRECTION. JUST
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL OF
US THAT ARE LOOKING AT HOW THE
FILM TAX CREDIT IS CREATING A-
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA IN
TERMS OF HOW STORIES ARE TOLD
IN HOTELS- STORIES AND- WHAT
THOSE STORIES LOOK LIKE SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO. WORKING WITH
YOU MORE IN UNDERSTANDING. WHY
THAT DIVERSITY AND EQUITY. IS
IMPORTANT BUT ALSO ENSURING
THAT THAT DATA IS ALSO BEING
PROVIDED TO THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATED. WE'RE GOING TO.
THANK YOU. TO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS RELATED TO PORTS AND
VISIT CALIFORNIA. RELATED TO
PORTS WHAT ISSUES DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION WANT TO ADDRESS
WITH THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPOSAL FOR
PORTS AND WHAT IS THE REGION'S
THAT THE STATE IS TARGETING.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS MORAL FIRST SEE WHAT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND
JUST ONE SECOND. MY NOTES HERE
RIGHT I'M SO THE NEED AT YOUR
APPOINTMENT MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION WERE- OUR INTENT IS
TO ADDRESS THE LOSS IS
IDENTIFIED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PORTS AND WE ARE LOOKING WILL
ALL LOVE IN PUBLIC WORKS WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THE
FUNDING. AND SPECIFICALLY THAT
THE FUNDS WOULD BE USED FOR
LOST WAGES AND CAPITAL
INVESTMENT CONSISTENT WITH
CLEAN AIR ACTION PLANS THAT ARE
MANDATED BY THE GOVERNOR'S.
ZERO MISSION EXECUTIVE ORDER.
AND WHAT. SOME SORRY I MISSED
THE PART WHAT REGION IS THE
STATE ACTUALLY TARGETING. WHAT
ARE THE REGIONS THAT ARE BEING
TARGETED SHOW IT'S ALL ALL
ELEVEN PORTS- ALL ELEVEN PORTS
OKAY. AND THE BUDGET IS
FOCUSING ON RE FILLING BUCKETS
FOR EASY ADMINISTRATION OF
PROGRAMS MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE ARE VERY LITTLE
DETAILS ON THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE GROUNDS FOR THE PORTS.
HAS THE ADMINISTRATION THOUGHT
ABOUT SENDING THESE GRANTS
THROUGH THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION THAT HAS AN EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO IMPLEMENT A
GRANT PROGRAM. SURE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- SO MADAM
CHAIR THE- I THINK SO GO VISIT
IS POSITIONED TO SUPPORT THIS
GRANT PROGRAM PROGRAM IN THE
SENSE THAT- BOTH THROUGH OUR
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND
STREET UNIT- AS WELL AS OUR
SUSTAINABLE FREIGHT AND GOODS
MOVEMENT UNIT WE DO HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF INTERACTION WITH
THE COURTS AND IN SUPPORTING.
UP LOGISTICS AND TRADE AND- AND
YOU KNOW THAT THAT IS ALL THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE RELATED TO
THE PORTS M. S. YOU KNOW HUGE
ECONOMIC DRIVERS IN THE STATE
SO I'M IN TERMS OF EXAMINING
WHETHER THE STATE LANDS WITH
ME. AN NTITY THAT COULD BE
MORE EFFECTIVE I MEAN I THINK.
WE'RE ONE ADMINISTRATION OR ONE
TEAM I WOULD SAY I WOULD SAY
THAT PERSON FOR MOST- I THINK
THERE ARE OF COURSE QUITE
EQUIPPED I'M AND I HAVE NO
DISPUTE ON THAT BUT- I THINK
THE FOR THE REASON I MENTION
ABOUT GOKU'S SPECIFICALLY I
BELIEVE THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
OF WHY- WE ARE POSITIONED TO
ALSO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM. DOES
GO BILLS HAVE THE STAFF. TO
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW GRANT. SHE
SO. WE HAVE STAFF THAT ARE IN
OUR INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS UNIT
WE HAVE TRADE REPRESENTATIVES-
ANALYSTS- AND STUFF AND WE ALSO
HAVE STAFF WITHIN OUR GREAT AND
SUSTAINABLE. SUSTAINABLE
FREIGHT AND GOODS MOVEMENT
MOVEMENT UNIT SO YOU KNOW BUT I
THINK INTO THIS. I THINK. THE
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IS YES WE
WILL FIND A WAY TO. LIFT IT UP-
YOU KNOW THE U. S. A. ENDING A
FEW PEOPLE MENTION THAT U. S.
TREASURY GUIDELINES WERE JUST
ISSUED. A LAST WEEK AND WE DOVE
IN AS DEEPLY AS WE COULD TO
THIS POINT WE THINK WELL WE
HAVE A GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THE EXPECTATION IS IN
TERMS OF ELIGIBILITY AND- AN-
ALLOWABLE USES THE FUNDING AND
HOW THE STATE WOULD WANT TO
STAY ON THIS PROGRAM UP- SO.
YES WE WOULD WE WOULD. WE HAVE
STAFF WHERE WE WOULD MAKE IT
WORK. OKAY YOU SEEMS LIKE WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT IT A LITTLE
BIT MORE TO ENSURE THAT YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT EFFORT. AND
THAT THERE IS ACTUAL STAFF
READY TO TAKE THIS ON. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO VISIT
CALIFORNIA. WHAT SORT OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES HAS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE INCLUDED IN THE PROPOSAL.
I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR CAN YOU
REPEAT THE QUESTION I HAD A
HARD TIME HEARING YOU. SURE
I'LL ACTUALLY A LAST TWO
QUESTIONS IN ONE WHAT SORT OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES HAS THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE INCLUDED IN THE PROPOSAL
FOR VISIT CALIFORNIA AND WHAT
SORT OF ANALYSIS WAS DONE TO
GET TO THE NINETY FIVE MILLION.
I YES IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
VISIT CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNED BY
A THIRTY SEVEN MEMBER BOARD-
THERE'S OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
INVESTORS ARE SESSION
BUSINESSES THAT NORMALLY FIND
THE DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS- AS
PART OF THAT FRAME GOVERNANCE
FRAMEWORK WE HAVE THREE TO FOUR
HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE
INDUSTRY- THAT ARE LOOKING. AT
OUR- PROGRAM OF WORK ON A DAILY
BASIS AND THEN ON A FINANCIAL
LEVEL WE ARE REQUIRED BY STATE
LAW TO CONDUCT. AN ANNUAL AUDIT
EVERY YEAR- AND I WILL SAY THAT
WE'VE HAD OVER TWENTY TWO YEARS
OF CLEAN UNQUALIFIED AUDITS
WITH NO MANAGEMENT OPINIONS.
AND THAT THOSE ARE VERY FOR ALL
COMPREHENSIVE ON IT SO WE'RE
CONSTANTLY LOOKING AT OUR
PROGRAMS AND PROCESSES. IN
TERMS OF THE- ANALYSIS FOR
RETURN ON INVESTMENT AND
IMPACTS. THE TRAVEL INDUSTRY
PARTICULARLY DESTINATIONS SUCH
AS CALIFORNIA FLORIDA LAS VEGAS
NEW YORK CHICAGO WHATEVER
DESTINATION. YOU KNOW THAT IS
PROMINENT IN AMERICA. FOR THE
MOST PART USES THE SAME
DEPLOYMENT OF METHODOLOGY FOR
ANALYSIS IN OUR CASE WE USE AN
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH FIRM THAT
LOOKS AT. A CONTROL GROUP AND
LOOKING AFTER. ADAM WEIRDNESS
AND INTENT TO TRAVEL THROUGH
MULTIPLE WAYS. TO LOOK AT THAT
INCREMENTAL SPENDING AND
VISITATION AND FRANKLY TAX
REVENUE AND JOBS THAT COME OUT
OF. OUR ACTIVATIONS
PARTICULARLY AS THEY RELATE TO
MEDIA BUYING. AND A TOUCH POINT
DIRECTLY WITH THE CONSUMER IT'S
VERY EASY TO MEASURE ECONOMIC
IMPACT. AND IT'S A NATIONAL
STANDARD. AND WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THIS PROJECT WHAT IS THE
TARGET AUDIENCE- AND WHAT IS
THE MESSAGE FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
UP FIRST AND FOREMOST OUR JOB
IS TO SHORTEN THAT RECOVERY
KIRK AND OUR LOWEST HANGING
FRUIT ARE ACTUALLY CALIFORNIANS
THEMSELVES. AS WELL AS A
NATIONAL AUDIENCE SO THAT WOULD
BE THE TARGET OF OUR MESSAGING
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT THREE
ISSUES AROUND. OUR STRATEGIES
AND OBJECTIVES FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS TO REALLY SUPPORT
BRAND HEALTH BECAUSE WE GAVE
NOT ONLY GONE THROUGH A BRAND
TARNISHED SITUATION RELATED TO
KOBE. BUT OF COURSE PRIOR PRIOR
TO THAT WE HAVE IMPACTS ON THE
BRAND AROUND WHILE BURKE RACES
AND OTHER CRISIS AND WE KNOW WE
WILL BE ANTICIPATING THAT
COMING EVEN OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. SECOND IS TO TRIGGER
ACTIVE CONSIDERATION AMONGST
THE TARGETED MARKET WHICH BY
THE WAY IS TWENTY FIVE TO FIFTY
FOUR IN TERMS OF THE MEDIA
BUYING TARGET. AND THEN FINALLY
DRIVE MARKET DEVELOPMENT- AND
THAT'S REALLY TO GET TO THE
TRANSACTIONAL LEVEL AND CREATE
AN URGENT CALL TO ACTION THE
KEY MESSAGE FOR US IS RECOVERY.
AND THE FACT THAT PEOPLE HAVE
MISSED OUT ON A YEAR OF
MILESTONES IN THEIR LIFE
WHETHER THAT'S WEDDINGS
SPORTING EVENTS FAMILY GET
TOGETHERS FRANKLY JUST LEISURE
ACTIVITIES VACATIONS ARE THE
DREAM OF A LIFETIME. FORTUNATE
FOR US WERE ABLE TO MONETIZE
THOSE IN SUBSTANTIAL TAX
REVENUE BUT OUR JOB IS TO GET
TO THE MESSAGE OF THE POWER OF
POSSIBILITY. AND BEING ABLE TO
MAKE UP TIME AND THE BILL
YOU'RE DREAMING CALIFORNIA IT
WHILE WE THINK OF CALIFORNIA AS
A GOVERNMENT PROCESS LIKE THIS
HEARING. CONSUMERS ACROSS THE
NATION SEE IT JUST LIKE A
RETAIL PRODUCT ARE THEY
CHOOSING COCA COLA OR PEPSI ARE
THEY CHOOSING FLORIDA ARE THEY
CHOOSING CALIFORNIA AND OUR
JOBS TO DRIVE THAT TOP OF MIND
AWARENESS AND. GET THEM INTO
THE CONSIDERATION SET. SO IT'S-
IT SEEMS AS WE ARE GETTING INTO
THE STAGE OF COMPLETE RE
OPENING WITH FULL VACCINATION
AND THE STATE IS DOING REALLY
WELL COMPARATIVELY ACROSS THE
STATE ASKING FOR NINETY FIVE
MILLION WHEN FOLKS ARE ALREADY
WILLING AND READY TO TRAVEL I'M
JUST CURIOUS AS TO WHAT THE
DIRECTION IS IN TERMS OF HOW
THAT FUNDING IS GOING TO BE
USED IN- EXACTLY YOU'RE
TARGETING. AND IF WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF ALSO RECOVERING FROM
COAL BED. WHILE OTHER STATES
ARE NOT AT THAT LEVEL. I'M
CONCERNED AS TO WHAT THAT.
ATTENTION WE CAN LOOK LIKE FOR
THE STATE. SO WE THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION IT'S EXCELLENT
WEEK WE HAVE A SERIOUS ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA AS IT RELATES TO
COMING OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA LOST MORE MARKET
SHARE THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN
THE CONTINENTAL US WE ACTUALLY
LOST 26% OF OUR SHARE BECAUSE-
WE TOOK A VERY CAUTIOUS
APPROACH HERE IN CALIFORNIA
DURING THE PANDEMIC. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME IT SENT A SIGNAL TO
THE NATION THAT WE WERE NOT
OPEN FOR BUSINESS SO FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY WE
ACTUALLY LAGGED BEHIND
COMPETITIVE STATES IN TERMS OF
THAT TOP OF MIND AWARENESS OR
WHAT WE CALL DESTINATION READY
NESS IN TERMS OF. ARE PEOPLE
LOOKING THAT IS CALIFORNIA
READY FOR THAT OPEN FOR
BUSINESS MESSAGING AND THAT
THAT TAKES AN EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORT TO COME FROM BEHIND TO
DO SO WHAT OTHER STATES
ACTUALLY MADE UP SHARE DURING
THE PANDEMIC SO AGAIN OUR
TARGET IS RESTORING CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE THE CALIFORNIA IS
READY AND OPEN FOR BUSINESS AT
THIS TIME WHEN THE COMPETITION
IS ADDED TO YOUR SUS POINT. AND
THAT'S WHAT THE MONEY WILL BE
USED FOR AND CREATE A
DIFFERENCE I WILL NOTE THAT
THERE IS STILL INDUSTRY
INVESTMENT AND THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE CAN FULLY RECOVER IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A FULL
THROTTLE APPROACH TO SHORTEN
THAT RECOVERY KERR SO OUR
GATEWAY CITIES SAN FRANCISCO
LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO SUFFERED THE MOST OUR
URBAN CORES. SO PART OF OUR
INVESTMENT IS TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
AND URBAN LAYER TAKE AND
RESTORE CONFIDENCE AND TOP OF
MIND AWARENESS FOR THOSE URBAN
CORES. THANK YOU AND I 1100%
APPRECIATE THAT THE RESTORE
CONFIDENCE CALIFORNIA HAS LED
THE WAY IN TERMS OF COBIT
RECOVERY. AN OPENING AND WE'RE
GOING AND WHERE DO A LOT OF
WORK TO ENSURE THAT ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE THE FUNDING AND
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED AS
MUCH AS WE ARE ALSO WORKING ON
THE EQUITY ISSUE WITH VACCINE
WHICH WE'RE SLOWLY. GETTING TO
A GOOD PLACE ON AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT IN MY OWN PARTICULAR
DISTRICT. OF MANY ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND MOST OF WHOM ARE
LATINO SUFFERED THE MOST AND SO
WHEN I WHEN I HEAR YOU SAY
ABOUT. IN YOU KNOW OTHER STATES
HAVE DONE BETTER DURING THE
PANDEMIC I THINK OF FLORIDA I
THINK OF WHAT WE SAW IN THE
NEWS IN TERMS OF COLLEGE KIDS
OR GENERAL POPULATION NOT
WEARING MASKS NOT BELIEVING IN
THE VACCINE. COMING TO
CALIFORNIA AND ACTUALLY
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING ALL OF THE
GOOD WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE. SO
I'M I'M JUST VERY PRECAUTIONS
ABOUT WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT FULLY. IN A
STATE OF- 1100% OR CLOSE TO.
THE TOP OF A HERD IMMUNITY
ACROSS THE NATION AND SO. I
JUST I WANT US TO THINK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE THE HEALTH OF OUR
STATE AND THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE
HERE SHOULD BE. AT THE PRIORITY
OF THE OF THE CONVERSATION. HI
I AGREED MADAM CHAIR AND IF I
CAN CLARIFY ARI A 100% SUPPORT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND PERHAPS.
MISSED COMMUNICATED THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
CONSUMERS BELIEVE AND WHY I
THINK WE DID IN TERMS OF THE
RIGHT THING AND OUR UNIQUE
APPROACH TO THIS. AS A MATTER
OF FACT WE'VE NOW LAYERED IN
AND PERHAPS YOU'VE SEEN IT AND
SOME OF OUR IN STATE MEDIA
THAT'S RUNNING. IS A
RESPONSIBLE TRAVEL CODE. ASK
DEAN AND BORING PEOPLE TO
RECEIVE HER TRAVEL RESPONSIBLY
WE HAVE AN ENTIRE RESPONSIBLE
TRAVEL HUB ON OUR WEBSITE. THAT
IS FRANKLY A BEST IN CLASS WITH
THE NATION THAT OUR LOCAL
DESTINATIONS ARE REPLICATING
AND ACTUALLY HAVE SOME SYNERGY
WITH SO. ARE YOU SUPPORT BACK
CAUTIOUS APPROACH I IT IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT ISSUE
HOW DO THEN WE CLOSE THE GAP
WITH THE CONSUMERS I DO NOT
SUPPORT SOME OF THE RECKLESS
BEHAVIOR THAT WE SAW ON FLORIDA
I'M I'M I'M- THANKFUL
APPRECIATIVE. OF OUR APPROACH
AND NOW THE REALITY IS WHEN WE
GET PAST YOU IN FIFTEENTH WE
NEED TO START TO LOOK AT HOW WE
MAKE OUT GROUND BECAUSE- WE
ACTUALLY ARE LOOKING AT AT A
TIME LINE FOR TOTAL RECOVERY.
THAT TAKES US THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND WOULD COST THE
STATE SEVENTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN CONSUMER SPENDING
WHICH FRANKLY HURTS THE VERY
COMMUNITIES. THAT YOU JUST
SPOKE UP BECAUSE A LARGE PART
OF OUR WORK FORCE. ARE LATINOS
AND MINORITIES THAT ARE VERY
MUCH PART OF THE HOSPITALITY
FAMILY THAT WE WANT TO SEE HAVE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU AND THERE'S
A LOT THAT WE CAN SAY ABOUT
HOSPITALITY AND WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE AN ENSURING THAT. WE
HIRING EFFORTS OF THESE WORKERS
IS ACTUALLY AGAIN- PART OF THE
LARGER CONVERSATION. ABOUT RE
OPENING AND RE OPENING SAFELY-
TO A DISH QUESTION FOR YOU TO
AND I WANT TO JUST KEEP IT
GOING WELL WHAT WAS THE LAST
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT THAT
WAS MADE NTO VISIT CALIFORNIA
AND MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS
PUT THIS THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL. HOLE WOULD BE. IN
CHARGE FOR THE GOVERNMENTAL
REPRESENTATIVES THAT WOULD BE-
DIRECTING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THESE FUNDS. THE LAST TIME THAT
VISIT CALIFORNIA HAD PUBLIC
DOLLARS IN A SUBSTANTIAL WAY
WAS ACTUALLY COMING OUT OF THE
AFTERMATH OF NINE ELEVEN. THEN
GOVERNOR DAVIS PUT TOGETHER A
SPECIAL PROCREATION ARE SIMILAR
TO THE PLAYBOOK AND TRYING TO
GET TO THE SAME PLACE. IT PAID
OFF VERY WELL ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA WAS ONE OF THREE
STATES IN THE NATION TO GROW
SHARE DURING THAT TIME. IN
TERMS OF OVERSIGHT AGAIN
PRINCIPALLY PER THE STATUTE-
OUR BOARD WOULD BE SIGNING OFF
ON THE FINAL PLAN OF WORK AFTER
WE GO THROUGH ACTUALLY A
STATEWIDE TASK FORCE RECOVERY
TASK FORCE THAT CENTER MCGUIRE.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON
QUIRK. SILVA HAS ASKED FOR AND
IN ADDITION TO THAT- WE HAVE
TWELVE GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTEES
THAT SIT ON OUR BOARD- AS WELL
AS THE HEAD OF GOBIZ. DIDI
MEYERS WHO SITS ON OUR
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE SO I THINK
I BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT OF
TOUCH POINTS AND SYNERGY-
THROUGH LAYERED THROUGHOUT OUR
PROGRAM. AND I'M SORRY IF I
MISSED IT BUT DID YOU ACTUALLY
GIVE GIVE ME THE NUMBER. WHAT
WAS THE INVESTMENT MADE
ORIGINALLY AND NINE AFTER NINE
ELEVEN WITH GOVERNOR DAVIS. IT
WAS APPROXIMATELY. EIGHT AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS. OKAY SO
EIGHTY A HALF MEN TO NOW NINETY
FIVE MILLION A A HUGE JUMP.
YES THAT CAMPAIGN WAS REALLY A
MORE SILOS- SPECIFIC CAMPAIGN
DESIGNED TO REALLY CREATE
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE WITH
CALIFORNIANS- THAT WAS THE MAIN
REASON BUT IT WAS ALSO
LEVERAGED BY THE INDUSTRY AND
MANY MEDIA PARTNERS SO IT
ACTUALLY HAD A TOTAL LEVEL
SPENDING OF ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. OKAY I WILL I WILL
NOTE. I'M SURE ALSO THAT THE
INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
STATE IN THE NATION THAT THE
INDUSTRY BONDS THE TOURISM
PROMOTIONAL EFFORTS- PRIOR TO
KOBE IN THE INDUSTRY HAD
INVESTED A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR TO
SUPPORT THE GLOBAL BRAND HEALTH
OF NOT ONLY THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY BUT THE BRAND
STEWARDSHIP OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE REALLY TRAVEL
HOSPITALITY IS AN INVITATION
AND A WELCOME IT'S BASICALLY
THE CONCIERGE FOR BUSINESS. SO
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH OTHER
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ENTITIES
AROUND MESSAGING AND
POSITIONING ON BEHALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIA BUT REALLY FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS WERE TALKING IN
UPWARDS OF A BILLION PLUS
DOLLARS THAT THE INDUSTRY PAID
FOR NOT THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
AND CREATED THIS GLOBAL
FOUNDATION AND FRAMEWORK SO
SIMPLY THIS REPRESENTS A ONE
TIME SPENDING LESS TO GET THAT.
CAR IF YOU WILL RE FIELD- SO
THAT THE INDUSTRY THEN CAN
SHORTEN THE RECOVERY CURVE AND
CONTINUE FUNDING FROM HERE ON
OUT AS OPPOSED TO PUBLIC
DOLLARS. THANK YOU IT MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR ANSWERS IN
RESPONSE- I WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE ATC PROGRAM JUST HAD ONE
FINAL QUESTION IN TERMS OF HOW
MUCH HOW MANY OR HOW MUCH
OUTRAGE DOLLARS ARE AVAILABLE
FOR OUT REACH FOR EITC. I'M
SURE THIS CALL THE WHITE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND-
I DON'T THINK MY- CALLING FROM
FINANCES ON THE LINE THAT WOULD
HAVE THAT INFORMATION SO I CAN
GET THAT BACK GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT I'M NOT RICH. THREE ITC.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT TO I WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S A
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO ENSURE
THAT THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
HOPE TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
ACTUALLY KNOW. THAT THESE
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
MADAM CHAIR DIRK SIMMONS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES GO
AHEAD. THERE IS CURRENTLY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION UNSPENT
GOLDEN STATE SEAMLESS FUNDS ONE
POINT ONE POINT L. THAT- HAS
BEEN SPENT IN CURRENT NEWS
BEING APPROPRIATED OR SHE'S ME
A RE APPROPRIATED FOR-
EXPENDITURE NEXT YEAR OTHER
THAN THAT- WE HAVE NOT PROPOSED
ANY ADDITIONAL E. I. T. C. OUR
RESPONSE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND WHAT WAS THE ORIGINAL
AMOUNT GIVEN THE TWO POINT TWO
THAT WERE LEFT OVER. ARE THERE
WAS FIVE MILLION. FOR GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS THERE WAS FIVE
MILLION- THOSE APPROPRIATE LAST
YEAR FORTY I. T. C. AND THEN
THERE IS ALSO A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. THAT WAS A
APPROPRIATE FOR GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS FUNDS ALSO SOURCE
TOTAL TEN POINT. TEN MILLION
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SAID TEN MILLION DOLLARS
APPROPRIATED TO E. I. T. C. N.
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS BUT
SPECIFICALLY ONLY FIVE MILLION
FOR EITC DIRECTLY OF WHICH TWO
POINT TWO IS LEFT OVER. THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY ANY PARTICULAR
REASON WHY THE FUNDING IS
DIFFERENT THIS GO AROUND. THERE
ARE. WHAT WE DIDN'T RECEIVE ANY
DIRECTION TO ADD ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR EITC OUTREACH- THE
FIVE MILLION LAST YEAR WAS
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND DOES NOT END OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR IN MAY
REVISION OKAY I AM ASKED IN
THIS IS CRYSTAL THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE JUST A ELABORATE ON MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE ANSWER THERE-
THE ADMINISTRATION DID NOT
PROPOSE ADDITIONAL EITC OUTRAGE
FINDINGS IN THE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND AS
BECAUSE THE FACT THAT- WE FEEL
THAT THE L. BEACH- WELL.
SUCCESSSCHOOL I'M STUDIES
INDICATE THAT OUR RECOUNTS AND-
IN A MINUTE OR TWO TAKEN IN THE
ITC ITC IS BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL.
YEAH THANK THAT THAT DUE TO A
VARIETY OF FACTORS AND JUST NOT
OUT OF REACH AND- SO THAT THAT
WAS ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT
GUIDED OUR DECISION ON THAT
POINT AS WELL. THANK YOU AS A
FOLLOW UP CAN YOU CAN YOU SHARE
WITH ME HOW MUCH FUNDING WAS
WAS ACTUALLY- AVAILABLE FOR
EITC. AND HOW MUCH OF IT WAS
USED. THANK YOU SEE OPPORTUNITY
CURRENT TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
BUDGET AX THERE IS A PRO RATED
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. LET ME
LET ME BE CLEAR NOT FOR OUT
REACH BUT FOR ACTUAL RESOURCES
FOR PEOPLE THAT WERE. UP THAT
COULD CLAIM EITC WHAT WAS THE
BUDGET AMOUNT AND HOW MUCH OF
THAT WAS USED. FOR QUALITY
MONARCHIES YEAH I'M CALLING
WHITE THAT DEPARTMENT FINANCE-
SO ON THE EITC CREDITS FOR THE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TAX- TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TAX YEAR
THERE WAS A ONE POINT TWO. IN
DOLLARS CLAIMED- AND I BELIEVE
ONE POINT ONE BILLION AND IN
THE TO TWENTY TWENTY TAX YEARS
WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING SO THERE
FOUGHT TAXPAYERS ARE FILING
RIGHT NOW AND CLAIMING CREDITS
RELATED TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
ATTACKS HERE THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NO LIMIT IN THE SENSE
THAT THAT THERE'S NO BUDGET
LIMIT IN THE SENSE THAT IF IT
ENDS UP BEING- ONE POINT YOU
KNOW ENDS UP BEING A LARGE
AMOUNT THE CREDITS ARE. ARE
STUCK THERE CAN STILL BE
CLAIMED. I SEE OKAY I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT. LOSING AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO OUTREACH TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE BEEN- VERY MUCH HIT BYE
BYE COBIT AND ENSURING THAT
WE'RE ACTUALLY. USING THE
BUDGET APPROPRIATELY IN TERMS
OF OUTREACH TO COMMUNITIES THAT
MAY NOT KNOW ABOUT THE PROGRAM
ALL FUNDING ACCESS. I HOPE I
HOPE I AM THAT'S CLEAR. THAT'S
REALLY THE INTENT OF THE
QUESTION. I'LL TAKE YOUR
SILENCE AS A YES OKAY OKAY YES
THIS. THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR BEING A PART OF
THE PANEL FOR THE ISSUES WE'RE
GONNA MOVE FORWARD TO OUR OUR
LAST ISSUE. AND THAT IS RELATED
TO THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
ON DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION AND
RESULTS ORIENTED GOVERNMENT-
LET'S BEGIN WITH- BLOCKS THAT
WE HAVE SEVERAL PANELISTS
ALYSSA MISS EVELYN SUSE MERRY
HOLDER MAN SALLY LUCKINBILL
TRUE SADDAM BURKE AND NICK
SCHROEDER. LET'S BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M SURE CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON- MEDICARE
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS EVELYN SEES ME PRINCIPLE
BUDGET ANALYST WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF THE PROPOSALS AND THE
DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION AND
RESULTS ORIENTED GOVERNMENT AND
GENERAL GOVERNMENT STATEWIDE
CHAPTERS AS PRESENTED. IN THE
ADMINISTRATIONS MAY REVISE.
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. WE HAVE THREE
COUPLES FOR THE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT- THE FIRST ONE- IS
THE TECHNOLOGY. OUR DECISION
FUNDING MAY REVISE INCLUDES A
ONE TIME- GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION TO SEE THE TEAM.
SENATE HE WILL UTILIZE THE
FUNDS BUT TO FIND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROACTIVE
SOLUTIONS IDENTIFIED THREE CG
STABILIZE CRITICAL SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE BCP AND AS YOU
MAY RECALL AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDED LIMITED TERM
FUNDING OF ELEVEN POINT FOUR
MILLION GENERAL FUND.
OPPORTUNITY TO CONDUCT
ASSESSMENTS OF EXISTING
CRITICAL SYSTEMS. AND IDENTIFY
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS THAT WILL
MITIGATE POTENTIAL RISKS OF
SEEKING MAY ALSO USE SOME OF
THIS FUNDING FOR OTHER SMALLER
STRATEGIC I. T. SOLUTIONS
IDENTIFIED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS IN AS
APPROVED BY CDT. CITY ESTIMATES
THIS PREPARATION WILL FIND
ABOUT TEN TO TWENTY FIVE SYSTEM
STABILIZATION IMPROVEMENTS AND
SOLUTIONS. THE FUNDING WILL BE
USED SIMILARLY TO THE FEDERAL
TECHNOLOGY MODERNIZATION FUND.
WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
SELECTED FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MODERNIZATION SOLUTIONS OUTSIDE
OF THE PROCESS. IN A REVISED
PROPOSAL INCLUDES PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT INCLUDES
ADMINISTRATIVE AND LEGISLATIVE
REPORTING TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
THE APPROPRIATION TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR ENCUMBRANCE OR
EXPENDITURE UNTIL JUNE THIRTY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THE SECOND.
ALL SHE IS. RELATED. TO
CETIOSAURUS EFFORTS TO CREATE A
DEDICATED TEAM AT CDG TO
SUPPORT CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT
OF THE C. A. DOT GOV OR CALL IN
TO IMPROVE SEAT SHE'S CAPACITY
TO ON BOARD AGENCY WEBSITES TO
NEW STATEWIDE WEB ENTERPRISE
PLATFORM ARE THEY MAY REVISED
INCLUDES LIMITED LIMITED TERM
FUNDING OF TWO POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND. EIGHT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THROUGH
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THE
COUPLE HEARD AND APPROVED BY
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE EARLIER THIS
MONTH. THE THIRD AND LAST OUT
RIPPLES ALL UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
ISRAELI MADE CHIP GIVES- I. T.
C. H. E. IS ALSO WORKING ON A
PILOT PROJECT TO DISCOVER AND
TEST ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
FEDERATING A SINGLE DIGITAL ID
BEGINNING WITH TWO ENTITIES
WHICH ARE YET TO BE DETERMINED.
MAY REVISED INCLUDES LIMITED
TERM FUNDING OF ONE POINT ONE
MILLION GENERAL FUND THE
212-232-2234 THIS EFFORT. UPON
COMPLETION OF THIS PILOT IN THE
TWO DEPARTMENTS CG WILL
EVALUATE THE POTENTIAL USAGE OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY AT A STATEWIDE
LEVEL TO ENHANCE COHESION
BETWEEN STATE PROGRAMS AND
IMPROVE USER EXPERIENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THIS PROPOSAL IS
ALSO HEARD BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE
EARLIER THIS MONTH BUT WAS HELD
OPEN. I'M GOING TO MOVE ONTO
THE NEXT ISSUE. OF WHICH LED TO
STATE WORKFORCE TELEWORK WHICH
IS NOT AN INFORMATIONAL IT'S
FOR INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES ONLY
AND PROVIDES AN UPDATE FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S PROJECT. DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES CONTINUE TO BE
EXAMINED THEIR WORK FORCE TO
DETERMINE ENTIRE-
CLASSIFICATIONS IN OPPOSITION
SECOND TELEWORK PROMINENTLY
WITHOUT DISRUPTION SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY AS
PART. IT'S CAL TO IMPLEMENT A
HOTELLING STRATEGY TO BETTER
MANAGE ITS OFFICE SPACE AND
JUST APARTMENT LEASING COSTS.
MORE THAN A DOZEN STATE
ENTITIES HAVE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN PURSUING SIMILAR
STRATEGIES AFTER PANEL
DISCUSSIONS WERE FACILITATED BY
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY. DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH WERE ALSO DIRECTED-
DURING THE FALL AND SPRING
PROCESS TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
REDUCTIONS THROUGH OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCY. THE CLOTHING
REDUCTIONS OF DISCRETIONARY
PROGRAMS LEASE SPACE TRAVEL
CONTRACTS AS WELL AS REDUCTIONS
IN OPERATING COSTS AS A RESULT
OF INCREASED TELEWORK. THE
GOVERNMENT BUDGET INCLUDED
INITIAL ESTIMATED SAVINGS TO
REFLECT VARIOUS OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES WITHIN. THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S THE MAY REVISE
INCLUDES A REDUCTION OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT POINT EIGHT
MILLION WHICH INCLUDES FIFTY
POINT FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND.
OF THAT TOTAL A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE POINT FOUR MILLION
IS ATTRIBUTABLE TO TELEWORK
EFFICIENCIES. YOU TO LESS
TRAVEL COSTS OF PRINTING
POSTAGE MAJORITIES IN TRANSIT
SUBSIDIES. THE NEXT ISSUE THAT
I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE YOU AN
UPDATE ON IS RELATED TO. THE
USE OF OFFICE SPACE ACROSS
STATE DEPARTMENTS. AGAIN THIS
IS ALSO FOR INFORMATIONAL
PURPOSES ONLY AND PROVIDES AN
UPDATE FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BY.
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED IT MAY
REVISE INCLUDES OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCY REDUCTIONS. DGS
CONTINUES TO EVALUATE THE STATE
PARK FOR YOUR STATE LEASES AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RESPECTING
SPACE NEEDS TO DETERMINE WHICH
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS MAY BE
ABLE TO RELEASE STATE SPACE DUE
TO THEIR EMPLOYEES WORKING
REMOTELY. FOR INSTANCE TGS IS
DEVELOP SPACE GUIDELINES AND
PLANNING PRINCIPLES TO HELP
GUIDE DEPARTMENTAL DISCUSSIONS
ON TELEWORK AND- COBIT. DGS
ALSO IMPLEMENTED A MORATORIUM
ON NEW SPACE REQUEST AND LEASE
RENEWALS. THEY'RE REQUIRING
THAT ANY CLIENT AGENCY- THE
REQUESTED SPACE MUST ACCOUNT
FOR FUTURE TELEWORK BEFORE DGS
PROCESSES PROCESSES THESE
AREN'T SPACE REQUEST. EGS IS
REDUCE THE SPACE ALLOCATIONS OF
STATE DEPARTMENTS IN THE NEW
OFFICE BUILDING PROJECTS ARE
COMPLETING CONSTRUCTION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AS WELL AS
IT. THOSE PLAN FOR RENOVATION
AS PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY IS LEVERAGING TELEWORK
TO REDUCE IT SPACE NEEDS UPON
RELOCATION TO ITS NEW
HEADQUARTERS BUILDING IN AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. CAN YOU HEAD
QUARTERS BUILDING WILL SERVE
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
FOUR EIGHT STAFF WITH OVER
ELEVEN HUNDRED SHARED SPACES.
LIVING ON THE NEXT ITEM.
SIMILARLY TO EAT ARE ASKED TO
ISSUES AT THIS. NEXT ISSUE IS
REGARDING THE STATE'S UPPER TO
REDUCE TRAVEL AND SLEEP COSTS
WHICH IS ALSO FOR INFORMATIONAL
PURPOSES ONLY AND PROVIDES AN
UPDATE FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. TO CONTINUE REALIZING
GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCIES AND
TRAVELED EGS IS IMPLEMENTING A
TRAVEL AIRFARE POLICY WHICH
INCLUDES COST SAVING MEASURES
THAT WILL REQUIRE STATE
EMPLOYEES TO. REFUNDABLE
AIRFARE- THEY MUST PURCHASE THE
AIRFARE AT LEAST SEVEN DAYS
PRIOR TO TRAVEL AND UTILIZE
UNUSED AIRLINE TICKET REDDIT'S
FIRST PRIOR TO PURCHASING NEW
TICKETS. THE POLICY BUT WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRED STATE EMPLOYEES
TO SUBMIT JUSTIFICATION FOR ANY
NON COMPLIANCE INDEED YES WILL
PROVIDE SEMI ANNUAL REPORTING
TO STATE DEPARTMENTS NOTIFYING
THEM OF ANY POLICY
NONCOMPLIANCE. AGS RECENTLY
ESTABLISHED A STATE AND ARE
INSTALLING IN UTILIZING
TELEMATICS DEVICE IS. THESE
DEVICES ARE SMALL- GPS DEVICE
THAT TRACKS DISTANCE TIME
LOCATION AND SPEED IN STATE
VEHICLES. IF OR WHEN FULLY
IMPLEMENTED ARE THESE DEVICES
WILL BETTER ASSIST THE STATE IN
MANAGING ITS FLEET VEHICLES
RESULTING IN REDUCED FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS. AND MINIMIZE
ACCIDENTS. WELL THE POLICIES.
NET SAVINGS TO THE STATE IN THE
LONG TERM DEBT MAY REVISION
INCLUDES THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM FUNDING FOR A- A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENTS- IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO- MAY REVISED
INCLUDES THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
OF THAT IS GENERAL FUND. AND A
NUMBER OF POSITIONS WERE ALSO-
PROPOSED FOR THESE DEPARTMENTS.
THIS TEMPORARY FUNDING WILL
ALLOW. BERMAN IS TO INSTALL THE
TELEMATICS DEVICES AND QUANTIFY
THE DEVICES THAT COST AGENCIES
WITHOUT CONSTRAINING THEIR
BUDGETS. WE KNOW THAT THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS FOR THOSE
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE PRESENTED
IN HEARD AT THE RESPECTIVE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES FOR THOSE
DEPARTMENTS. ZERO THE NEXT ITEM.
AS PART OF TRANSFORMING STATE
OPERATIONS CALIFORNIA'S
PRIORITIZING EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. THE STATE'S FIRST
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER AT THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
WAS PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WITH TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONGOING
GENERAL FUND. IN PART THIS
POSITION WILL HELP OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF EQUITY
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LEADS AS AN EMPLOYEE
INITIATIVES. THEY WILL WORK
WITH KALINJAR TO RECOMMEND
CHANGES TO CLOSE THE GENDER AND
RACIAL PAY GAPS IN THE STATE
WORKFORCE. AND WORK WITH THE
STATE'S CHIEF DATA OFFICER TO
GATHER AND REPORT DATA ABOUT
STATE WORKFORCE. ANY REVISION
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING GENERAL FUND TO FUNDS TO
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO SUPPORT THE
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICERS WORKLOAD.
THIS PROPOSAL WAS HEARD AND
APPROVED BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE
EARLIER THIS MONTH. MOVING ON
SHARE. AT RETIREMENT
CONTRIBUTIONS TO BOTH CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO MAKE REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTIONS TO BOTH CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS AS WELL AS
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENTS
TO BOTH SYSTEMS TOWARDS THE
STATE'S UNFUNDED LIABILITIES.
SPECIFICALLY FOR CALPERS STATE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE. AND THAT
TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
OF THAT IS GENERAL FUND. TWO
SIX BILLION ARE IN AND THREE
POINT TWO BILLION GENERAL FUND
RELATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE ADJUSTMENT REFLECTS
THE LATEST CONTRIBUTION RATES
ADOPTED BY THE CALPERS BOARD
AND ASSUMES STATE EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION REDUCTIONS WILL
NOT CONTINUE THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEAR. ADDITIONALLY DUE TO THE
INCREASE IN THE ESTIMATED
AVAILABILITY OF PROPOSITION TWO
DEBT REPAYMENT FUNDING. IS THIS
PROPOSED PAYMENT TO CALPERS TO
FURTHER REDUCE THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES OF THE STATE PLANS.
THE PROPOSED AMOUNT FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO IS ONE POINT
NINE MILLION AS COMPARED TO THE
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION PROPOSED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT. TOWARDS
THE STATE OUR CALPERS UNFUNDED
LIABILITY IS ESTIMATED TO
RESULT IN A MINIMUM LONG TERM
GROWTH SAVINGS RATIO OF TWO TO
ONE. FORECASTERS SAY
CONTRIBUTIONS TO IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO HAVE INCREASED BY
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND. CHEN SAID THE TOTAL OF
THREE POINT NINE BILLION
GENERAL FUND RELATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND THIS IS
DUE TO A REVISION IN THE
REPORTED COMPENSATION FOR I K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TEACHERS. CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL THIS CONTRIBUTION
AMOUNT INCLUDES A ONE TIME. AND
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
PAYMENT TO OFFSET THE REDUCTION
IN THE STATE'S CONTRIBUTION I'M
IN THE CURRENT YEAR TO ALLOW
THE FUNDING PLAN TO STAY ON
TRACK TO BE FULLY FUNDED BY
TWENTY FORTY SIX. THE MAY
REVISION MAINTAINS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
INCLUDE A ONE TIME FOUR HUNDRED
TEN MILLION OPPOSITION TO
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT TO
BE PAID TO CAL STARS IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. TOWARDS THE
STATE SHARE OF THE CASTERS
DEFINED BENEFIT PROGRAM. FUNDED
LIABILITY. THIS PAYMENT IS
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN ONE
POINT ONE BILLION IN GROSS
SAVINGS TO THE STATE THREE
TWENTY FOUR. SHE'S A. TWENTY
FORTY FIVE TO TWENTY FORTY SIX.
LASTLY. MAY REVISED INCLUDES A
DECREASE IN- JR'S CONTRIBUTIONS
BY SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS- CURRENTLY. MAY REVISE
INCLUDES EIGHTY SIX MILLION FOR
THE REQUIRED CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CHURCH JIM. I'M GOING TO NOW
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUES TO
PRESENT ON THE REST OF THE
ISSUES- WITHIN THESE TWO
CHAPTERS OR D. MAY REVISE.
AFTERNOON ALTERMAN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. I'LL BE GOING OVER
SOME OF THE- GENERAL GOVERNMENT
IN STATE RIGHT. SO THE FIRST
ITEM IS INFORMATIONAL ONLY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AS A RESULT OF THE
KOBE NINETEEN RECESSION
REDUCTIONS IN STATE EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION COSTS AND A FOR
AUSTIN GO SHE DID GENERAL
SALARY INCREASES WERE NECESSARY
TO BALANCE THE TWENTY TWENTY-
BY JACKS AND ALL TWENTY ONE
BARGAINING UNIT SUCCESSFULLY
REACHED AGREEMENTS TO CHEAP THE
NECESSARY SAVINGS THROUGH THE
PERSONALLY PROGRAM TWENTY
TWENTY. AS WELL AS DEFERRING
PAYING CREASES AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RELEASE- WE
HAD INDICATED THE REVENUE
PICTURE. AND THE COMPENSATION
REDUCTIONS MAY NOT BE NECESSARY
TO CONTINUE INTO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO NOW GIVEN THE MAY
REVISION REVENUE PROJECTIONS
FOR SOME BARGAINING UNITS
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
REDUCTIONS AM PETERBOROUGH'S
WILL AND AUTOMATICALLY. RIGHT
THE PROVISIONS OF THEIR PLP
TWENTY TWENTY AGREEMENTS AND
CAL H. R. HAS INVITED ALL
BARGAINING UNITS THROUGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TO
DISCUSS THE- REVISION OF THE
PLP TWENTY TWENTY AGREEMENTS.
SPECIFICALLY FOR ITEM NINETY
EIGHT HUNDRED WHICH IS EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION TO MAKE. CLOSE ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION FOR
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN PAY
INCREASES THAT WERE NOT
DEFERRED I'M BECAUSE INCREASES
TO RELATED MINIMUM WAGE CHANGES
AND ADJUSTMENTS TO THE HEALTH
AND DENTAL CONTRIBUTIONS BASED
ON UPDATED TWENTY TWENTY TWO I
ESTIMATED PREMIUMS. OR THE
STATE HEALTH CARE BENEFITS THE
STATE IS PROJECTED TO SPEND SIX
POINT EIGHT BILLION AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FOR MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND STATE EMPLOYEES
RETIREES AND THEIR ELIGIBLE
DEPENDENTS. THIS INCLUDES TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION FOR STATE
AND CSU RETIREE. BENEFITS THE
MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES ONE
POINT THREE BILLION FOR OTHER
POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS PRETTY
FUNDING CONTRIBUTIONS. OF THIS
AMOUNT SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION IS THE EMPLOYER
SHARE OF PRE FUNDING
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR. SINCE EMPLOYEE.
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE SUSPENDED AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- DUE TO THE
PLP TWENTY TWENTY AGREEMENTS AN
ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITIONS YOU FUNDING WILL
BE PROVIDED BY THE STATE
EMPLOYER ON BEHALF OF. HE'S A
TO HELP REACH FULL FUNDING FOR
RETIREE HEALTH BENEFITS BY
TWENTY FORTY SIX. AS A RESULT
OF THE STATE'S POLICY TO FOR
REFUND THE RETIREE HEALTH
BENEFITS MORE THAN THREE POINT
EIGHT BILLION IS CURRENTLY SET
ASIDE IN THE PRE FUNDING TRUST
FUND FOR FUTURE BENEFIT. I THE
MAY REVISION ALSO INCLUDES
SEVERAL PROPOSALS RELATED TO
CANNABIS THIS INCLUDES THE
DEPRTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED FORTY
SIX THOUSAND FROM THE CANNABIS
CONTROL FUNDING TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AM AND TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. WHEN A
POSITION FOR THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. DIRECTOR OF EQUITY
AND INCLUSION. IN A TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WHICH CONTINUES
TO FOCUS ON THE AUTHORITY
NEEDED FOR THE TRANSITION TO
THE CONSOLIDATED DEPARTMENTS.
AND ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THIS IS GRANT
PROGRAM THIS IS PART TRANSITION
PROVISIONAL LICENSEES TO ANNUAL
LICENSES. I HAVEN'T THE NEXT
ITEM AS FOR THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL AND IT INCLUDES
INVESTMENTS OF SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL FUND.
MEANT THE CALIFORNIA CREADA POR
PILOT PROGRAM TO ALLOW THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL TO
SPEND MEDIA OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT CAMPAIGN. AS WELL AS
FORTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL'S EXISTING
CREATIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. AND LASTLY THERE'S
VARIOUS INVESTMENTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS- TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME TO CREATE THE CALIFORNIANS
FOR ALL COLLEGE SERVICE PROGRAM
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CAL. ARE YOU
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM THANK
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
B. FOR THE YOUTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME FROM THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACTS FUNDING IT
WILL BE PROVIDED FOR GRASSES
CITIES OR COUNTIES TO CREATE OR
EXPAND USE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND I WILL BE PROVIDED
TO BE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE ACTION
CORPS AND THEN THE RESOURCES TO
BUILD A STATEWIDE POLL.
CALIFORNIANS DEDICATED TO
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE
THROUGH DIRECT SERVICE AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH I'M AN
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT NINE
GENERAL FUND TO MAINTAIN AN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE FRAMEWORK TO
PREPARE AND TRAIN FOR FUTURE
DISASTER RESPONSE. IN FIFTEEN
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
ESTABLISHED STUDENT SUCCESS
COACHES IN COMMUNITIES. AND TO
NURTURE RELATIONSHIPS WITH K.
TWELVE STUDENTS AND THREE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO HELP
RECRUIT STEM PROFESSIONALS INTO
THE TEACHING PROFESSION. AND
LASTLY ALTERNATE OVER TO MY-
ARE YOU LOOKING BILL TO PRESENT
ON STATEWIDE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SALLY LOOKING BILL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY
TO PRESENT THE ADMINISTRATION
STATEWIDE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROPOSAL FROM A REVISION. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED SIX
HUNDRED AT ONE TIME WROTE
RESOURCES EXCUSE ME OF SIX
HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL FUND
FOR TWENTY THREE DEPARTMENTS TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE MAINTENANCE NEEDS
STATEWIDE. THE MAY REVISION
STRENGTHENS THIS COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS BY PROPOSING ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME RESOURCE OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION FOR A TOTAL OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO BILLION
PERCENT WHITE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING AND- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. R. THIS
ONE QUICK BILLION IS COMPRISED
OF SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWELVE MILLION-
FROM ARCA FUNDS. THIS
INVESTMENT ALLOWS YOU
MINISTRATION TO CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE STATE WIDE BACKLOG
OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO THE
ENHANCEMENT OF PROTECTION OF
THESE IMPORTANT STATE ASSETS-
ALL NOTE THAT- IS DECIDED ITEM
COVERS NUMEROUS DEPARTMENTS
THIS PROPOSAL WILL BE DISCUSSED
IN SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS FOR
EACH RESPECTIVE DEPARTMENT-
WITH THAT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DO WE HAVE SOMEONE FROM THE
AUDIO. YES MADAM CHAIR- DREW
SORT OF BOARD FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WILL BE ARE PRESENTING OUR
OFFICES COMMENTS ON SOME OF THE
PROPOSALS THAT WERE JUST
DISCUSSED- BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. TO BEGIN WITH ALL
SPEAK TO THE PROPOSAL TO CREATE
ARGUES FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUNDS TO CREATE A
FUNDED FOR- INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS
STABILIZATION AND MODERNIZATION
PROPOSALS THIS IS A PROPOSAL
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
FIRST THE PROPOSAL WOULD LIMIT
LEGISLATURE THE LEGISLATURE'S
OVERSIGHT BY IN COVERING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF GENERAL
FUND OVER SEVERAL YEARS WITH
ONLY REQUIRING REPORTING TO THE
LEGISLATURE. SECOND THE REQUEST
PROPOSES NO NEW STATUTE OR
ADMINISTRATIVE POLICY EVEN
THOUGH IT WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN HOW THE
STATE BUDGETS FOR IT
STABILIZATION. AND
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS. ON THIRD
THE PROPOSAL PRESUPPOSES THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOME NEW
PROGRAMS. THAT WERE PROPOSED IN
JANUARY WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD WAIT AND
TELL THESE PROGRAMS ARE
IMPLEMENTED I REQUEST
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT THE STATE'S IDEAS OUR-
SYSTEM STABILIZATION. AND
MODERNIZATION NEEDS TO CONSIDER
HOW BEST TO PRIORITIZE THE
RELATED SPENDING. NATURAL
SPEECH TO THE- PROPOSAL- WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT THE PROPOSED
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
ON THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES
ONE HUNDRED MILLION AND ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR A
NEW CANNABIS LOCAL JURISDICTION
A SYSTEMS GRANT PROGRAM. THE
GRANT PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDS TO CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
TRANSITION OF CANNABIS
LICENSEES FROM PROVISIONAL
LICENSURE TO ANNUALIZED INJURE.
THE PROPOSAL RAISES A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WANT TO CONSIDER AS IT
DELIBERATES- ABOUT ITS
APPROVAL. FIRST ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL NEED TO ANSWER IS WHETHER
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO USE THE
GENERAL FUND TO OFFSET LOCAL
TOPS AT COSTS THAT ARE NORMALLY
COVERED WITH LOCAL FEES AND OR
LICENSEES PRIVATE FUNDS. IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATURE WILL
NEED TO CONSIDER WHETHER IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO SUBSIDIZE THE
COST OF ANNUAL LICENSURE FOR
ONLY A PORTION OF LICENSEES.
AND WHETHER STRUCTURING THE
PROGRAM AS A LOAN RATHER THAN A
GRANT WOULD BE MORE APPROPRIATE.
OUR NEXT ALL TURN TO THE
PROPOSALS WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL FIRST THE-
PROPOSED CALIFORNIA CREATED
CORPS PILOT PROGRAM. UP THIS IS
THE PROGRAM THAT WOULD PROVIDE
SIXTY MILLION ONE TIME IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
CREATE PUBLIC AWARENESS
MESSAGES REGARDING THE
PANDEMIC- THE ENVIRONMENT
SOCIAL JUSTICE AND CIVIL
ENGAGEMENT. THERE ARE SOME KEY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS PROGRAM
THAT REMAIN UNANSWERED FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
EFFECTIVE. THE PROGRAM WOULD BE
ADDED SHE BEING ITS INTENDED
OUTCOMES TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN
APPROVING THIS PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND THAT IT ONLY MAKES
FUNDING AVAILABLE- CONTINGENT
ON A PLAN BEING PROVIDED THAT
WOULD DETAIL PRECISELY HOW THE
GRANT WOULD BE ADMINISTERED.
AND EVALUATED FOR COST
EFFECTIVENESS. WITH RESPECT TO
THE- ART COUNCIL'S CREATIVE
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT MOST OF THE-
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROPOSED FOR
FUNDING HAVEN'T BEEN EVALUATED
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THEY'RE
EFFECTIVE AT ACHIEVING THEIR
RESPECTIVE GOALS. AS SUCH IT'S
UNCLEAR IF PROVIDING THEM WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS
APPROPRIATE TO THE EXTENT THE
BLOOD LOOK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
MONSTER PROVIDEADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR ARTS PROGRAMS IT
COULD CONSIDER WHETHER THESE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS ARE
ALIGNED. WITH ITS INTERESTS
WORK WOULD PREFER TO DIRECT.
THE FUNDING TO OTHER PROGRAMS.
NO WILL SPEAK TO THE- OUTPUT%
FOR THE- VOLUNTEER- THE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS IS STILL
WORKING OUT SOME KEY DETAILS OF
THE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS FOR ALL
COLLEGE SERVICE PROGRAM. BUT
APPEARS TO BE CLOSELY
COORDINATING WITH THE STATE
FARM COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS WE KNOW THAT THE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS WILL NEED
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES IN IMPLEMENTING
THIS NEW PROGRAM IN ORDER TO
AVOID. NEGATIVE INTERACTIONS
WITH STUDENTS FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION PROPOSED FOR USE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT GRANT
PROGRAM COULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL RESOURCES
TO EXISTING PROGRAMS. WE
RECOMMEND HOWEVER THAT YOU
DIRECT CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS TO
ONE OF ALL OF THEIR GRANTS ON A
COMPETITIVE BASIS FINALLY WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE THREE
MILLION FOR THE START OF
TEACHER RECRUITMENT- GRANTS
BECAUSE IT'S DISCONNECTED FROM
THE STATE'S BROADER. TEACHER
RECRUITMENT ACTIVITIES. ALL
RIGHT NOW I WILL TURN TO THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROPOSAL
THAT WAS PREVENT PRESENTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRE. DEPARTMENTS RECEIVING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDING TO
REPORT ON THE PROPOSED PROJECTS
THEY WILL IMPLEMENT WELL
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS
GENERALLY INEFFECTIVE STRATEGY
FOR MAINTAINING FACILITIES AND
OPERATING MORE EXPENSIVE
REPAIRS ON THE LONG TERM. IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO IDENTIFY ITS
PRIORITY MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
TO ENSURE THEY ARE CONSISTENT
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES. I
NOW BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S BEGIN I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS REMAIN RELATED TO THE
CANNABIS. ON CANNABIS WHAT IS
THE LONG TERM PLAN WITH
PROVISIONAL LICENSES AND HOW
WILL WE ENSURE A TRANSITION
TOWARDS PERMANENT LICENSES.
NOON MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS RICHARD PARROTT AND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD NEVER CULTURE- I CAN GO
AHEAD AND ANSWER THAT QUESTION-
LOOKING A LONG TERM- IN
ADDITION TO THIS- PROPOSED
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS SYSTEMS
PROGRAM- WE ALSO- IN THE
TRAILER BILL. ARE PROPOSING TO
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENSES- AND ALSO
ARE PROPOSING A DATE WHERE WE
WOULD- DISCONTINUED THE
ISSUANCE OF NEW PROVISIONAL
LICENSES- AND THEN WORK WITH
THOSE ALL OF THOSE EXISTING
PROVISIONAL LICENSEES. AND
MAKING PROGRESSION TOWARDS
ANNUAL LICENSES SO WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT IN THE TRAILER
BILL AS WELL- SO THAT WE COULD-
GET A SOLUTION AND NOT RUN INTO
A SITUATION WHERE. I'M MORE UP
AGAINST ANOTHER SUNSET DATE AND
LOOKING AT PROVISIONAL-
LICENSES EXPIRING AND HAVING TO
THEREFORE POTENTIALLY DROP OUT
OF THE LICENSED- SYSTEM. THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I ALSO WANT TO
OPEN IT UP TO MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER COOPER JUST A FOLLOW UP
ON THE TERMS QUESTION. IT'S
BEEN GOING ON FOR HOW LONG THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSES FOR THREE
YEARS OR- HOW MANY YEARS. THANK
YOU MEMBER COOPER WE STARTED-
WE BEGAN OUR PROGRAMS WITH
TEMPORARY LICENSES AND-
TEMPORARY LICENSURE SUNSET AT
THE END OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN- THE
CONCEPT OF PROVISIONAL LICENSES
CAME FORWARD. MID TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN WE REALIZE THAT
ONLY ABOUT 20% OF THE TEMPORARY
LICENSEES WOULD BE ABLE TO
QUALIFY FOR ANNUAL LICENSES- IT
WAS PRIMARILY DUE TO. SEEK WHAT%
AND OTHER LOCAL- MEETING OTHER
LOCAL REQUIREMENTS SO THE
CONCEPT OF PROVISIONAL LICENSES
CAME INTO EXISTENCE- THAT AND
SO IT HAS BEEN ABOUT- SO WE
WERE ISSUING PROVISIONAL
LICENSES AND ANNUAL LICENSES
FOR THOSE WHO TO QUALIFY. WE'VE
BEEN DOING THAT SINCE TWENTY
NINE- SPRING OR SUMMER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. OKAY I WAS
GLAD TO SEE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- SIT WITH AN INCREASING
EMPHASIS ON ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES. FOR CANNABIS THERE'S
A MAY REVISE INCLUDING
INCREASING LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES. UNFORTUNATE
RESOURCES. I'M A MEMBER COOPER
CHEMICALS ON FROM THE BUREAU
I'M SURE IT DOES NOT THE MAYBE
BY JUST NOT INCLUDE INCREASED
STAFFING- FOR PEACE OFFICERS
SPECIFICALLY. SO ONE OF THE
PROJECT WORK PROJECT WORK FOR
THE SIXTY THREE SEWER PROJECTS
TO RESTORE PEACE ALTERNATIONS
OF PETITIONS. SO RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE SEVENTY SIX ONE PEACE
OFFICER POSITIONS IN TOTAL- AND
SO THEY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
THE I'M LICENSE CASES ARE DOING
RIGHT NOW. DO YOU HAVE
SUFFICIENT PROPOSITIONS
STATIONS. I'M GOING TO GET ARE
YOU GOING TO GIVE HIM THE
REQUEST. WELL I THINK WE DO IT
THIS TIME- WE GET OUT AND FORCE
MEANT FROM DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS
OBVIOUSLY THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES WITH THE SEARCH
WARRANTS AND ACTIVITIES OF THAT
NATURE BUT WE ALSO ARE WORKING
VERY HARD AND PART OF THE WAIT
REASON. WE'RE DOING THIS AS THE
PROVISIONAL ARE TO TRY TO GET
PEOPLE INTO THE LICENSE MARKET
SO THAT WE CAN. HELP QUELL THE
UNLICENSED MARKET THAT WAY THAT
WE DON'T HAVE BY A LICENSED-
PEOPLE TURNING TO THE ILLEGAL
MARKET BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE THE
LICENSING PROCESS. WE ALSO-
HAVE BEEN DOING CONCERTED
EFFORTS AND CONTINUE TO DO TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC TO USE
THEIR- THE Q. R. CODE AND OTHER
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE AND PURCHASING IT FROM
LICENSED RETAILERS TO SUPPORT
THE LICENSE MARKET. YOU KNOW
TWO YEARS AGO WE HAD NO TWO
YEARS AGO WITH THE BLACK MARKET
THEY BEING SPECIFICALLY VAPING
DESK. IN COVERT SUCKED ALL THE
AIR OUT OF THE ROOM ON THAT
THAT IS STILL AN ISSUE. WITH
THE BILL DONE TO DEAL WITH THAT.
I'M WE HAVE DONE THE- ONE OF
THE THINGS WE DID WITH THE YOUR
CO CAMPAIGN AND TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE KNEW THEY WERE
PURCHASING FROM A LICENSED
RETAILER MOST OF THE ISSUES
CAME FROM. THE UNLICENSED
MARKET- SO WE'VE CONTINUED TO
DO THAT WE ALSO INVESTIGATED
ANY LEADS WE HAVE RELATED TO
THE VAPING CRISIS ADDITIONALLY
WE ARE CONTINUING OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS TO FILL ARE
VACANT- SWORN PEACE OFFICER
POSITIONS. SO THAT WE CAN SEE
WHERE WE'RE AT WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ALLOCATED. IF WE DETERMINE THAT
THAT'S ENOUGH WE WILL COME BACK
AND ASK FOR MORE IF WE IF WE
DON'T THINK THAT SUFFICIENT
ONCE REBEL TO DO THAT. I GUESS
MY TO DRILL DOWN FURTHER THE-
THEY HAD ONE- INVESTIGATION LA
THEY GOT IT A PRETTY SIZEABLE-
YEAH. I GUESS ENTITY THAT WAS
DOING THE BLACK MARKET VAPING.
AND THAT WAS IT SINCE THEN-
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY MORE
LARGE SCALE OPERATIONS. IN THE
BLACK MARKET CONTINUES TO
THRIVE OUT THERE ESPECIALLY IN
THE VAPING. PORTION SO- WHAT'S
THE PLAN OF ATTACK BECAUSE IT
HASN'T GONE AWAY- I SAID COVERT
TOOK ALL THE AIR OUT OF THE
ROOM SO THE FOCUS BEEN ON
COVERT. WITH EVERYBODY ELSE BUT
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING FROM
THE- BUREAU ABOUT. BLALOCK IF
THEY BEING. EIGHTY IS THERE A
PLAN TO DEAL WITH IT. AND DEAL
WITH THAT SURE WE'RE CONTINUING
TO- WORK ARE UNLICENSED CASES-
WE'VE DONE NOTHING DOING A
NUMBER OF SEARCH WARRANTS- TO
DEAL WITH THOSE. WE DON'T FOCUS
JUST ON TAPING OBVIOUSLY IF
SOMETHING COMES IN FROM BABY
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS. WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT AND WHEN WE
DETERMINE WHAT. WE KEEPS WILL
TAKE PRIORITY WE LOOK AT THE
BIG PICTURE AS TO PUBLIC HARM-
BUT WE ARE OUT THERE DOING
SEARCH WARRANTS ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND FOLLOWING UP ON LEADS
DOING UNDERCOVER SURVEILLANCE
AND THOSE SORTS OF ACTIVITIES.
YOU SENATORS THAT'S OVER IBM'S
TO SEE WHAT YOUR STATS ARE- FOR
THE PAST MY GUESS FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS. YOU MEAN THE NUMBER
OF SEARCH WARRANTS NUMBER
SEARCH FOR SERVICE MEMBERS.
INVESTIGATIONS ARE
INVESTIGATION. WE KNOW THAT
LIKE MARGOT IS MUCH LARGER THAN
THE ARTICLE MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I WANT TO SEE
WHAT KIND OF ENFORCEMENT IS
GOING ON. GOING ON ACTUALLY
PUTTING AGENT AND ACTUALLY
BRING IT TO ME BECAUSE WHEN YOU
TELL ME THAT YOU STILL NEED A
RESOURCE YOU. ASK FOR. FROM
WHAT I'VE BEEN TO BY EVERYBODY.
EARLY IN THE LONG FOR. LOS FOUR
ZERO IS THAT STILL THERE ARE
SOME REALLY. REALLY FOCUS MORE
ON DOING LESS IS MORE ON THEIR
LIFE. WITH THE LEGAL. ILLEGAL
MARKET. SO WE CAN CERTAINLY GET
YOU SOME UPDATED INFORMATION-
FROM THE INFORMATION WE
PROVIDED PREVIOUSLY ON THE
SEARCH ONE OPERATIONS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE- WE DO
HAVE- ACTIVITIES GOING ON
RELATED TO LICENSING AND
LICENSING ENFORCEMENT OUR PEACE
OFFICER UNIT IS PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON ALL THE M. LICENSE
ACTIVITIES THEY CONTINUE TO DO
THAT WE ARE OF COURSE ALSO
CONTINUING TO FILL ANY
VACANCIES WE HAVE AND FEEL THAT
ONCE WE DO THAT WANT TO BE IN A
BETTER POSITION TO ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD
REQUEST ADDITIONAL POSITIONS.
MISTER COOPER BEFORE YOU
CONTINUE LET ME JUST SUGGEST TO
OUR PANELISTS TO GO ON MEAL
WELL YOU SPEAK SO THAT THERE'S
NO ECHO THANK YOU. HOW MANY
VACANCIES DO YOU CURRENTLY HAVE.
SO WE CURRENTLY HAVE FORTY ONE
VACANCIES HOWEVER WE HAVE
THIRTY EIGHT PEOPLE IN
BACKGROUND RIGHT NOW FOR THE
STATE. SO YOU HAVE THIRTY ONE
VACANCIES OUT OF HOW MANY
EUROPE WAS TO OFFER I STAFF
SEVENTY SOMETHING OFFICERS.
FIRST WE HAVE SEVENTY SIX TOTAL
THIRTY FIVE ARE FILLED AND
THIRTY EIGHT OF THOSE POSITIONS
ARE ALL BUT THREE THAT REMAIN
HAVE PEOPLE IN THE BACKGROUND
PROCESS RIGHT NOW SO THAT'S
GREAT IN THE BACKGROUND PROCESS
BUT I MEAN YOU'RE BASICALLY
RUNNING AT HALF STRENGTH IN HOW
LONG HAS IT BEEN THAT WAY FOR.
WHAT I WOULD HAVE TO TAKE A
LOOK I WASN'T IN THIS POSITION
TO BE SAFELY I'D HAVE TO. TAKE
GO BACK HISTORICALLY LOOK AT
SOME OF THOSE NUMBERS. THE
PROBLEM WITH THE STATE IS NO
MATTER WHERE YOU ARE- THAT'S
LEVELS THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BECAUSE
THE STATE THE PAY IS. IS NOT
VERY GOOD AND IT'S ALL OVER
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE
WHETHER YOU'RE AT. A CANNABIS
OR YOUR CONSUMER AFFAIRS OR
REAL ESTATE- YOU THINK
INVESTIGATORS INVESTIGATOR FOR
THE STATE BUT THE STATE IS. SO
DYSFUNCTIONAL WE HAVE DIFFERENT
PAY SCALES ARE DIFFERENT
BARRING AGREEMENTS SO MAKES IT
HARD TO RECRUIT INDIVIDUALS
WITH THIS. BECAUSE THE PAY IS
LOCAL PROCEDURE OF MUSICALITY
IS. THAT PAY MUCH BETTER SO
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN AN ISSUE THINK
ON THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. OVER THE
YEARS WE'VE SEEN IT WITH
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
STATE SO. IT- ARE YOU DEBATE
I'VE USED UNTIL. GOING BACK
LOOKING BACK FOR THE PAST THREE
OR FOUR YEARS. WHAT'S YOUR
VACANCY RATE WAS. AND HOW LONG
THESE POSITIONS HAVE BEEN
VACANT FOR. I WOULD I WOULD
LIKE TO THOSE NUMBERS ALSO.
THAT WOULD BE VERY. SURE I CAN
DO THAT THE PEACE OFFICERS WERE
ONLY FORMALLY TRANSFERRED INTO
THE BUREAU THIS FISCAL YEAR
CORRECT BUT THERE WERE SOME
RULES BEFORE THOUGH. YOU
COMBINE THREE TO. NINE ONE. ONE
THERE ARE STILL SO THERE ARE
STILL SOME. CORRECT THEY WERE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS IN THERE AS PART OF
THEIR STRUCTURE BEFORE AD THE
SPECIFICALLY MADE TO MOVE TO
THE BE HONEST SURE IT'S NOT BE
HELPFUL SO. I'M THE VICTIMS
WERE THERE BACK THEN. CHECK OUT
APARTMENT OF FINANCE IF I MAY-
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT-
WE JUST READ OF THIS FISCAL
YEAR WE JUST ADDED TWENTY NINE
NEW OFFICER POSITIONS THAT
WEREN'T PART OF YOU KNOW
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
AND THESE TYPE OF PSITIONS FOR
THE RECRUITMENT PROCESS IT
TYPICALLY TENDS TO BE BLINKING
AND YOU KNOW THE BEAR HAS BEEN
WORKING HARD TO TRY TO FILL
THESE POSITIONS SO- JUST WANTED
TO POINT OUT THAT YOU KNOW WE
JUST RECENTLY ADDED A BUNCH
POSITION ITSELF AS THE
POSITIONS WHICH IS PROBABLY
CONTRIBUTING TO THE CURRENT
VACANCY RATE IS THAT IN
ADDITION. TO THE SEVENTY PLUS
POSITIONS ARE ON TOP OF. ON TOP
OF THAT. THAT'S INCLUDE THAT
INCLUDED IT ESPECIALLY. OKAY
SOMETIMES A THAT THEY HAD
FEWER- TRYING TO YOUR PS
OFFICER POSITIONS OKAY. LET'S
SEE THE INFORMATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER SOME
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS ARE
RELATED TO CANNABIS HOW IS THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLIGRAM FIGURE
GENERATED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS RICHARD PRYOR WAS
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE- WE LOOKED AT-
SEVERAL DIFFERENT-
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
A WE LOOKED AT WHERE WE HAVE
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
PROVISIONAL LICENSE HOLDERS- IN
THE TOP EIGHT I JURISDICTIONS
FOR CULTIVATION- RETAIL
MANUFACTURING DISTRIBUTION. AND
THEN WE TOOK A LOOK AT WITHIN
THOSE JURISDICTIONS- GENERAL
COSTS FOR- A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE YOU TO BE ABLE TO
QUALIFY FOR AN ANNUAL LICENSE
I'M PRIMARILY LOOKING AT COSTS
FOR SECRET DOCUMENTS FIRST THE
SEQUEL PROCESS. AND BASED ON
THAT- WE WERE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH THE ALLOCATION OF- HOW
FAST HOW THE I. ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS COULD BEST BE
USED ACROSS THESE JURISDICTIONS
I'M WE ALSO INCLUDED IN THAT
FORMULA- I GUESS AT THE TOP
EIGHT- STE COUNTIES OR CITIES
WITH PROVISIONAL LICENSE
HOLDERS. AND THEN WE ALSO
LOOKED AT JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAMS AS
WELL SO WE COULD FOCUS ON-
SMALLER LEGACY GROWERS AS WELL
AS- EQUITY- EQUITY OF
BUSINESSES. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT WAS ACTUALLY MY NEXT
QUESTION IS HOW ARE WE ENSURING
THAT THERE'S DIVERSITY AND
EQUITY AND THE LICENSING
PROCESS. YES SO- THAT I THINK
THIS IS- THIS THIS A LAND THIS
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
GRANT PROGRAM LENDS TOWARD THAT
END. CONSIDERING NOT ONLY- THE
HIGHEST NUMBER PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES BUT ALSO A LOOK
LOOKING AT JURISDICTIONS THAT
DO HAVE SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAMS-
50% OF THAT MONEY IS GOING
TOWARD THOSE JURISDICTIONS WITH
SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAMS AS WELL-
THEREBY- MAKING SURE. THAT I
THINK WE'RE GETTING THE BEST
USE OF THAT MONEY AND- THIS
THIS- BOB POOL OF PROVISIONAL
LICENSE HOLDERS I'M- TRYING TO
CAPTURE SMALLER LEGACY FARMERS
AS WELL AS SOCIAL EQUITY-
BUSINESSES- IN IN ALL THOSE
RESTRICTIONS I HAVE THOSE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU I THINK
WOULD BE VERY INTERESTED IN
KNOWING- THE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HAS ALSO IMPLEMENTED A
DIVERSITY AND EQUITY PROGRAM
AND I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHAT THAT
IS THAT COULD POTENTIALLY LOOK
LIKE FOR THE ENTIRE STATE VERY
SIMILAR TO THE PREVIOUS
QUESTION THAT I ASKED REGARDING
FILM TAX CREDITIN REGARDS TO
EQUITY AND INCLUSION. SAME FOR
CANNABIS LICENSING TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S A REFLECTION OF THE
STATE. YES YEAH AND I AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S- YOU KNOW A
VERY IMPORTANT. PART OF OUR
PROGRAM I KNOW THAT THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL. AS AN
EQUITY- UNIT THAT WORKS VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAMS- WE'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT- ENHANCING THAT IN THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT- I BELIEVE THAT- IT
WAS MENTIONED AT THE BEGINNING
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
THERE'S ALSO- A PROPOSAL TO
HAVE- DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
EQUITY. AND INCLUSION IN THE
NEW DEPARTMENT AS WELL TO
CONTINUE GROWING THAT PROGRAM
AND ENSURING THAT WE ARE.
WORKING WITH ALL THESE
JURISDICTIONS. I'M TO HAVE THE
MOST INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY IN
OUR AND OUR POPULATION OF
LICENSEES THAT WE CAN. THANK
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFULNESS BEHIND IT I YOU
KNOW IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS WE
HAVE ALSO DISCUSSED THAT THIS
NEW OFFICE OF. EQUITY AND
INCLUSION ENSURING THAT ONE
INDIVIDUAL IS NOT SOLELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THE EQUITY
AND DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
EFFORTS THAT THE STATE HAS TO.
WORK ON SINCE THAT SEEMS TO BE-
AN UNREASONABLE. REQUEST FOR
ONE INDIVIDUAL TO SOLELY DO
THIS JOB FOR THEM FOR THESE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE- ONE ONE FINAL ONE FINAL
QUESTION BEFORE I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE ARTS CAUGHT
THE COUNCIL WELL THIS PROPOSAL
TARGETS THE AREAS IN THE STATE
WHERE THE MOST PROVISIONAL
LICENSES ARE HELD IT WOULD MAKE
FUNDS MORE DIFFICULT TO COME BY
ELSEWHERE WHAT MEASURES ARE IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
SIMPLY MOVE THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSING PROBLEM TO A NEW
JURISDICTION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IN THE AND LOOKING AT THE
JURISDICTIONS- WE DID. WE DID
REALLY TRY AND FOCUS ON- FIRST
SECTION OF THE SOCIAL EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND THOSE WITH. REALLY
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
PROVISIONAL LICENSEES- LOOKING
ACROSS THE OTHER- LOOKING
ACROSS THE OTHER JURISDICTIONS
WHERE THERE ARE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES- WE STILL WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH- ALL OF THE
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
EDUCATING THEM ON PATHWAYS FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENSEES TO GET TO
ANNUAL LICENSEES- IN IN LOOKING
AT THIS FUNDING PROGRAM- YOU
KNOW FOR THE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT WE STILL
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT FOR THOSE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS- IF THEY NEED
INFORMATION- TO BE ABLE TO
EIGHT TO. GET THEIR THEIR
LICENSEES INTO ANNUAL AN
INTANGIBLE LICENSURE. THANK
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M GONNA
MOVE ON TOWARDS A QUESTION FOR
THE ARTS COUNCIL THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES SIXTY MILLION
TO ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
CREATIVE CORPS PILOT PROGRAM IN
ANOTHER FORTY MILLION TO FUND A
YOUTH ARTS PER A YOUTH ART ARTS
GRANTS WHAT METRICS WILL YOU BE
USING TO DETERMINE THE SUCCESS
OF THESE PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION. AND SHARE.
AND BOND PROPERTIES IN THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL- THE
METRIC THAT WE USE WILL USE-
WILL BE FOR. IMPACT ON
COMPANIES THROUGH THE CREATIVE
CORE WILL BE DEVELOPED AS WE GO
ALONG WE'RE WE'RE CURRENTLY
DOING EIGHT- CAN ABOUT UA ATION
OF ALL OUR GRANT PROJECTS. AND
PROGRAMS AND THOSE TYPES OF
METRICS WILL BE PART OF THAT
AND BE ENCOURAGED FOR THAT NOW-
IN TERMS OF THE METRICS THAT
WILL USE FOR BETTER. WE HAVE
USED DEVELOPMENT. THAT WILL USE
SIMILAR METRICS THAT WE USED IN
ORDER TO ALREADY EVALUATE AND
ASSESS THEIR JUMPSTART'S
PROGRAM WHICH IS ONE OF OUR
CREATIVE YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS WHERE WE DID AN
INTENSIVE. EVALUATION AND
ASSESSMENT REPORT ON THAT NOW
FROM. THE METRICS INVOLVED YEAH
ASSEMBLY INVOLVES SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING HOW TO HOW
TO THE- KIDS OUR- KEEP COMING
TO SCHOOL WHAT'S A RETENTION
HOW HOW DID THEY BECOME
EMPATHETIC HOW THEY WORK WELL
AS LEADERS AS TEAM MEMBERS AND
THEN HOW DO THEY GO FROM GRADE
SCHOOL TO HIGH SCHOOL ON TO
COLLEGE AND CAREERS. NO I
UNDERSTAND THAT I JUST I'M
CURIOUS AS TO I'M CURIOUS AS TO
THE MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS THE
METRICS AND WHICH YOU WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER THE ONE.
THERE'S DIVERSITY THERE'S
EQUITY THERE'S OUT REACH THAT
THIS POTENTIAL NEW PROGRAM THE
CALIFORNIA CREATIVE COURT
COURTS PILOT PROGRAM. IS A
REFLECTION OF THE POPULATION OF
THE STATE. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION AND THAT SITS AT THE
HEART OF THE PROJECT IT'S A
REGIONALLY BASED PRODUCT
PROJECT WE NEED TO COVER. ALL
THE COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HAVE REGIONAL
FOCUS IN EACH CHARACTER THANK.
THAT WAY WE MAKE SURE THAT WERE
BURNED REACHING. EVERYBODY
INAPPROPRIATE MATTER AND ARE
USING TRUSTED MESSENGERS FROM
THE PARTICULAR REGIONS THAT
THEY'LL THAT ARTISTS WILL BE
HIRED FROM. WELL WE HAVE A
STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK FOR RACIAL
EQUITY AND IN COLLUSION SITS AT
THE CENTER OF IT AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO USE THAT FRAMEWORK
IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS SOME
PROJECT EFFECTIVE. IN ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. HOW YOU
DETERMINE THOSE TRUSTED
MESSENGERS WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE. SO WE HAVE A PRETTY CLEAR
PLAN IN A PASS FORWARD FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER WE PLAN
OFTEN OF MENDING OUR FIFTY FOUR
COUNTY DESIGNATED ARTS COUNCILS
WHICH WE CALL STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH GRANT
CONTRACTS. IT'S JUST SO TAKE
THEIR RE GRANTING CAPACITY TO
LOCAL UNEMPLOYED AND UNDER
EMPLOYED ARTISTS STATEWIDE.
FIRST OF THE HE'S ALSO BE
CONTRACTS SEVERAL PARTNERS WILL
BE IDENTIFIED TO SERVICE
REGIONAL LIAISONS. TO SUPPORT
THE CREATIVE CORE PROGRAM IN
THOSE REGIONAL LIAISONS WILL
HELP HELP LOOK AT EACH AREA OF
THE STATE AND MAKE SURE THAT IT
IS TRULY APPROPRIATE AND
REPRESENTING THAT PARTICULAR
REGION IN ADDITION CA CO
CONTRACTS SEVERAL ADMINISTERING
NONPROFIT ARTS ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT HAVE A CAPACITY FOR RAPID
PAYMENT TO THE ARTISTS TO
CREATE PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
ENSURE OUT REACH TO ALL OF
THOSE AREAS. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE BUT I
GUESS WHAT I'M NOT HEARING IS
ACTUALLY YOUR YOUR PLAN WHAT IS-
HOW YOU DETERMINED. THE
REGIONAL TRUSTED MESSENGERS AN
ADDITIONAL TO THE REGIONAL.
POTENTIAL NONPROFITS THAT CAN
SUPPORT THIS PLAN. SO WE
ALREADY HAVE A STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP NETWORK IN PLACE.
OKAY THEY ARE- IN THEIR
DESIGNATED BY THEIR COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THEY
ARE PARTNERS THAT WE HAVE LONG
STANDING THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IT IS HIGHLY LIKELY THAT MANY
OF THOSE PARTNERS WILL ALSO
BECOME THEIR REGIONAL LEADS.
WE'RE WORKING ON A MORE
DETAILED PLAN NOW AND WE CAN
GET THAT TO YOU AND NOW FOR THE
FUTURE WEREN'T ENCOURAGING
EXCITED BY THE REACTION FIRST A
LOCAL PARTNERS TO BE IN THE
MIDST OF THIS WORK. AND
DETERMINING ON IF IT THE-
RESPONSE IS APPROPRIATE FOR THE
REGION WILL BE PART OF THE
GRANT GUIDELINES HOW THEY'LL DO
THAT HOW IT MAPS WELL WITH OUR
STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK. SO IF I
WERE TO JUST AN EXAMPLE- YEAH
IF I WERE TO. CALL LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND ASK FOR
WHO IS ON CALL IN L. A. COUNTY-HAS BEEN TAPPED TO BE A TRUSTED
COMMUNITY NONPROFIT RELATED TO
THE ARTS THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ME A LIST THAT HAS A
DIVERSE GROUP OF POTENTIAL
NONPROFITS. YES THEY WERE
ACTUALLY THEY WOULD BE RESEARCH
FOR FIRST TWO CHRISTENSEN
KATAKU C. X. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THAT L. A. COUNTY ARTS
CULTURE. DEPARTMENT WHO IS ALSO
OUR STATE LOCAL PARTNER IN THAT
AREA. AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
THEY DO RE GRANTING THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A LIST OF
THEIR CURRENT GRANTEES. AND
SOMEONE. AND OTHER STATE LOCAL
PARTNER THEY THEY WILL GO
THROUGH A VERY. BAD AND-
PROCEDURE TO READ GRANT AND SO
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO LOOK IN
THEIR AREA AND LOOK IN THE
COUNTY. TO ASSESS. WHO CAN COME
ON BOARD IF THEY DON'T ALREADY
HAVE. OKAY I BELIEVE THAT I IF
MEMORY SERVES ME CORRECTLY I
HAD ASKED FOR A PLAN IN THE
LAST HEARING THAT WE HAD AND
MAYBE TO PREVIOUS HEARINGS AGO.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE A BASED ON
WHAT I JUST HEARD YOU SAY THAT
YOU'RE STILL WORKING ON THAT
PLAN IS THAT ACCURATE. WORKING
ON THE DETAILS BUT WE HAVE A
VERY CLEAR PATH USING OUR STATE
LOCAL PARTNERS IN OF BANNING
THEIR CURRENT GRANTS. AND
UPLIFTING THEM WITH RESOURCE.
TO BEAT THE NETWORK THAT WILL.
DO THIS PROGRAM. GOT IT OKAY
THANK YOU. I WE ARE DONE WITH
THIS ISSUE THANK YOU AGAIN TO
ALL THE PANELISTS THAT HAVE
PARTICIPATED AND WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TOWARDS PUBLIC COMMENT.
IN THE HEARING ROOM IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK THEY MAY
RAISE THEIR HANDS AND I WILL
ASK THEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE I WILL ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC RESPECTFUL DISTANCING
AND NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM AS A PUBLIC
COMMENT IS DONE A RETURN TO
YOUR STATE PLEASE BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING LIMITED. ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON. ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND YOU SHOULD ALSO BE
ABLE TO SEE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU ARE WATCHING ONLINE. THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO. OPERATOR
YOU MAY BEGIN. I'M SORRY WE
HAVE ONE PERSON IN THE HEARING
ROOM PLEASE APPROACH THE MIKE.
SO STRANGE WE HAVEN'T HAD
ANYBODY FOR IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU AND NOT IN TURN THIS IS MY
THIS MY FIRST TIME BACK IN
ABOUT A YEAR SO- THANK. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS STRUCTURE YOUR
MICROPHONE IS ON LET'S MAKE
SURE IT'S ON. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOHN THE CLAY REPRESENT THE
PORT OF SAN DIEGO WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT OF THE NAY
REVISED PROPOSAL IN THE TUNER
FIFTY NINE PURPORTS- GIVEN THE
CONVERSATION EARLIER ALL. JUST
OFFERED TO SAY IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO AND GET
INTO THAT BUT- JUST WANT TO
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT
DISCUSSION EARLIER. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN AUTHORIZING THIS
FUNDS PUT THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT PUT OUT GUIDANCE
RELATED TO THOSE EXPENDITURE OF
FUNDS RELATED TO YOU KNOW
ADDRESSING PUBLIC HEALTH
RELATED TO ADDRESSING WORKFORCE
AND LABOR. ALSO INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS WE THINK THAT TREASURY
GUIDANCE GIVES A LOT OF- SORT
OF A FRAMEWORK FOR MOVING
FORWARD- ONE CONCERN THAT WE
WOULD HAVE ON ALL THIS IS. IF
THE STATE WERE TRYING OVERLAY
THE CLIMATE OR THE SEA LEVEL
RISE KIND OF PRIORITIES OUR
CONCERN IS HOW DOES THAT MATCH
UP WITH THAT FEDERAL GUIDANCE
THAT REALLY DICTATES
EXPENDITURE OF THOSE FUNDS SO.
JUST WANNA REYES AS A CONCERN
AS WE MOVE FORWARD SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU AND
WELCOME. OPERATOR LET'S OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT PRESS SOMEONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN THE ONE
THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT. AND JUST SO YOU KNOW
WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY IN THE
QUEUE. WELL GO TO LINE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS AN ENEMY LINE WITHOUT THEM
ONE NIGHT CANONICA BRITTANY
BANNER AND I'M WITH BOTH THE
CALL THE ATP AND SAFETY NET FOR
ALL COMMISSION. I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ALL OF THAT SAFETY
NET FOR ALL PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
RELIEF. WE NEED TO MAKE UP
FORTY MILLION DEALERS GAS AND
EXCLUSION FROM WHICH
REPLACEMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITH THAT I CAN. DO YOUR DATA
IN ANYTIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
FOLLOW PEOPLE. FOR TAKING OUT
FOR ALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. MAX WHAT'S FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
LINE FIFTY SIXTY MAY BE NEEDED.
HELLO MAXO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAXIMO CAROLINE SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI JOHN ASIDE WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BANKS
THANK YOU CHAIRPERSN IN KOREA
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT-
WE PUT THE FLAG ARE SUPPORT FOR
EXTENDING THE SOON TO EXPIRE
THE BANK IN ASIAN TAX CREDIT BY
FIVE YEARS WHICH IS CHAMPIONED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE AND
SENATOR EGGMAN. THAT TAX CREDIT
IS CURRENTLY GIVEN FOR THE
DONATION OF MANY HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA GROUND SUITS AND IS
A TRIPLE WIN ITS PREVENTION AT
THE PROVINCIAL TO FIGHT HUNGER
IT REDUCES HEAT LOSS AND
PREVENTS METHANE EMISSIONS THAT
ARE A KEY DRIVER OF CLIMATE
CHANGE NECKAR SUPPORTS THE HARD
HIT AGRICULTURE AND FOOD
SYSTEMS SECTOR BY PROVIDING A
15% CREDIT ON THE WHOLESALE
VALUE OF THE FOODS THAT HELP
COVER THE PICKING. BACK UP
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER COSTS
TO DOWNEY- IT COSTS LESS THAN A
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND IT
DELIVERS AN OUTSIZED IMPACT
ENSURING DONATIONS OF BATTLING
NEEDED FRESH PRODUCE DAIRY
PROTEINS AND OTHER STAPLES WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TURNED SURE THE
POLICY DOES NOT SENSE THAT AT
THE END OF THIS YEAR. AND TO
SUPPORT THE BANKS AND FARMERS
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WE ALSO
SUPPORT MAKING COVERT STIMULUS
RELIEF INCLUSIVE OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS FOR REAL
EQUITY CALIFORNIA IT SHOULD
FUND A REAL SAFETY NET FOR
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM FEDERAL RELIEF. WE NEED TO
MAKE UP FOR STIMULUS CAPTION
EXCLUSION FROM WAGE REPLACEMENT
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WITHOUT ITUNES IF YOUR
CAN YOU. IT WE CAN DO IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU KNOW
COLOR. MAX OF TELLING SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU- HI YES MARANDA
SHEFFIELD I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE WAREHOUSE WORKER
RESOURCE CENTER WITH THE SAFETY
NET FOR ALL COALITION I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EXPANDING
THE RESOURCES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
EXCLUDED WORKERS- SO THAT ARE
AND YOU NEED REVISED BUDGET
REFLECTS OUR VALUES. OUR ASKING
TO FILL THE STIMULUS GAPS AND
TO ALSO- ADDRESSED THE ISSUE A
WAGE REPLACEMENT FOR OUR
DOCUMENT CHANGE- WORKERS AND
JUST BEFORE NEW YORK IS ABLE TO
COOK FOR THIS- POLICY WE
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN DO
THIS WITH A SEVENTY FIVE
BILLION SURPLUS. WE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
SUPPORT SAFETY NET FOR ALL
SOLIDARITY NOT CHARITY OR ARE.
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS THANK YOU.
THEY YOU NEXT CALLER. MAXIMAL
CAROLINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI THIS IS JEFF
NELSON I'M THE CHIEF POLICY
STRATEGIST FOR THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO AND WE'RE CALLING TODAY
IN SUPPORT O THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
QUIRKS REPORTER SAN DIEGO IS
FORECASTING A LOSS OF NINETY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
OPERATING REVENUES SINCE THE
PANDEMIC CARE. NETWORK BUDGET
THAT IS NORMALLY AROUND TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
SHORTFALL THE SPICES THAT
OVERWHELMING BARRIER TO
COMPLETE OUR MISSION- AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LOSE ABOUT FOURTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN OPERATING
REVENUES PER QUARTER TOLD THE
ECONOMY TURNS AROUND SPEAKER
PELOSI IN OUR CALIFORNIA
SENATORS THEY PUT PROVISIONS IN
AMERICAN RESCUE PLANS TO ALLOW
US TO- ACCESS THESE BONDS FROM
A- DIRECT TRANSFER FROM THE
STATE- AND THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THE REPORT CAN DIRECTLY
BENEFIT FROM THE RECENTLY.
ENACTED FEDERAL STIMULUS
PACKAGE. CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS
MADE IT CLEAR ON THE FLOOR THAT
THESE PROVISIONS ARE BEING PUT
IN THERE SPECIFICALLY TO HELP
WORKS. AND AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER PORTER COMMITTED TO
ACCELERATING OUR EFFORTS TO
GREEN UP CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY-
BUT IN SOME CASES BECAUSE LOS
RESIDENTES A LARGE WE'RE NOT
FIGHTING WITH ONE HAND TIED
BEHIND OUR BACK. I'M THAT SAID
WE ALSO NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS MEAN TO
SPEND THE MONEY ON. THE LOSS OF
LIVING WAGE JOBS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE REPAIRS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT OFF. WE NEED TO
WE NEED TO ALLOW US TO BUILD
BACK BETTER WE NEED TO GET
PORTS FLEXIBILITY TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR EMPLOYEES. AND HANDLE
ALL THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT WAS PUT OFF FOR OVER A
YEAR- WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION. ON KIND
OF DEFINING WHAT SOME OF THOSE
NEEDS ARE- BUT ALSO WOULD BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH GO BIZ
THAT THAT'S THE DIRECTION THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNORSHIP CHOOSE- TO GO-
THAT SAID- YOUR HELP WITH. ITS
MUCH NEEDED AND WE DO THINK THE
TREASURY GOTTEN SERVES AS A
KIND OF A MORE STARK HELP.
DEFINE WHAT THIS PROGRAM LOOKS
LIKE. THANK YOU NEXT CALL. AND
JUST ENTERING. YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE. MAXIMAL CAROLINE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ADAM
BARNETT BARTENDER IN ORGANIZER
IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WITH THE
SAFETY NET FOR ALL COOLEY GOT
COALITION TOO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY WERE EXCLUDED FROM THE
SENATE THANK YOU KNOW AND WHAT
TENS OF THOUSANDS IN WAGES PER
PERSON MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO RUN OUT
DISPROPORTIONATE RISK DURING A
PANDEMIC IN ORDER TO SURVIVE
WITH THEIR FAMILY. THE NEW YORK
HAS SHOWN US THAT REAL SUPPORT
CAN BE OFFERED TO OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES IN IN OUR STATE THE
NEW YORK AND DO WHAT WE CAN DO
IT TOO WE NEED TO MAKE UP FOR
STIMULUS CAPTAIN EXCLUSION FROM
WAIT REPLACEMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY THOSE
WITHOUT. I TEN NUMBERS THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NOT. MAXIMAL CAROLINE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR AREER ON MEMBERS ALEX OR
THE STRATEGY THREE THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
SIX HUNDRED INDEPENDENT VENUES
AND PROMOTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YOUR STATEMENT SUPPORT FOR THE
ARTS AND CREATIVE ECONOMY TODAY
WE HAVE PROPOSED A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS VENUE
STIMULUS GRANT PRETTY SMALL
BUSINESSES AGED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT IS REALLY GOOD
APSLEY CRITICAL FOREIGN
PROBABLY JOIN OUR COALITION
PARTNERS BE CALIFORNIA IS NOT
THE CASE IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. VM TO PROPOSE A
TRANSFORMATIONAL ONE BILLION
DOLLAR ARTS ECONOMY WHICH
INCLUDES OUR VALUES GRANT
PROGRAM WE ARE PROUD TO PRESENT
THE BUDGET THAT THE SENATE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FOR LAST
WEEK AND OPENNESS COMMITTEE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO COMPETITORS
ITEM GOING FORWARD ONE
EXPRESSED SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
A FEW SPECIFIC MEMBERS AND
DISTRICT INCLUDING THE BLOOD
DRAWN THE AIRLINER AND SILVER
LAKE ONTO YOUR DISTRICT MADAM
CHAIR AND- THE ONE HUNDRED TEN
THEN YOU MEMBERS OF THE LA
INDEPENDENT VENUE COALITION FOR
MEMBERS MEDICARE AND LACKEY. MR
CHIU A CALLING TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FROM THE BILL GRAHAM
CIVIC AUDITORIUM THE
INDEPENDENT AND MISTER COOPER
FOLLOWS THE PRESS HERE BOTH IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY ALL
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- ALIGNED IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A PROPOSAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. MAXIM TELLING
THIRTY. PLEASE AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS IS PLOY ALREADY
HAVE A SERIES MAYOR BREED IS A
FOR TO IT ALMOST AND CAL I WANT
TO SAY ASSEMBLY TO FOR HIS
COMMENTS MORE FLEXIBLE FUNDING
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- TO
ADDRESS OPERATING BECAUSE I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THEIR
COMMENTS IN RESPONSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER Q. TO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE FLEXIBLE FUNDING FOR
OPERATING COSTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NICE COLOR.
MAXELL MULTILINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE WELL I HAD. NINE SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS MARTHA
MILLER AT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PORT AUTHORITY
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE
CONTINUE TO HAVE ONE MINUTE.
EIGHT THANK YOU I'M TESTIFYING
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ALLOCATION- THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT. IN THE
AMERICAN RECOVERY ACT- BY
SPEAKER PELOSI AND HER STAFF TO
HELP THE PARTS WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY INCLUDING
PREMIUM PAY REVENUE LOSS FOR
GOVERNMENTAL SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
INCLUDING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
AND WE SUPPORT INVESTORS HAVE.
ALLOCATION ON BEHALF OF THE
ELEVEN PART IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. MAXIMAL
TIELINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS TINA
BALLOTS WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
MON PROPERTY AND WE ARE
COMMENTING ON ISSUE ONE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS- LIKE TO
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR
DEDICATING AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION TO
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
UTILITIES AS WELL AS ALLOWING
1100% OF ARREARS AND
PROSPECTIVE BRIDE WHICH TENANTS
NEED. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZING THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL TOOL TO PREVENT
EVICTIONS FOR LEGAL SERVICES
BUT THE BUDGET PROPOSAL COMES
WOEFULLY SHORT OF WHAT THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS WE URGE THE
LEGISLATOR TO ADD ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILLION ON TOP OF
THAT THREE YEAR SIXTY MILLION
TOTAL PROPOSAL BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND LASTLY THE GOVERNOR TWELVE
BILLION ALLOCATION FOR
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PROPOSAL BUT WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO ELIMINATE THE FUNDING FOR
CLEAN UP A PROMISING CAPTAINS
AND INSTEAD REDIRECT THAT
FUNDING INTO PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL SERVICES TO THE
PEOPLE WHO. LIVE IN THOSE AND
CABINET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR. MAXIMAL LINE ONE OH
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON
WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR
YEARS I'M CALLING- TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR ITEMS THAT WERE IN
MAY REVISED THE EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM. AND THE FIVE
MILLION FOR HOUSING NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM AND ALSO THE INCLUSION
OF A NEW SATISFIED FOR
ADDITIONAL SECOND ROUND OF HOME
KEY FUNDING- AND TEETH WERE
EXCLUDED FROM- THE FIRST ROUND-
FUNCTIONALLY SO WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THOSE IN THE FINAL
BUDGET WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
FLEXIBLE FUNDING THAT WAS
DISCUSSED IN TODAY'S- BY
TODAY'S NUMBERS INCLUDING- WE
ARE CO SPONSORS OF BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME A BUDGET
PROPOSAL AN ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY ONE. WHICH INCLUDED 10%
SATISFIED FOR UNACCOMPANIED
HOMELESS YOUTH AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT IN THE FINAL
BUDGET THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. MAXIM OF TELLING
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR- MORE
TALK ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO- WE TOO ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND APPRECIATIVE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS- THE
INVESTMENT IS CERTAINLY
SIGNIFICANT AND VERY MUCH
NEEDED. BUT IF SOME OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE NOTED
EARLIER WITHOUT CONTINUED
INVESTMENT OF THE FLEXIBLE
LOCAL DOLLARS WE WON'T BE ABLE
TO FULLY REALIZE THE VALUE OF
THE PROPOSED INVESTMENT. ARE IN
THE POPULAR LOCAL HAP DOLLARS
MATCH PHYSICAL RESOURCES- WITH
THOSE NECESSARY WRAPAROUND
SERVICES YEAH WE WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
INCLUDE- SOME SIGNIFICANT MULTI
YEAR HAPPENED- IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET AND ALSO ONE ECHO- OUR
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR. MAXIMAL CAROLINE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS NICOLO TO LOOK AT
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF OAKLAND
BERKELEY SAN LEANDRO SANTANA A
WORD IN FREMONT WE'RE SO
EXCITED TO SEE THE VARIOUS-
PROPOSALS BILLION TO
HOMELESSNESS AND THE VERY SPOT
THE FUNDING TO ARE VERY
GRATEFUL AND AS OTHER CALLERS
HAVE SAID WE SUPPORT THE DIRECT
ALLOCATION OF FLEXIBLE FUNDING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS- UNDER
THAT HAVE PROGRAM- AND
CERTAINLY ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS ARE APPROPRIATE.
FOR THESE VARIOUS PROGRAMS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR. MAXALT TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE CALL I HAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JULIE SNYDER REPRESENTING THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE THE
INSTITUTE AN INDEPENDENT PUBLIC
POLICY ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO ADVANCING SOUND POLICY ON
BRAIN HEALTH ISSUES WE ARE A
MEMBER OF THE BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION AND IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
OF OPPORTUNITY PROPOSAL FOR
SUBSTANTIAL MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. IN THAT CONTACT
ON TOP OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
WE WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROPRIATE AT LEAST TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR FOUR
YEARS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
USING THE PROGRAMMATIC
FRAMEWORK IN THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME ACT OR EIGHTY
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY LUIS
REBA. THIS FRAMEWORK
INCORPORATES ROBUST
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN SOUGHT BY YOUR
MEMBERS IT ALSO REFLECTS THE
AUDITORS A RECENT
RECOMMENDATION TO FUND DATA
DRIVEN INVESTMENTS IN EVIDENCED
BASED SOLUTIONS FINALLY IT
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY TO
LOCALITIES WELL FOCUSING
PRIMARILY ON PERMANENT SOLUTION
TO HOMELESSNESS. BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME REALLY REFLECTS
THE LESSONS THAT WE'VE LEARNED
OVER THE PAST THIRTY YEARS
ABOUT WHAT BUT THE FACT IS AN
EFFICIENT AND IT'S THE NEXT
STEP IN THE EVOLUTION OF THE
STATE'S MONEY PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS WE URGE.
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
MAXIMO TO LINE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE CALL HAD. STIRS TO URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
DAVID THE CALIFORNIA- MEMBERS
MAKING MENTION TANNERS THAT
HOTELS AND RENTAL CARS GETTING
PEOPLE BACK TO THE STATE IN
TRAVELING HERE IS OF PARAMOUNT
AND PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
MAXIMO CAROLINE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I BEING BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS SPEAKING ON MY
OWN BEHALF REGARDING THE EDT
PRESENTATION HAVING
ECONOMICALLY DIVERSE REGIONS IS
AN IDEA PRESENTED TO THE EIGHTY
NINETEEN LEGISLATOR ON AUGUST
SECOND OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BY THE COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS. HAVING
A HIGH CONCENTRATION OF HIGH
PAYING TECH JOBS IN THE BAY
AREA IMPACTS BOTH THE HOUSING
AND TRANSPORTATION SECTORS
ALTHOUGH THE LEGISLATOR
REJECTED THIS IDEA IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I BELIEVE
THIS IS AN IDEA WHOSE TIME HAS
COME REGARDING THE ROLE OF
UNIONS. IN THE NEW CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY IANS HAVE BEEN CREDITED
WITH WEEKLY BY LIGHTING THE
ECONOMY IN COUNTRIES SUCH AS
GERMANY AND GERMANY EATING IT
IS HAVE A BROAD ROLE AND EVEN
SERVE ON CORPORATE BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS UNIONS COULD HAVE AN
EXPANDED ROLE IN CALIFORNIA AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR. MAXIMO TELLING NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDERS OF A COMMA TODAY
JUSTIN ROSE ON BEHALF OF WORKER
OWNED RECOVERY CALIFORNIA WE
ARE COALITION A STATE AND
NATIONAL EXPERTS ON WORKER
OWNERSHIP WORK ON BUSINESS AND
ORGANIZED LABOR- IN RELATION TO
ISSUE THREE. WE ACTUALLY HAVE
THE REQUEST SUBMITTED BY COMING
MEMBER KALRA AND SIGNED ON TO
BY ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES ON
THE COMMITTEE I'M A MEMBER TO-
FOR DEDICATED LONG CAPITAL.
THROUGH COPAYS. TO CONVERT
EXISTING SMALL BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE TO WORKER OWNERSHIP.
THAT COULD HELP ACCOMPLISH SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED THIS AFTERNOON AROUND
PROVIDING HIGH WAGE JOBS AND
PATHWAYS FOR CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE- AND OFFICERS
THAT THAT BUSINESS PRESERVATION
STRATEGY I WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NICE COLOR. MAXIMAL
CAROLINE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
JULIE MALACHOWSKI BALL ON
BEHALF OF A CALIFORNIA HOTEL
AND LODGING ASSOCIATION CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
NEWLY REVISED ALLOCATING NINETY
FIVE MILLION PER VISIT
CALIFORNIA'S MARKETING CAMPAIGN
THE FUNDS ARE A DOWN PAYMENT TO
GETTING CALIFORNIA TRAVEL AND
TOURISM INDUSTRY BACK ON ITS
FEET. MORE THAN 20% OF ALL
CALIFORNIA HOTEL CLOSE DURING
THE PANDEMIC HOTEL MORTGAGE
DELINQUENCIES SKYROCKETED OVER
NINETY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WERE
LAID OFF 98% OF THOSE WERE
UNION JOBS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ADDITIONAL
MEASURES TO GET CALIFORNIA
WORKERS BACK ON THE JOB THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
MAXIM OF NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
WITH IRVINE URBAN COUNTY FOR
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL
STATE HOMELESSNESS INVESTMENTS
HAVE DISCUSSED TODAY WE
PREVIOUSLY SUBMITTED A LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE INDICATING WE
ARE BOTH SUPPORTIVE OF
ADDITIONAL ACQUISITION PROGRAMS
LIKE PROJECT HUNKY WITH
APPROPRIATE CAPITALISATION OF
OPERATING COSTS. AND ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBLE FUNDS FOR EACH STEP IN
THE CONTINUING TO BUILD OFF OF
HAPPENS INVESTMENTS DISCUSSED
TODAY ALONGSIDE THE HOMELESS.
HOMELESSNESS INVESTMENT BEING%
CONTEMPLATED AND SOCIAL
SERVICES AND HEALTHCARE
SERVICES ARE A GREAT STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION WE KNOW THERE
ARE STILL MANY CONVERSATIONS TO
HAVE RELATIVE TO A FINAL
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE AND ARE
READY TO ENGAGE FURTHER AT THIS
IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR COUNTIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. MAXIMAL TIMELINE AB
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
EVENING KILLERS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YEARS AND I JUST WHEN I THOUGHT
THAT CHAIR AND TAP FOR THE
COMMENTS TODAY AND APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO YOUR THE
CRANKING HOME NOT THAT WE KNOW
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN THE NATION AND 80% OF
CALIFORNIANS EITHER ACTUALLY
UNSHELTERED SO PROBABLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ATTENTION THAT PULLING OUT
DOLLARS FOR OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WE
KNOW WE NEED TO DO MORE AND WE
CAN END YOUR COMIC MATH OF
WELL. THAT THE BEST WAY THAT WE
CAN GO ABOUT ENDING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS BY STOPPING THE
PIPELINE INTO THE TEN THE
TRAJECTORY AND ONE WE KNOW WE
CAN DO SO MUCH AROUND YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH THEIR BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT UP UNTIL THE AGE OF
TWENTY FIVE THIS IS A CRITICAL
MOMENT IN THEIR LIFE AND WE
NEED TO YOU AND CAN BE DONE SO
MUCH MORE TO SUPPORT THEM SO
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES IN THE LONG RUN THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT. AND
THAT THEY CONTINUE. TO INCLUDE
SATISFIED THREE IF. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. MAXIMO NINE ONE OUT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIRMAN
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
IT'S HEALTHY HOUSING
FOUNDATION- WE APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR- FOR THE MANY MANY-
VERY GOOD PROGRAMS HE'S
PROPOSED RELATIVE TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND- AND
HOMELESSNESS- WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS HOWEVER
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS ONE WHO'S
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND THAT'S RELATED TO
GETTING RENTAL ASSISTANCE
DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR- BEFORE
THE- BUT THE CLIFF OCCURS ON
JULY FIRST. I'M AT THE END OF
THE ADDICTION MORATORIUM WE- WE
SUBMIT THAT SIX WEEKS IS NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT LL THAT MONEY GETS OUT
THE DOOR- WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE MAY VERY WELL WANT
TO CONSIDER SOME SOFT LANDING
LANGUAGE IN A TRAILER BILL THAT
WOULD ENSURE THAT ON JULY FIRST
WE DON'T HAVE- PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY NOT BEHIND IN THEIR
RENT- BEING KICKED OUT OF IT.
GETTING KICKED OUT OF THEIR
HOMES THE SECOND POINT WOULD
LIKE TO RAISE IS RELATIVE TO A
KEY OPPORTUNITY WE BELIEVE IS
BEING MISSED RELATIVE TO
INCENTIVIZING- NONPROFITS TO
USE PRIVATE FUNDS TO DEVELOP
LOW INCOME HOUSING AS A CHEF
HAS DONE ACROSS THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- YOU CAN GET AN
UNLIMITED PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION IF YOU USE STATE AND
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO PAY FOR
THOSE PROJECTS- YOU GET A VERY
LIMITED PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION.
IF YOU USE ONLY PRIVATE FUNDS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MATT TO LINE TO FOUR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS YOUR
BOND WORKS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOU AS PER YOUTH
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ELEVATE YOUNG
PEOPLE- WE KNOW THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HAS INCREASED
NUMBERS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WILL BE WITH THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION REALLY
APPLAUD THAT AND REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT IS STRUCTURED
IN A WAY THAT IS GOING TO
SUPPORT THE- YOU KNOW SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT I'M GOING
TO GET OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS TO.
THEIR OF THEIR BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT SO THE STRUCTURE WE
BELIEVE SERVES YOUNG PEOPLE-
AND HIS STAFF OUTLINED AND THE
SUPPORT ACT- FROM STE- SENATORS
SCOTT WIENER SO- WE ALSO WANT
TO SUPPORT ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR ALMOST SERVICES I
WANT TO ENSURE THAT ANY DOLLARS
FOR SERVICES CONTINUE BY THE
USE SATISFIED AND COMPONENTS
THAT YOU KNOW LEGISLATORS COULD
CHAMPION- AND CONTINUE TO WORK
FOR SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY UNDER DISCUSSION AS
WE BRING THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
BECAUSE- THEY'RE NOT JUST OUR
FUTURE TOMORROW THERE ARE
FUTURE TODAY. SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS TOP. THANK YOU
NEXT COME. MAXO MOTEL THIRTY
PLEASE COULD I HAVE. THANK YOU
HONORABLE TO I AM THE
OPPORTUNITY ADDRESS YOU MY NAME
EIGHT BEHIND TRY AGAIN I'M WITH
WHERE CAT CAN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
THE HIGH LEVEL OF YOU CONSENTED
HERE TODAY BUT CAN'T GO INTO
SOME DETAILS YOU'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS. OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
ANTI DISPLACEMENT AND HOUSING
PRESERVATION PACKAGE ITEM
NUMBER ONE OF THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM ITS
CHAMPIONS BY SIMPLY NUMBER CORK
AND SIGNED ON TO BUY SOMETHING
NUMBER FIFTY NINE. AND IT IS
FOUR SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION OVER THE COURSE OF FIVE
YEARS TO ACQUIRE THAT- FOR
CLOSE PROPERTIES UNDER AND HE
TEN SEVENTY NINE THAT WAS
ENACTED FROM LAST YEAR AND THEN
AGAIN THE SECOND ITEM ON IN
THIS ANTI DISPLACEMENT HOUSING
PRESERVATION PACKAGE IS THE-
COMMUNITY ACQUISITION AND
PRESERVATION PROGRAM CHAMPIONED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILLIAM AND
THAT WOULD BE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT
ACQUISITION AND PRESERVATION
ARE WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WITH
KEYBOARD COMMENTARY ABOUT.
EQUITY AND FOCUS EQUITY
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE HEARING
THANK YOU THINK THAT AS THE
NEVER ENDING FOCUS OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE WE APPRECIATE
YOU THANK. YOU THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR. NEXT VOTE I AM FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHECK REMEMBER THE COMMITTEE BY
NAME IS JULIE BAKER DRIVE CAL
ARTS HITS THE INTERESTS OF THE
OVERFLOW THOUSAND ARTS CULTURE
AND HUMANITIES NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION NUMBER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND ARTS
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA WE LIKE
TO COMMEND THE STEPS TAKEN BY
GOVERNOR NEED MINUTES MABEL
VISION AND MORE SUPPORT ABOUT
THE VERY ARTICULATED BATHROOMS
BIG MADE IN THAT PROPOSAL. BUT
TODAY WE'RE ASKING THE
COMMITTEE TO GO FURTHER AND
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
REQUEST OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT TWO TO FOUR YEARS
FOR THE COVERAGE OUR CULTURAL
MY DEFENSE INDUSTRY. THE
PROPOSAL WOULD SUPPORT MY
PARTNER THAT NEED A CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF MUSEUMS
REPRESENT A CRITICAL INVESTMENT
IN HUMAN CAPITAL INFRASTRUCTURE
OF THE INDUSTRY SPECIFICALLY
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OR
SO THE GOVERNOR'S ONE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS TO HELP THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL PEOPLE
THEIR PROGRAM REACHING EVERY
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA AND
INCREASE INVESTMENT SPECIFIC
FINDING SOLUTIONS TO THE IMPACT
OF EIGHTY FIVE ON OUR SECTOR.
EXPANDED FROM THE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROGRAM AND CREATE A
NEW WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS SPECIFIC TO THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRY TO BUILD AN
EQUITABLE PIPELINE FOR NEW JOBS
AND COMMUNITY ACCESS TO ART
YOUR PLEASE ENTER LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP CHAMPIONS OF THE ONE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT ASK
INCLUDE SENATORS BEN ALLEN AND-
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAURA
FRIEDMAN AGREEMENT VARIANT AND
JUNK SILVA ALL THE PROGRAM
THREE MINISTERED BY THE C. A.
C. WOULD BE BASED ON A
COMPETITIVE MULTI YEAR GRANT
PROGRAM. WITH CLARITY TOWARDS
COMMUNITY BUT BEEN
TRADITIONALLY UNDER RESEARCH
WHICH IS MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
COME COLIN. THANK YOU WE URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
ONE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
AND WILL COVER THE ART CULTURE
AND CREATIVE INDUSTRIES AND I
HOPE. YOU GET SOME REST YOU
ROCK THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
PLEASE SOME OF SIXTIES PLEASE
CALL. CARE INCOMING MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SELECTED AND I NEXT
AFTER OF THE K. AT THE OF. ALL
WITH K. ARE AT THE AND EVEN CAL
AND MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
STATE AND LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
BUSINESSES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE ARE REQUESTING
ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO BE SPENT
OVER FOUR YEARS TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S ART CULTURE AND
CREATIVITY FACTOR AS CHAMPIONED
BY SENATORS ALLEN AND RUBIO AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRIEDMAN CORK
SILVA AND NECESSARY AND-
INCLUDED IN THE- PROPOSAL IN
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. TO THE CALIFORNIA
CORTANA DARKLING DAMMIT WHICH
IS HOUSED WITHIN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY ACHT WHAT THE
FABULIST IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE. SO LET'S STOP LIFT UP
UNDERREPRESENTED STORIES IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND THIRD
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
TRANSACTION FEES PHD HAVE BEEN
ON HAVE BEEN UNFUNDED FOR
SEVERAL YEARS- WE APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRED THE QUESTIONS THAT
THE PORT AND URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING IS
INCLUDED IN THE FINAL BUDGET
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO ADELINE TO
VOICE SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
THE OAKLAND MUSEUM AND OAKLAND
TO THANK. YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. MAX KALAW FIFTH
SAID PLEASE GO OUT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANGRY AND
WE ILL SHOW YOU THEIR HANDS WE
SMOKEAROUND LYING HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI- REGARDING A-
PROPOSAL MAY REVISE FROM
GOVERNOR NEWSOM RELATIVE TO. A
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING AND WE
SUPPORTED TWO BILLION DOLLARS
SET ASIDE FOR DIRECT FLEXIBLE
GRANTS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS YOU
CONTINUED SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS
ARE LIKE A BRIDGE HOME- WE ALSO
SUPPORT- THE ALLOCATION FORMULA
OUTLINED IN AB SEVENTY ONE
RIVAS WHICH ALSO INCLUDES VERY
IMPORTANT ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS SOME OF WHICH HAVE
BEEN INCLUDED AT LEAST AGAINST
MERS WE CAN TELL IN THIS MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL WE THANK YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE MATTER AND WE
APPRECIATE QUESTIONS BUT- AT
THE TOP END OF THIS HEARING
FOCUSED ON. SOME OF THESE-
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE DESIGN
OF THIS HISTORIC PROPOSAL AND
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU I'M
SHARING YOUR COLLEAGUES TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO MAKE A REAL LASTING
CHANGE. THIRTY FIVE
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU COLOR
PLEASE. MAXIM TELLING SIX EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
GIOVANNA MORALIS WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WE
APPRECIATE THE SIXTEEN MILLION
IT TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING LEGAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS THIS IS A
SESSION TO PROVIDE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE WHO NEED
IT THE MOST THE COMMITTEE A
LEGISLATURE **** MUST ENSURE
THAT MORE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED
PRINTER SEARCH AREA ALSO
DESPITE THE INCREASINGLY
DESPERATE SITUATION IN OASIS
MOBILE HOME PARK IT DOES NOT
APPEAR THAT THERE'S ANY FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY ALLOCATED FOR
RELOCATION OF OASYS MOBILE HOME
PARK RESIDENTS. AND IT IS
UNCLEAR WHETHER ANY OF THE
FUNDS PROPOSED TO ADDRESS
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS WILL
TARGET THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
IN LEASES SHE DIRE SITUATION
AND THINK WATER SEEPING SEWAGE
POWDER POWER OUTAGES AND
INTIMIDATION GOT EVEN MORE
PRECARIOUS WHEN THE PROGRAM WAS
UNEXPECTEDLY PASSED AWAY
USHERING IN WHAT APPEARS TO BE
A CHAOTIC SITUATION WHERE PARK
OWNERSHIP AND MANAGEMENT IS AND
WHAT CONDITION CONTINUED TO
WORSEN WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
MAKE A DIRECT ALLOCATION FOR
EASTER. TO PROVIDE RELIEF NOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR
PLACE. MAX TO E. TO PLEASE GO
OUT. WELL I AM EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK GOD I'M
THINKING ABOUT IMPAIRING
MEMBERS I LOOK AT THE HIGH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSALS FOR
ADD ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT AND
ECONOMIC PART OF THE PART. AS
WELL AS THAT PROPOSALS FOR A BE
A RARE DISEASE YOU COULD NOT
IMAGINE THE MATERIAL. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY COOLEY COOPER MANY
ACCESS TO FISCAL RELEASED BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY COVENANTING
RESPONSE EFFORT AND WHILE MANY
CONTINUE TO BE LOCKED OUT WE
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE ENTITIES AND
URGE YOUR CONSIDERATION FOR
ADOPTION THE FINAL BUDGET THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT COLOR PLACE.
MAXIMO THE LINE NINETY EIGHT.
PLEASE CALL. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR NUMBERS KRISTEN BACK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WE WANT TO REALLY
APPRECIATE BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND MAYBE FOR
YOUR DEDICATION AND ATTENTION
TO THE ISSUE I'M NOT- WE WERE
VERY GLAD TO SEE THE GOVERNOR
ARTICULATE A VISION FOR ENDING
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS AND WE
SHARE THAT VISION. HOWEVER HE
NOTED THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
SPECIFICS YOU FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS AND THROUGHOUT THE
PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE- THERE IS AN ABSENCE OF A
RECOGNITION OF THE INTERSECTION
ABOUT WITH THAT ONE. ON ANY
GIVEN DAY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTERS HOW MORE CHILDREN THAN
ADULTS BECAUSE THEY PRIMARILY
HOW FAMILY. AND WE CANNOT
ADDRESS FAMILY HOMELESSNESS
WITHOUT ALSO ADDRESSING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WE WOULD URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
OPPORTUNITIES FINAL BUDGET
ISSUE- BETTER DIRECT. FAMILY
HOME OF FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EMERGENCY
SHELTERS TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
AND HOUSING FIRST PROGRAM THE
COURT USE CRITICALLY NEEDED
SERVICES AND FAMILIES-
FURTHERMORE WE ARE ALSO PART OF
THE BRING CALIFORNIA HOME
COALITION. IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMPREHENSIVE STRUCTURE
OUTLINED IF NOT BUDGET REQUEST.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TOWARDS FINAL BUDGET THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT COLOR.
MAXIMO TO LINE FIVE WE'VE GOT.
MEMBERS NOT TO CONSOLIDATE AND
OF THE HOW LOWER ACTION. WE
URGE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT OF TO PUT
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
FUND UNDER THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
THE ONE TIME ALLOCATION AS
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
FEDERAL DOLLARS WITH SUPPORT
REGIONAL AND LOCAL STAKEHOLDER
COLLABORATION TO PLAN IMPLEMENT
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC STRATEGY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND WORKFORCE. AND
REFLECT THE SHIFTING INDUSTRIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. MAXIMO MAY EAST PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JORDAN
BOTH A CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION WE
APPRECIATE THAT- EMPHASIS ON
YOUTH AND THE GOVERNOR'S
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT SERVICES AND
COMMUNITY SERVING AND ENGAGING
WITH CURRENT OR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR THE FUNDS
DIRECTLY HISTORICALLY YOU'D
HAVE BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED DURING ECONOMIC.
DOWNTURNS AND THE PANDEMIC HAS
EXACERBATED THE IMPACTS OF KERN
A FORMER BOSS USED WE ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SB TWO
THIRTY FOURTH THE SUPPORT ACT
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT FOR
PROJECT HOME KEY WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHT. EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE ON GOING
FUND FOR THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM AND FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
FUNDING FOR THE HOUSING
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM AND ARE PROUD
SUPPORTERS AB SEVENTY ONE WE
UPLOAD SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES AND WANT
TO ENSURE THAT ANY DOLLARS FOR
SERVICES CONTINUE TO BE
SATISFIED FOR CURRENT AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THANK. YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. THE
MAXIMUM LINE ONE MILITARY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CARE MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEXIS
AND I'M A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AND NOW ADVOCATE ONCE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF BRINGING
CALIFORNIA HOME WHICH INCLUDES
THE 10% CERTIFIED TO SERVE
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH
I'D ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
IN THE MAYBE FIVE. TO EIGHT
EIGHT MILLION FOR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PROGRAM THE FIVE
MILLION BIRD HOUSING NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM IN THE PROPOSAL TO
INCLUDE TO GET CERTIFIED IN
HOCKEY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT CALL. MAXIMO CAROLINA ONE
OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS JOE MEEKER WITH
THAT SUBJECT LEGAL SERVICES IN
LOS ANGELES I ALSO CALL THE
NUMBER OF BASIC YOU KNOW PRO
COALITION I'M CALLING REGARDING
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS AND
EQUITABLE RECOVERY THE FUNDS IN
THE SECOND GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS ARE MUCH NEEDED
HOWEVER CURRENTLY PROPOSALS
STILL LEAVE OUT TOO MANY
WORKERS AND FAMILIES WHO HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
STIMULUS ESPECIALLY
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. WE URGE
YOU TO INCREASE RELIEF FUNDS
FOR UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
INCLUDING BOTH I CAN FILERS AS
WELL AS UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS
WITHOUT YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND WE
URGE YOU TO TAKE OUT THE
ALEJO'S RECOMMENDATION TO
EXPAND SILICON DOCUMENTED
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM PREVIOUS PAYMENTS AND WE
ALSO ASK THE BUDGET GO FURTHER
BY PROVIDING WE'D REPLACEMENT
TO FAMILIES THAT HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
PROGRAM. A TRULY QUITABLE
RECOVERY MUST INCLUDE WEIGHT
REPLACEMENT AND MORE SUPPORT.
FOR UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
SOME CAROLINA TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PUBLIC HEARING MEMBERS
OF THE MONEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING THE STATE'S TRAVEL
AND TOURISM INDUSTRY I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA'S MARKETING CAMPAIGN
TO JUMPSTART NOT ONLY BUT
TOWARD THEM IN THE STREETS
RECOVERY BUT THE ENTIRE STATE
TO CONNIE. WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUICK SILVA ALONG WITH
MANY OF YOUR COLLEAGUES TO
PRIORITIZE THEM LISTEN LAST.
NIGHT AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NICE COLOR.
MAXIMO CAROLINA WON ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BECAUSE THE
RESPONSES POLICY ADVOCATE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY YOU WANNA GO TO
COMMENTS MADE ABOUT EXPANDING
STATES THE MINISTER
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO LACK AND I
CANNOT BURN OUT THE PAIN YOU'VE
BEEN SHUT OUT OF PANDEMIC THAT
LEAVES. IN THE SAME BOAT WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION TO EXPAND THE
GOLDEN STATE SENATE SAW
CALIFORNIANS ARE DON'T FILE
TAXES INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE
RECIPIENTS OF THE GENERAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM I DO MENTION
I'M SURE THE STATE'S BUSINESS
RECOVERY MUST INCLUDE MICRO
ENTERPRISES THAT OWNED AND
OPERATED BY COMMUNITIES WILL
NOT BEEN TARGETED THE PREVIOUS
FORMS OF- BIGGEST BUSINESS
ECONOMICALLY. BUT ALLY WESTERN
CENTER NICOLO HOLDERS IN OUR
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC
JUSTICE JUSTICE AREN'T A PART
OF THE SIDEWALK PREPARING YOU
FOR A PROPOSAL HAS BEEN MET BY
BECAUSE OF ACTION FOR STILL
NEED FOR THE CITY OUT OF LOS
ANGELES TO ALLOCATE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO STREET
VENDORS BUT GETS OUT IN THE
FORMS OF ECONOMIC. DEBATE THANK.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MAX THE LOCAL TO LINE ONE
PLEASE I HAD. GOOD EVENING
CONTACT US FOR FAIR WAGE. IS OF
BEING THAT IN HIGH ROAD TO IS
THE OF CALIFORNIA WORK FOR
DEVELOPMENT. WE THE FOCUS ON
RECORD THE INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE OF
COLOR INCLUDING IMMIGRANTS TO
NOT ONLY FIND ENTRY LEVEL JOBS
THAT HAVE POLICIES IN PLACE
WITH THE EMPLOYER TO ENSURE THE
CAREER PATHWAYS TO ALL THE BEST
PAYING JOBS IN ALL SECTORS.
WISER WAGES FOCUS ON THE
RESTAURANT SECTOR AND WE'RE
EXCITED TO WORK WITH THE BOARD
AND OTHERS TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF
RACIAL JUSTICE AND GENDER
JUSTICE IN OUR INDUSTRY THANK
YOU. MAXIMO CAROLINE ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OPERATOR LET'S MOVE ON IF
THERE'S SOMEONE ON THE LINE
NEXT COLOR. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS
MATTHEW CAN'T HE- I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF UNITED WAY TO
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE KELLY
AGENCY COALITION AND ALIGNMENT
BUT THE SECOND CALL COALITION
AS WELL- I WANT TO ASK WHAT THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
MADE ABOUT EXPANDING THE
STIMULUS PAYMENTS TO-
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE EXCLUDED.
FROM THE FEDERAL STIMULUS AS
WELL AS STRONGLY CONSIDERING
REPLACEMENT AS WELL-
SPECIFICALLY I'D LIKE TO THINK
THAT IT'S A STIMULATE PAYMENTS
WERE EXPANDED TO EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS- PER ADULT AND
CHILD AND I CAN FINALLY
FAMILIES UNDER SEVENTY FIVE K.
AS WELL AS THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
PER UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS WHO
DOES NOT HAPPEN I TO YET IT
WOULD NEARLY MAKE UP IT WOULD
MAKE A FOR NEARLY ALL OF THE
FEDERAL SENATE PAYMENTS THAT I
WOULD MISS OUT ON THIS PAST
YEAR- THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND
CONSIDERATION. AND I LOOK FOR
SPEAKING. ALONG FUTURE ABOUT
THIS THANK YOU. MAXIMAL TELL I
KNOW ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL I KNOW I KNOW MINE IS. THE
HEAD HELLO HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. HI MY NAME IS OAKLAND I'M
CALLING IN FROM LARKIN STREET
YOUTH SERVICES AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF YOU COULD STAND IN
HOMELESSNESS IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND ACROSS THE STATE. WE ARE
RELIEVED TO SEE A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SATISFIED IN
THE TRUMP ALLOCATION THIS IS
THE START I NEED TO ADDRESS OUR
STATE CRISIS VIEWS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. YOU KNOW THAT
EVEN BEFORE CO THAT ONE OUT OF
EVERY THREE YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE U. S. BUT
BY THE CALIFORNIA AND WE KNOW
THAT THOSE NUMBERS HAVE ONLY
INCREASED OVER THE PAST YAR.
WE NEED INVESTMENT THAT WILL
TRULY NEEDS A CRISIS
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT TO
PURCHASE ME HAVE HOUSING. FOR
YOUTH IS ONLY THE START WE
ALSO. I THINK THE SERVICES
BECAUSE GETTING A YOUNG PERSON
WITH A PLACE TO LIVE IS ONLY
ONE OF THE PUZZLE. WHEN PEOPLE
BENEFIT ENORMOUSLY FROM
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT HEALTH
WELL BEING PART OF THE
PERMANENT PATHWAY OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS PLEASE ENSURE THAT
THE STATE INVESTMENT INVESTMENT
IN YOUNG PEOPLE. ADEQUATELY TO
PROTEST THANK YOU. MAX CAROLINE
ONE TWO ONE. ONE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MY NAME IS THE NAME AND
I'M EXACT DIRECTOR THE CORD
AFTER. AND I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
THE TWO FIFTEEN MILLION FOR THE
ELEVEN CALIFORNIA POINTS AND I
BELIEVE THIS ALLOCATION REALLY
HELP- ADVANCED STATE PRIORITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO ANGELA 50% OF
THEIR REVENUES AND WE WILL USE
XML EXPANDING TO AVOID LAUGHTER
THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS AT THE
PORT WE WILL REIMBURSE OUR
TENANT RELIEF MEASURES.
INCLUDING BAD PREGNANT WE HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED BUSINESSES MANY
SMALL FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES
MINORITY OWNED COOLEY PROVIDED
TENANTS BEFORE. WE WILL
REIMBURSE SUPPORT FOR SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS PROVIDED- TO.
ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN OWNED
BUSINESSES AND OTHER L. BE EASY
AT OUR WATERFRONT AND WILL
RESTORE OUR MAINTENANCE BUDGET
TO KEEP OUR WATERFRONT ST
TAXATION PARTICULAR OUR CAPITAL
BUDGET IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO US- AND WE'D BE FUNDED IT AS
A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
I'D LIKE TO APPRECIATE YOU FOR
YOUR DEEP AT WORK THIS EVENING
IT'S VERY IMPRESSIVE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THEY YOU
NEXT PLACE. MAXO TO LINE ONE
TWO FOUR PLEASE. WELL I KNOW
ONE TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY BE
NEEDED. MAXIMO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS SABRINA
THE FROM CALIFORNIA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF GOLDEN STATE
OPPORTUNITY WE ARE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES- LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND WANT TO
ADD OUR VOICE TO THE CHORUS
CALLING FOR EQUITABLE AND AS
GENEROUS AS POSSIBLE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS TO ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT OF FEDERAL COMPORTS. WE
ALSO WANT TO. BRING SOME
ATTENTION TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCLUDING EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH AND- FREE TAX PREP
DOLLARS BACK INTO THE BUDGET-
WE HELP REACH THE HARDEST TO
REACH FOLKS WHO ARE NOT
CONNECTED TO SYSTEM- THROUGH.
THE STATE WHO MAY NOT HAVE A
DRIVER'S LICENSE TO HAVE A JUST
OF GOT AND DO THAT. WITH LOCAL
COULD OR- WHO HAVE BEEN
THOROUGHLY. AND WE THAT THESE
KINDS OF PARDON ARE HELP FOLK
COME. INTO THE CAMPAIGN THE
GETS TO TALLY. THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT THE GOLDEN STATE
WHICH ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER ESPECIALLY TO THE LOWER IN
COOPER THING YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT TO ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE ONE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MA'AM CAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG. WE LIKE TO THINK THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE PRIOR
TESTING HOMELESSNESS FUNDING IN
YOUR PRELIMINARY PROPOSALS AND
THEN THE MAY PROVIDE. COVER
WE'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COLLEAGUES- CUT THE TRUCK
ALLOCATION TO SEE FROM AFAR PAP
THEM UP TO BILLION EACH YEAR
FOR TWO YEARS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU KNOW WHAT I DON'T WANT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
WOULD BE FANTASTIC ON BEHALF OF
AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
WANTING TO REGISTER STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE INFUSION OF
DOLLARS. TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS BUT WANTED TO
REGISTER SOME CONCERNS ABOUT A
COUPLE OF MISSING COMPONENTS
THE FIRST OF WHICH IS THAT
THERE SEEMS TO BE- A LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR COUNTY RUN
PROGRAMS WHICH NEED TO HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE SERVICES NOT JUST
TO THOSE FALLING. SHORT IN
HOMELESSNESS CURRENTLY BUT WHO
ARE AT RISK OF FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS A DEBT DEBT
ADDITIONALLY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE 25% MATCHING
REQUIREMENTS. BECAUSE DOT COULD
POTENTIALLY IN FRANCHISE
CERTAIN COUNTIES THAT ARE ILL
EQUIPPED TO- MEET THE NEEDS OF
THAT MATCHING FUNDING- WE
ADDITIONALLY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE- INSUFFICIENT AMOUNT
THAT WAS PROVIDED FOR LEGAL
AID- AND THAT THERE WAS NO
FUNDING FOR THE EQUAL ACCESS
FUND OR- EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. AND WE ARE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT A LACK OF
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THE COURTS AS THEY- ADDRESSED
THE WORKLOAD ISSUES ARISING OUT
OF THE OBJECTION MORATORIUM
FINALLY IT WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE
CONCEPT OF HIGH ROAD TRANSITION
COLLABORATIVE AND LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENSURE THIS PROPOSAL IS AS
INCLUSIVE AS POSSIBLE IT'S
VITAL THAT THE FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE TO A WIDE ARRAY OF
BENTLEY'S RAP INCLUDING
INDUSTRIES. HIGHER WAGES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND OF
ONLINE ONE SEVEN YEAR IS A-
GOOD EVENING THIS IS SHERIN
REPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN THE BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION. WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSALS FOR
MULTI YEAR TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TOWARD
SOLVING HOMELESSNESS AND IT
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR STRONG
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO CORPORATE
THE PROVISIONS OF AB SEVENTY
ONE BY THIS RECESSED THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME PROPOSAL TO
FUND ALLOCATIONS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AB SEVENTY ONE WAS
DEVELOPED BY A COALITION OF
OVER THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE CRAFTED A
COMPREHENSIVE CONSENSUS
PROPOSAL ON RESTRUCTURING TH
STATE'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS. AB SEVENTY ONE
AND BRING CALIFORNIA HOME WOULD
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY LOCAL
CORPORATION REDUCE
FRAGMENTATION AND STATE
RESPONSE EQUITY AND STATE AND
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS. IT
ADDRESSES CHALLENGES WITH HALF
AND BUILDS ON THAT SUCCESS.
FINALLY IT PROMOTES DATA DRIVEN
STATE AND LOCAL DECISIONS ON
HOW TO USE FUNDING. EXPERIENCE
SHOWS US THAT STEADY PROGRESS
IS ONLY POSSIBLE WHEN
GOVERNMENT'S PLAN WELL SON
SUFFICIENTLY AND TRACK OUTCOMES
CONSISTENTLY. THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET PROPOSAL OFFERS A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO CRISTINA
THOUGHTFUL STATEWIDE STRATEGY
TOWARD SOLVING HOMELESSNESS AND
AB SEVENTY ONE BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME OFFERS THAT STRATEGY. FOR
COMMITMENTS THIS YEAR AND WELL
BEYOND. ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY CHIU'S PROPOSAL TO
COMMIT TO OTHERS THE STATE WILL
STAY IN PRISON CLOSURES TO PAY
FOR HOUSING AND SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE EXITING PRISON AT LEAST
20% OF HOMES FALL INTO
HOMELESSNESS EACH DAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING ROBERT
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- I AM CALLING IN ON A
FEW MATTERS FIRST I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON- AN ITEM NUMBER
THREE IN THE EVENING THE
CIVICALLY THAT ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION RESEARCH TO HELP
WITH THE INSOLVENCY OF THE U.
I. FUND- WE APPRECIATE THAT
THAT THE STARTING POINT BUT WE
BELIEVE IT HIGHLY INSUFFICIENT
I WOULD REQUEST YOU TO BE
INCREASED- WITH RECENT
PROJECTIONS THEY REVISED THE U.
I FIND. IT'S PROBABLY ABOUT
TWENTY BILLION INSTALLED IT
WILL BE TWENTY FIVE BILLION
INSTALLED OR SO BY THE END OF
THE YEAR- AND THAT IS THE COST
WHICH WOULD STATE MANDATE ON
EMPLOYERS BY COME BY COMPELLING
EMPLOYERS TO SHUT DOWN- WE
BELIEVE BECAUSE THAT THE
STATEMENT CHOI COULD NOT IT AND
ECONOMIC FAILURE LIKE JAPANESE
GREAT RECESSION. THE STATE
SHOULD PAY A LARGER PORTION OF
THAT SIMPLY WOULD AT THE STATE
PAY OFF THE PRESIDENT TALKED TO
THE PLAYERS PICK UP FUTURE
EMPLOYERS WOULD STILL HAVE
ALMOST A GREAT- POTENTIALLY
HALF OR SO OF THE GREAT
RECESSION INSOLVENCY KERRY-
YOUR AT ONE MINUTE. THIRTY
AFFECT. THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT-
LIKE TO ECHO. AMELIA FROM
TRAVEL ABOUT. FOR THE FIVE
DOLLARS FOR TOURISM IN ADAM
FOUR. THANK THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. GUILDERLAND ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
SB CREWS WHICH CRUISE STRATEGY-
BEHALF OF SAN JOSE MAYOR
LICCARDO AND- THE BIG CITY
MAYORS COALITION THANK YOU
CHECKING UP THE APPLICATION
COMMENT ON HOMELESSNESS
INVESTMENTS OUTLINED THE
GOVERNOR THEY REVISE THOSE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT CONSIDER THE
BUDGET PROCESS. OUR GRATITUDE
GOES TO THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SHOPPING THE
STORE COMPOSED TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND FOR YOUR
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH BIG
CITY TO SUPPORT THE ONGOING
INCREASED COMMITMENT TO HOW
MUCH SPENDING AS OUTLINED THE
GOVERNOR'S NEWLY REVISED
HOWEVER WE URGE YOUR CONTINUED
READERSHIP TO SUPPLEMENT THE
TROUBLING. BECAUSE BY THE
GOVERNOR AS OUTLINED IN THE
ASSEMBLY BLUEPRINT- TO INCREASE
THAT AMOUNT INITIALLY REQUESTED
A DIRECT ALLOCATION OF FLEXIBLE
FUNDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WHICH YOU'VE BILLION PER YEAR
FOR TWO YEARS UNDER EXISTING
HALF GUIDELINES THE FORMULA AS
YOU HEARD FROM OTHER- THE
REPRESENTATIVE STEPHEN- THE
STATE STREET INVESTOR HE
HAPPENED HOME KEY HAVE HELPED
CREATE MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND
BACK IN OUR CITY CERVANTES CHAU
TO MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND ON
HOUSE RESIDENTS FOR THESE
REASONS WE- URGE A DIRECT
ALLOCATION- COMMENSURATE WITH
THE MIND OUT CASTING AT. THANK
YOU AGAIN CLEAR. LEADERSHIP AND
PARTNERSHIP. CAN CALLER. THANK
YOU WILL TO LAW ONE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH APPLE.
STREET ASKING FOR SHIPPING FOR
A BI AND I. COULD NOT HER CARTS.
EMIGRATE TO. TRYING TO DISTRACT
HAS BEEN THAT OUT AS- THE
REQUIREMENTS WITH TRAINING IS
JOB PLAY. WHICH LATIMES THIS
INDIVIDUALS CANNOT MEET BECAUSE
pOF PAST CRIMINAL. RECORD YEAH.
FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU IN MY
STRUGGLE ME TO COMMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
YOUR NEXT GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU HELLO MY NAME IS ELEANOR
TAURUS REPRESENTING THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR CALIFORNIA
PORT. BUT A LOT FOR THE FIRST
PART OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
THOUGHT UNPRECEDENTED THAT THE
CANCELLATION. SO EVEN WITH A
DRASTIC UPSWING IN CARGO
VOLUMES THE LATTER PART OF THE
YEAR WE EXPERIENCED A LOSS OF
OPERATING REVENUES OF THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FAMILY FURLOUGHED
EMPLOYEES. PURPORT OPERATING A
MOVIE IMPORTING GOODS LIKE
VENTILATORS AND PP WE EXPENDED
MORE THAN FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
TO KEEP OUR WORKERS STATE.
INCLUDING HOSTING A TESTING
SITE WHICH SERVE MORE THAN
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE.
TO DATE CALIFORNIA PORTS HAVE
NOT SEEN A TON A TON OF RELIEF
FOR CALL THAT COST. THEY KEPT
CALIFORNIA AND U. S. GOOD
MOVIE. WELL WE HAVE SEEN AN
UPTICK TECH AT CONTAINER PORT
ARE TELEPORTING GAUGE IN THE
CRUISE AND TOWARD. THREE ARE
STILL SUFFERING AND HAVE LOSSES
FIVE TIMES GREATER. WE WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
OF THIS MUCH NEEDED RELIEF. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. QNX COLOR. THANK
YOU ABOUT LINE ONE TWENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD REGION
WITH OUR CONTRIBUTE SERVICES
WHATEVER CISCO- I JUST WANT TO
ITERATE- OUR DEEP APPRECIATION
FOR THE EFFORTS TO ON USE. IN
THE GOVERNOR'S HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL- WITH THE REPORTED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN PROJECT HOME
KEEPER USE. WE ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT
NONPROFIT AGENCIES DIRECTLY
SERVING YOU- ARE ABLE TO
DIRECTLY APPLY FOR THE FUN. OF
IT WE ALSO STRONGLY- ENCOURAGE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES- TO. ENSURE
THAT YOU ARE NOT ONLY CAN
OBTAIN HOUSING BUT ALSO CAN
MAINTAIN AND SUSTAIN THAT
HOUSE. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU NEXT
COLOR. EMBARRASSED WE HAVE FOR
THE PUBLIC COMMENT QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATE. I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS FOR PARTICIPATING
IN TODAY'S- BUDGET SUB FOR
HEARING AS WELL AS FAR AS WELL
AS OUR STAFF THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH THIS A HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.